hello I'm web Dave host of outbreak
Gamers and Gamers Council thanks to the
iron Lords for giving me a chance to
give you my predictions for the Showcase
let's see I think there's going to be
some money and welcome past Day One
games announced and uh maybe even a drop
one at the show which would be awesome
and then I also believe that they are
going to announce that game pass family
plan is going to drop during the
Showcase and we'll be able to jump on
that right away let's see crazy
prediction maybe a shadow drop of Forza
Motorsports
I also think that maybe Killer Instinct
2 might get announced uh hopefully we're
going to see some Fable gameplay maybe
some in-town progression and maybe you
know showing some of the game mechanics
and the fighting mechanics in the game I
think that'd be awesome and then I think
we're gonna have uh some Contraband
gameplay uh maybe a small amount of
Perfect Dark will there be some you know
maybe some gameplay but at least maybe
more of a concept of exactly you know
what we can expect out of the game
hopefully let's see and then uh maybe uh
maybe a three to four new game
announcements that we haven't heard of
before hopefully with some CGI trailers
and then um I think they'll wrap things
up with hellblade 2 Gameplay a release
date for this year a 2023 and then when
the Showcase starts for Starfield I'm
hoping they announce 60 frames per
second on the series X
fingers crossed let's hope dreams do
come true
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's up I am Lords
Xbox community
Xbox game showcase man my predictions
got a couple
that's why I want Xbox to do knock it
out the part
put the nail and the PlayStation coffin
gotta show hellblade too
It's gotta look awesome
and it has to have a release date and I
think they'll do that I think they'll do
an October 27 2023 release date I think
help late too it's gonna look good
enough it's probably gonna steal the
show
uh uh star field they have to show
and it has to be confirmed to have a
performance mode at 60fps and it just
has to look good uh I trust Todd Howard
I trust Bethesda
um and I'm not even the biggest fan of
their games but as long as star field is
the game that Bethesda fans expect
they're in good hands
uh
about
um this is supposedly the game that you
know Xbox was very happy with during
your acquisition of uh obsidian and I
think avowed has the opportunity to be
that Elder Scrolls game we get while we
wait for the next Elder Scrolls game and
maybe you have petition to be better
maybe they surprise us with some
gameplay and a release date window for
early 2024 think that will go a long way
um
we all seen the things they've been
doing on Twitter we all expecting Fable
and I think they show up with Fable
vertical slice of uh something
impressive something in engine in game
that Forza Tech and maybe this is a
holiday 2024 release maybe they tell us
this 2024
and fortunate Force has to look great we
have to get that final release date I'm
hoping for to sooner rather than later I
think it probably releases maybe a month
after uh star field or maybe a couple
weeks after Starfield uh and we need for
uh we need Forza to show off that Xbox
series X power 4K 60 with Ray tracing
in-game think it's gonna do that and so
a few surprises man I expect uh Xbox to
show off some major Japanese support
some more day one game pass games maybe
uh Persona 3 remake maybe who knows man
maybe GTA 6 shows up on Xbox stage but
at the end of the day Xbox needs to come
hard uh they need to become heavy their
first party has to show out their games
have to show we have to see gameplay and
we have to see release dates and I think
Xbox and Bethesda will execute on that
and I think we're going to be looking at
a very very promising showcase and I
think you all will be excited for what
we see and yeah hopefully we all enjoy
it man but that's my predictions for the
Xbox game showcase and I think we're in
for a great one
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so what do I expect for the Xbox
showcase coming up here on June 11th
well it's it's pretty simple for me we
know we have the Starfield direct so
star field will clearly have a heavy
presence with a full Deep dive into what
that game is going to be but for the
Showcase proper
I'm looking forward to titles like
hellblade 2 hopefully with a release
date for 2023 we know we're going to get
Forza Motorsport with a release date for
2023. I'm also thinking of titles like a
vowed which maybe a 2024 title I'm
thinking of something like Perfect Dark
we've obviously seen some of the hints
and rumors towards Fable which I'm not
expecting anytime soon but it seems like
it will have some type of presence here
at the Showcase I'm also looking forward
to
what is
what is in Exile working on there's been
rumors about them potentially having
some type of RPG so looking forward to
that what is compulsion games working on
rare with everwild I'm looking forward
to seeing what that is going to actually
be
um
I I would also think some of their
Partners as far as like an indie title
goes I expect replaced to be at the
Showcase I think back to last year
during the extended showcase where we
had the excellent video kind of
highlighting
um what the the team that's working on
stalker 2 has been going through with
the war in Ukraine so maybe we get an
update on that and hopefully we do get
stalker too here this year in 2023
I would also expect there will be some
surprises that we're just simply not
expecting I mean on my wish list I I
would hope to see something like
Banjo-Kazooie but none of that is
Promised but I just think overall with
the Xbox showcase I I do expect them to
to come out swinging I expect them to
show that first party lineup all these
20 plus Studios give us some insight
into what they're working on along with
some of their third-party Partners as
well we obviously know Day One on Game
Pass we know there's the Kojima aspect
to this there's a lot that Xbox can have
here on June 11th in their showcase and
then as I said at the top ended with
that Starfield direct so it's going to
be looking good I I have a lot of
confidence in it um yeah let's see Xbox
showcase those are my predictions
here you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's up everybody doc dog dog within
A5 there's levels to this messed up my
freaking cord shout out to my dude
addict he hit me up on Twitter and he
said he uh doc can you make a one to two
minute video of what you want to see on
the Xbox showcase
yet yes I can at it yes I can and this
is going to be extremely simple okay
first of all understand that we um
are still here holding the line very
strong and it's very easy after the
PlayStation showcase it's very easy you
have to Ratchet and Clank go into PC
it's very easy after that freaking
handheld joke that the PlayStation is
doing so it's very easy to hold the line
but this is what what I want as an Xbox
fan what I want to see at this showcase
okay
number one
everything that they show
they better show running on an Xbox
series X
I I don't want to see any PC gameplay I
know this stuff can run on PC but I want
to know what my console can do that's
that's number one
number two I want something that's going
to
blow my mind show me something that
looks beautiful show me the true power
of the series X that's that's number two
number three I want to see everything
that you show better have a release date
if you don't have a release date don't
even show it if you don't have a release
date don't even show it we went a whole
year without things dropping now we just
we want actual release dates okay and
last but not least I
I'd be lying to you if I told you that I
wasn't a fan of controllers it's it's
one of my gripes it's one of the things
that I have so show me a new controller
doc dog went on a Father's levels to
this we out peace
please
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's good everybody it's your boy Jack
move man first of all shout out to the
iron Lords podcast man you know I'm rock
with y'all boys man so y'all want to
know a PlayStation fans perspective on
this Xbox showcase coming up
uh simply put man I feel like and I'm
not trolling I feel like Xbox has a
golden opportunity to really capture the
my share of Gamers the hearts of Gamers
right this could be a real magical
showcase I feel like they um I hope they
deliver it's a couple of games I want to
see personally uh some games they
announced like last year year before
that whatever uh Contraband I would like
to see an update on Indiana Jones uh
Perfect Dark I want to see how that's
coming you know the main game I would
like to oh another little little game I
don't know if they canceled this game I
know had a little bit of legal trouble
or whatever the last night you remember
the last night they announced it a
couple years ago a little side scroll or
uh cyberpunk hotline miami-ish looking
game they look really dope to me I hope
that game is still uh alive and well I
would love an update on that game right
the main game I would say I'm really
looking forward to and I really want to
see and it needs a release date we've
given these people Amber opportunity I
believe this game got announced December
2019. it's coming up on four years
people
um hellblade 2. definitely want to see
hail blade too and we need a release
date I wouldn't even say we need more
gameplay a cinematic trailer or do hey
I'll put a picture up there but we need
a release date okay definitely looking
forward to that game
and um as far as me I would say that's
what I'm really looking forward to for
the Xbox showcase now what I think they
need to show in addition to what I just
named we need a Halo infinite update
right I'm not a Halo player but that
Community seems like they want they want
to know a road map a true road map man
you can't be a game service not have a
roadmap you also can't be a game service
and abandoned Community or development
after two years so what are they gonna
do with that of course we're getting
fours or that's no need to even talk
about that
and uh one of them another thing I want
to see no broken promises try your best
not to lie to the people
last year they said every game we show
you is coming out within the next 12
months
and they did not keep their word with
that I believe only pentiment and
um red ball came out so that's that's no
bueno that's no good in my opinion
but Xbox like I said they got a golden
opportunity they got a lot of games they
can show
and I hope this is uh I know it's
probably not gonna be heavily uh first
party you know you got third party deals
or whatnot
but they they they've made a lot of
Acquisitions and I think it's time to
show improved for a lot of those guys
right
so uh I feel like they got a golden
opportunity man like I said hopefully
it's impressive hopefully I get a reason
to renew my Game Pass right my game pass
run out of August y'all can I be honest
with y'all I ain't never paid more than
a dollar for Game Pass not ahead the
thing about three or four years
but if they show me something that I you
know it tickles my fantasy I might have
to renew my game pass with my own money
I ain't never want to do that I'd be
lying if I said I want to do that
but I will do it I will do it but anyway
man like I said shout out to the iron
Lords podcast man I see y'all boys doing
y'all a thing over there and then with
jab move man so I don't know peace
thank you
[Music]
radio
a proclamation
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them when he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then that would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to get
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to an even
though I gotta be Neato I know it's my
destiny word to carnido who cares if he
flies he's still a mosquito you swear he
ain't something but really be Stevo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that joke King David still be the
king of the statue sister juvenile I've
been cursed with a curse to be Musical
and if you hate it we'll meet in The
Crucible other than nothing it's cool
and it's beautiful we let you know that
your dreams are pursuable whatever you
want to do then it's doable if you got
work on a Sunday it's suitable cause you
can listen to this and you're cubicle on
the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord day
radio
[Music]
Mike's about to be hot over here with
this Slayer
I do not know what to do with my hands
right now
you're on the coincidental list
it is gonna be a wild show today already
see little quick mic checks from the
legendary guess let's start with plume
can I get a mic check sir can I get a
mic check mic check mic check one two
three yeah that's what I'm talking about
kid in the building can I get a mic
check my check my check yeah yeah yeah
the ghost can I get a mic check mic
check one two
a little bit a little bit more a little
bit raise them a little bit more ghosts
my check one two all right ghost face
and of course the million dollar man
what's going on let me get a mic check
shouldn't this be done pre-show is this
is this a real podcast
I've done I've done so much podcasting
this week
I'm losing it we got five hours on you
today no sir no sir
give me that five give me that smooth
[__] [__] oh man all right here you hear
you and we are professionally live right
welcome to the Arlo's podcast LLC and
also live on lordsgaming.net episode
number 307. it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's date I'm extremely excited for
our special unique Minds assembled and
we've got the Xbox game showcase
prediction Series yeah that's right baby
stop yeah baby oh yes Darfield direct
people seem to forget about Ratchet and
Clank Rift apart PC to discuss that
someone forced this topic on an Xbox
showcase but anyway we're gonna get
Creator is very well deserved for his
balance and research takes combined with
a genuine passion for Xbox and the
entire games industry
introducing the creating host of the
plume Network YouTube channel
the Lord of logic and reason and one of
the Realms most highly requested guests
live from Canada and making his debut
into the realm of the Lords Marvin Lord
plume Network how we doing sir
I'm I'm doing great man I'm happy you
guys think that I'm the Lord of logic
and reason I appreciate that some of the
some of the comments I read on my
channels don't think that but but I'm
excited to be here man this is awesome
on probably the best podcast out there
oh I think and uh I'm ready to get going
talk about Xbox and then everything's
gonna be great no no excited for the
Showcase sir
is going on in here yeah okay cheat code
radio oh okay I see what's going on I
see what's going on no the probe is the
man anyway
[Music]
once we have a lord who is no stranger
to the realm of the IOP and represents a
distinct combination of informative game
news but is always willing to get messy
to talk his talk he knew this was him
introducing the creator of the dirt
grickety YouTube channel co-host of the
attic show and the host of the wbg Xbox
podcast
the Lord who still bleeds green with the
most head-knocking intro music in the
game
that's fine I don't care nobody live
from Detroit and making his return into
the realm of the Lords my man Lord Dirk
griggity how we doing sir man that
introduction man thank you brother I
appreciate it man I am back in the realm
again you guys are awesome thank you for
inviting me and uh I'm excited for next
Sunday uh the 11th and I'm ready to talk
about it brother let's go yeah that's
right it's that time it's that time good
to have dirt in the building and of
course we have a lord who not only
exemplifies pure professionalism as a
content creator but also gives proper
Spotlight to the true heroes within our
games industry and it's the expansion
every Xbox gamer needs these to
subscribe to
introducing the creating host of the
Xbox expansion pass on YouTube and
iTunes plus co-host of the cast Co-op
podcast
the Lord of insightful interviews yet is
still willing to go to change.org on
behalf of the community
from North Carolina and making his
return into the realm of the Lords my
man Lord insept ghost how we doing sir
oh my gosh that was an intro brother I
am good I am excited we are a week away
from uh the Showcase I do I could not be
more honored to be here feels good man
let's go
and now
rounding out this starting lineup is the
Lord in front of the realm who
absolutely needs no introduction based
on pure gaming reputation alone with
over a million reasons to be invested in
the Xbox ecosystem as a model of
consistency and Sage wisdom throughout
Xbox's Wheel of Time
no I did no I did
introducing the creating host of the
Rand out Thor 19 YouTube channel and the
co-host of the Xbox 2 podcast
the Lord of honest Xbox analysis
referred to as the other guy on Xbox
rumors and rightfully educated Lord Cog
on proper Chicago Tavern style pizza yo
that Illuminati that joke is fire live
from the south side and Xbox's with the
city assassin making his proper return
into the realm of the Lords my man Lord
ran down 19 how we doing sir
we're doing pretty good Cog it's uh it's
always a pleasure to be here in the
realm of the Lords and uh
you gotta we gotta we got a big show
planned and next week is uh I feel I
feel pretty good about next week and
we'll talk about all this episode I'm
glad King is here I missed him last week
I I do apologize I'm kind of happy I
wasn't here last week because
if I would have heard something that I
heard after I heard it boy internet
would have been on food it doesn't
matter we you know exclusives don't
matter now we get
but we don't like that no more I see you
try to get extra ones
yeah I got you dudes because exclusives
really don't matter oh man this guy
right here but how excited are we for
the Showcase friend well we excited I
mean I'm excited I'm always excited you
know Xbox is out here teasing no uh
temper expectations no no hold the lines
trending yeah the line is definitely
doing something good we good different
out here
salute salute you know what I'm saying
so everybody know we got the four
horsepower game I think we got the four
but one is missing I believe
he's he's in route
The Raven has been sentenced
our brother retrieve our brother no
doubt but of course we have all those
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also that's
the Lord of clarity and Lord Patriot of
the iron bank PC Master race his own
Lord Sovereign how are we doing sir I'm
doing very very well I'm rested that
won't last for long but I'm rested
I'm good man good girl yesterday got to
got to go to the movies yesterday and
see Spider-Man across the spider verse
POG was not able to join us I know I had
to save myself for today yeah
exactly so that's fine I'm telling you
right now
that's an old timer yes that's an
all-time I have never
these two movies these two animated
movies along with no way home sell it
have never these are the first time that
I've really seen the idea of
for Spider-Man to become Spider-Man
there are certain things that have to
happen to them a certain tragedies that
have to go through for them to become
who they're supposed to be and they
threw that on its head a little bit they
they showed you they showed you the
process of spot of Spider-Man going
through that right in addition to
turning it on his head and saying
something different and how do you react
to finding out something is different
and
I've never seen an animated movie with
more heart
but the only thing that pissed me off
about it is it and this isn't a spoiler
it it leaves you in a place there's more
to come okay okay yo I'm gonna tell you
oh my God I saw it on Friday I took my
son immediately picked him up from
school I was racing through time to get
there and
well it's greater than the first movie
yes that question is greater than the
first movie I thought the first movie is
more remembered for post Malone song and
you know when you hear that song you you
have the correlation with Miles Morales
this movie
is an uh an Ascension of a young adult
growing into his manhood and it's also a
young woman
uh growing into her Womanhood it's it's
a dichotomy of two individuals growing
but they also link to each other and
there's certain lies that we say that we
don't uh talk out loud and it's
approached in this movie but the movie
is done in such a manner that they took
the basic elements of Spider-Man and
like Saab said flipped it on its head
and showed you a new facet of it that
you never saw coming but it feels so
familiar and waited they did it it's
iconic in that sense and and this movie
is is so black and brown Rich salute it
is a beautiful thing it's a beautiful
thing yo Spider-Man look Puerto Ricans
and then we use this little language in
Spanish
it's amazing it's amazing it's amazing
pun intended go see it um beyond that
yes yes yeah
story you can oh
King is back to granddaddy he is back in
the building and oh my God so very
quickly I know we have a lot of people
yes yes we do um I didn't really get a
chance to play much of anything else I
fell to the fomo thanks to kaibatsu of
just System Shock I wasn't gonna get it
right now but I'm gonna get it uh I
gotta talk to Maddie Maddie I think got
the impression that I disliked it and I
never got to elaborate on my points so
no it's great
um I needed to play more I have not
Diablo installed well
you're installing okay cool it went
great it went great I would play that at
some point but Street Fighter all right
no no doubt every yes they they went in
another Direction they took it back to
the essence they made it so it's
accessible to so many different people
um as opposed to Street Fighter 5 which
is really just about you know sort of
going the Esports route and it was very
light on elements that console players
like this is a completely different
direction they have the world tool more
which is essentially an RPG kind of like
Yakuza light but Goofy and stupid and
crazy um then you have obviously the the
arcade modes and stuff like that and
that's all very goofy and stuff it's not
as in-depth as a Mortal Kombat probably
never will be and that's cool but the
fighting is so good
um the the game changer this time around
is that street fighter has always been
difficult to manage for you know casual
players because there's so many meters
to sort of manage and here it's kind of
the same but they simplified it in that
for instance before you just had a super
gauge and then you could pick you had to
pick certain super moves you would you
would pick during each fight now the
super gauge is a level one two and three
you have three super moves one that you
could do at each level and that's it and
that's across the board so there's no
picking super moves it's just a matter
of how much Super gauge you have so you
don't have to sort of manage moves in
that way just have to be cognizant of if
you're at level one level two level
three which move you can pull off that's
it now the big game changer is the drive
mechanic the drive mechanic is another
gauge that essentially allows you to to
do perfect parries and do overdrive
moves which can sort of override other
regular moves right you can tell by it
kind of looks like a flaming sort of uh
effect and when the the Parry is like a
blue effect which it's a Parry that you
can hold
or to sort of block full combos now the
thing about the drive is that it also
allows you to apply that drive to other
special moves like your your Fireballs
your Your Dragon punches your your
spinning kicks things like that and make
them more powerful and give them certain
different properties the thing is that's
just one meter that applies to all that
stuff you don't have to worry all you
have to do is worry about managing the
meter because if meter goes all the way
down and it replenishes during the fight
so it's not something that you have to
really worry about losing and the meter
pull yeah exactly yeah it replenishes to
the top oh whoa
so yeah majorly replenish it too oh yes
I see what's good time on this street by
the time
I get messy you're timing it
yeah
continue yeah so that it is it is at
equal is equally as as in depth as any
Street Fighter game has ever been but
it's super accessible as well and I
think that's what street fighter is
missing Street Fighter 5. this is it's
back like it's back absolutely can I
jump in on that yes really quick I think
this is the best Street Fighter I mean
we recently buys I think it's the best
street fighters ever been wow um and it
allows players to enter into Street
Fighter thanks to the different control
schemes three different control schemes
depending on your skill set nice and uh
classic which is the sixth question
right Dynamic and modern and modern I
think is where a lot of people are that
are new are going to find their their
comfort level
um but and then those there's three hubs
that you can go into for different types
of Street Fighter kind of like in COD
where you get war zone you get DMZ you
get multiplayer campaign same premise
you can get so much from this anybody
that spends 60 bucks on this they've got
a game for them whatever that whatever
their interest is and I think Street
Fighter 6 is going to be very special
and it looks like so is Mortal Kombat
that's the cool part you know what I
mean it's not gonna be one or the other
this year
probably next year though I don't feel
technically are you on Vegas this year
tries to move slow and I think it is
crowded it is crowded yeah it is it is
super crowded but it would be what a
year what a year that week yeah that
would be insane that would be insane
Fridays bro no doubt no doubt and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the access gamer the prophet of
Xbox well I mean King of the statues who
defends nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the hold
the line movement
beloved kid upgraded how we doing oh my
God shout out to Clarissa Shields last
night
um she didn't get the knockout but she
put in such a beautiful uh palette of
work last night hugely an aggressive uh
Fighter for the whole evening scoring
Jabs right hands Hooks and uppercuts
throughout the whole fight um it was
something nice to see I wasn't calling
it yesterday because we have uh Tio
female coming up next and we all gearing
up for
Bud versus Spence and that's going to be
fighting decades hopefully it lives up
to the building I think both dudes got
dog in them and I think they really want
this
um I came up to the show today uh
playing a whip your head boy
a couple of reasons okay very aggressive
energy continue yeah but that that's all
started from Clarissa seals last night
because she was whipping heads they
saying I should upgraded also according
to General now is that is something I
should be considering well um
what I would say is
what's a general to a King
this is true this is true but today is
is all about being a Swami that's why I
have them on the Swami okay okay and
then Nostradamus
we have to do predictions of the future
yes and um what I've been playing this
week I've been playing fortnite yeah for
the frauds that say I don't play
anything yeah this is for you
oh buddy
so oh man
fortnite this week I found out this
little cheat code right all right so
they have this girl and they want you to
do this mission to get all this ice girl
stuff but it's like you got to get 50
levels to get all her stuff out and I'm
like 50 level I grind 50 levels that's
crazy I said they give you nine weeks to
do it right so I'm like damn then they
had another character in there and if
you purchase this character she comes
with this Quest stuff and the quest
stuff is uh you go up a level and it's
uh 40 levels that they can give you
every time you do her missions her
missions are so benign and so BS
okay all you gotta do is run through a
little gate and you go up a level so I
said oh this is this is this is it so
I'm doing both quests at the same time
and my teams they doing something else
they fighting for their life
I'm done with you I'm done with you
you're investing
and I'm running through Gates and I'm on
reels all over the town
dudes is cursing me out I got messages
in my my DMs what's wrong with you you
know no I'm not a noob but I went up my
40 levels in the moment with that all
right so I went back playing Jedi
Survivor Jedi oh the little tweaks and
twerks that they put in that we don't
have to download or do anything to I
love this console life I won't change it
for the world just come into my little
patches are there the game is running
phenomenal blue pero playing that okay
um I'm a beta boy oh you debatable you
boy what's your baby
I know what you baited I know what you
been I know what you broke your rule for
it
108 dragons
okay so I'm watching his stream the
other day and he's playing Diablo
and on God and them
in my stomach I said I gotta have this
game and I gotta have it now so I hit
solve up iron bar
give me my Hava
and the hammer will sit down
handle
set that package so I'll set that
package so I I downloaded right
and then I'm looking at the chat I
checked Sav is laughing
haha got you I said what the hell you
mean you're a beta boy that's right I'm
like I'm not afraid of nothing
I gotta say it like just I gotta say
diablo for b-town yes
[Music]
uh you know I was sticking to my rule I
thought the game release and when I said
when I went when I purchased it and then
it said um pre-install
yeah yeah
and then you had that moment
do you want to get down or do you want
to lay down
yo the
that game insane
briefly circus we're going crazy time
times
that's the first time in a long time
from our an RPG fan
that I said
they really don't need Square
what you mean like
I mean no it's blizzard though this
blizzard it's big yeah but yeah
you know that the big overarching Mark
to it if Microsoft gets a hold of
activists oh yeah and this is the home
of this game pass is friendly
very gay fast friendly it can really
start to lock out and and it's it looked
really scary best narrative so far
you can be merry let's just release
yourself over to the dark side
come on you release yourself and say the
words that you would be free yeah yeah
oh I absolutely love it so that's
exactly what I'm playing and you know
it's
I know Street Fighter is next yeah we're
going back to fight night Fridays but
this game is going to have a special
hold of me for a while oh no doubt look
who arrive might check my check make
sure he's good old enough for him he's
back can you hear me yeah yeah you sound
like a different mic though
it's a different one yeah I have to turn
on my zoom yes all right switching mic
so I can intro you properly sir
no doubt no doubt good to see him good
to see him I was holding up just for him
what about now Mike check down hello
yeah there we go and of course we have
my co-host with the comos my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conquer a lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man Lord addict
of the attic show how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh
Advanced
oh you got the my hero Academia okay you
don't even know what that is I don't
know what it is
we support the sponsor we're supporting
our sponsor that says that's what's up
you got the focus you know what I'm
saying a little Focus that's what's up
let's do it I don't know who that is
what we're gonna move on I'm sure the
chat does you know
Philadelphia feeling good sir quickly we
are everything all right we've been
playing
uh I played a little Diablo nice yeah
not a lot like it's been chaotic man I
even dropped Zelda oh
yeah yeah I don't know like I got to the
to the Third Temple and was like this is
the same stuff
oh oh oh sounds like you snut Game of
the Year for you
it sounds like the real tears of the
kingdom is coming from your house I'm
gonna be real with you this is the
definition of DLC
you know when I say careful they clip
it's not a bad game it's just you gonna
sit here and tell me that like every
time I go to a region it's exactly like
breath of the wild I go to point a to
interact with point B to go to another
location finish something there and get
the person in that region then I go to
another area go to point a to get to a
point B go to a region beat the region
and take the person with me and then
it's like it is literally more the the
same not is that is that like a bad
thing because breath of the wild has
like a really good uh format it's just
like Nintendo like I feel like they're
it they did it with with uh with uh
Pokemon it's like
I don't know why everything got to be
like open world now it's not open world
for tea maybe that's what it is no I got
this ain't Zelda fatigue
let me move on because I'm trying to
save you for yourself from the Nintendo
Community we don't do that smoke I don't
know what that's I mean that that's
that's what Zelda's gonna be moving
forward they said it I mean I play them
all but it's it's just
I want them to improve that that's what
I want like I love it I enjoy it I
really do okay I enjoyed a little less
after they patch the Duke glitch but you
know oh yeah the duplication it's just
like it just it's just frustrating you
know I love I I love Zelda I think this
zeld is a fun game but I'm not on the
whatever you guys the dopamine or
whatever it's over there
it's a great game it's definitely Game
of the Year Contender but okay there we
go
let me keep it because we are running
behind already and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself exactly the Shinobi
Lord Cognito spread that romance in the
Roman IOP and I'll tell you what you
whatever what you need then shout out to
Mr Maddie play shot to finally do and
the Xbox 2 we had our prediction damn
near Five Hour podcast go check that out
but it was a lot of fun Rand right it
was a lot of fun yeah a lot of fun a lot
of fun indeed always fun hanging with
the Dukes all right you already know
Dukes is gonna build their shout out to
no last word for me because I was trying
to protect my stomach situation and
what's going on with me and again real
briefly um thanks to the community thank
everybody for the love this week um
obviously for those who didn't know I
had a pretty scary ER situation where I
try to check myself in my condition was
deteriorating I did not know what was
going wrong with me so pretty much I
just you know sucked it up and you know
the Lord's doing because I was talking
to them and I just said I'm gonna go to
the ER see what's going on you know
thankfully they find out what it is
diverticulitis so I've been about to
become a zombie yeah I've been battling
zombie Club
of a bad lab but now I know what it is
you know what I'm saying I make a
necessary change short term the medicine
has got me a little crazy so apologize
for any podcasts I missed that I was
supposed to guest on but I'll try to
conserve my energy for the shows that I
knew I had to do was obviously Duke and
then obviously ILP of course last word I
owe you I will get it back to you uh
shout out to ebonte's Travis Scott Scout
for holding it down but I just want to
say thanks to community because I was
really in a dark place it was very scary
I didn't know what was going on and then
I had a lot of stuff going on in my
personal life and work life and it just
wasn't good so to see the community kind
of all hit together when I put the
picture pick up with the first pick was
a little bit too boring
I realized I think let me put a second
pick where people see me and I'm okay
and I'm coming out man you're like damn
it was wrong man what's wrong with cars
bro people yeah what happened to your
arm what happened what's going on people
thinking it was you know yeah like what
happened so yeah yeah now but I
appreciate it was like can he still just
give intros though
I'll be doing intros for the hospital
did he hurt his voice
thank you community for clearly
prioritizing what you care about Lord
Cockney keep the money maker intact
nah but people the messages the
community man y'all y'all made a brother
tear up and um it just goes to show you
one you know don't be afraid to let
people know when you're going through
something really serious and then two
just um focus on on the positive because
as much as down as I was the community
Lifted Me Up and yeah what you think of
thank God I wish it was the raw Galley
but we gonna move
you know until she show up you know she
said she the man till the main show up
no doubt as far as being not too much
gaming a little bit of dancing season of
course booted up that Diablo full say
what that is yeah
I am not about that title you not about
seasoning no no you don't want to go
play with me no no no no no no no
those PlayStation get them
like the nicest thing to me we're just
like yo I can't imagine the gaming
community in the world without you in it
that was love thank you so if you want
to get the um super chats and then we
can get going down hold on a second let
me see the last time if not I got the
long net just through some awards and
then we got to get going I got a couple
of copy paste go ahead do that okay log
that quickly it is that time of the
month shout out to Lords gaming.net the
amazing scribes that we have they
absolutely kill it month in month out
super proud of the team we out here
breaking records on traffic all type of
stuff want to celebrate one particular
Lord who went Above and Beyond in the
month of May we effectively call him the
Michael Jordan of like that when it
comes to them stats you know what I'm
saying he's described has been
consistently improved as a writer had an
amazing um interview with the nostalgics
president on the I believe the training
car Community which is absolutely
amazing just getting into a new genre so
the winner proudest winner latest winner
of the Lord dizzy long their scribe of
the month goes to Lord see you Nick
Chris Jones salute Chris Jones our
brother our Pax brother he obviously um
couldn't be here but he left a little
text a little speech that I could read
real quick he said oh did you expect
someone else all jokes aside it's a
great honor once again to be a survive
of the month the team has been killing
it this year motivated the Michael
Jordan of Loch net to try some new
things and step outside my comfortable
surroundings whether it was going to PAX
East where everyone except cargo myself
was like over six foot six
and if you're a president of the new TCG
and soon reviewing my first piece of
tech yeah he's got a hardware review
coming the Lord's gaming team as a whole
have a lot of good and big things
happening this year I guarantee you I do
for sure big shout out to the entire
team for killing it so far and it ain't
stopping no time soon it's like we the
95 96 Bulls Rand yes lognet and IOP are
absolute best gaming site podcast around
and like Diddy said we ain't going
nowhere you can't stop us because we
and of course we have our secondary
award this goes to our editors and
remember my brother-in-law dizzy giving
proper credit to the people behind the
scenes to edited the teaching lifeblood
of the site so this editor is an
informative asset to our team
outstanding ride a jack of all tradesy
he'd be breaking traffic all crazy right
now Call of Duty articles state of the
K2 updates so we probably present the
Lord dizzy lognet editor of the month
for May to our assistant
editor-in-chief Undead and Canada's oh
Lord Nicholas Downey in the building
salute Nicholas down you already know
Canon inability plume we got a lot of
representation Oh Canada we go hard we
go hard so his speech his speech right
quick he says I appreciate being
nominated for editor of the month
especially when it comes to our best
month ever for Lords of game dot net I'm
so proud to be such a small piece of
this amazing team that continues to
achieve so much Chico rate I see you in
the building is there he is he's got the
friends of brother proud of you brother
you are so start with the old candidates
in the chat yo get your people bro
yeah it's very patriotic
Mabel leaves it'll build this to your
brother Nick or did you think what up
see you that you did your thing so I'll
get the super chance let's get it
cap you go on one second because I think
I'm nice
I can't have the ghost out here dying to
go so limited time
okay so we have a Robert Kelly five
dollar Super Chat bless Sunday Lords did
anyone see a peek Peak fiction that is
across the spider verse uh amazed that
it almost topped the last one I think
they did top the last one
my movie theater is like 20 minutes away
so I don't I only go to like extra extra
no this is that this is that though I
wasn't expecting it but it is that this
is that uh HBO Max
we held the line General King what do we
do now hold down each sandwich
next week we will start to fire some
shots
so we have big news five dollar Super
Chat dirt yes sir fine yes it is yeah
it's good then we have Marvin ginyard
two dollar Super Chat let's save the
East Philly albino lombax
that's the rare animals that came out to
save the tropical Puerto Rican trial of
the snake last week
continue
man's gave Dita in the uh they're in the
chat yes yes
Dragonheart yo remember for one year
twenty dollar Super Chat peace love life
to the Lords hey dirt is it true that
when you became President when you
become president your first order would
be to rename nightmares to dirt man
I know it
make sure you get your residuals for uh
BLK Inc they're using your essence
Dragonheart man hey that hurt my
feelings bro
[Laughter]
remember IOP we're not an Xbox podcast
IOP before PlayStation showcase that's
it PlayStation showcase slash Nintendo
Direct crickets for an Xbox showcase we
need the Avengers for this
[Music]
ko3 black truth two dollar Super Chat
It's the Return of the King yes it is
yes he's back
and we have JD gamer remember for two
years hundred dollar Super Chat thank
you I appreciate that blessings brother
Microsoft if you're watching this create
your own this is how you share a game
moment please excite your base some exec
needs to wear a Hold the Line shirt at
the Showcase while saying for those of
you that held the line we have something
special then bang new IP this this is to
me textbook is what it should be
listening man see Aaron outside
I would absolutely lose my stuff Bros
crazy that kid
that would be crazy I mean that would be
crazy what I would say is this
um and it might be a nice surprise for
you to do it get it done because my man
Aaron out here doing work and my man
Aaron out here doing it again
I'm not gonna lie Greenie has held me
down personally facts
so much that is not really a surprise
that he's held us down publicly facts
the guy is 100 genuine he does so much
stuff
um and I know I'm hard on him sometimes
but that's just you know his marketing
aspect of it and you know because he
controls that thing but as far as having
a heart that dude A Heart and Soul on
Microsoft oh no doubt he outside yeah
for sure love you Greenie salute salute
what else we got solved I'm actually
gonna go backwards now I just copy
pasted one more so I don't want to go uh
Robert kill it five dollar Super Chat
man can't believe attic is so wrong
guess God of War and Spidey 2 will be
DLC too
God of War is yeah
you
had 35 years to play the same Zelda game
with the same formula y'all need to get
over it breath of the wild and tears of
the Kingdom all the goat Zelda games
yep
we got free R Kelly Two Dollars Super
Chat Kang Phil can't save you from Sony
domination
I hope on God first of all they can
dominate you all day
but I'm gonna tell you next week it's
gonna be so hurtful for you dudes when
my dude look over and you had your worst
show and he said good little show you
had over there
good good dude who's your dude sir good
way to kick off your little show season
real dominance back so it's really
interested
he's stiff Lord Phil now you guys are in
trouble I can't wait till next week I'ma
be so extra
y'all can make any video y'all want I'm
gonna be so extra that the video that
y'all make I'm gonna have the same
energy from beginning to end
from the ER introducing
that that's what that's when your homies
don't love you they pull you out in the
ER do the intro [__] imagine like the
doctor coming in introducing them
somebody get that damn mic away from him
nurse Becca
ah yo straight out of Florida State I
can't I can't continue song
Super Chat even bad zeldas get 90 plus
metas tears of the Kingdom hashtag not
my game of the year oh yeah okay then we
have King is overrated
I love that name
glad you went to the dot Cog us men need
to not be so afraid to look after our
health respect Cog in the hospital doc
walks in COG introducing
the colonoscopy get those done y'all
that's important 40 something to do take
care of business continue There we go
once again take care of business
continue yo somebody gonna go to the
doctor but y'all need that colonoscopy
because that's right
yo what's up
real quick oh I don't know what doctors
[Laughter]
tell me tell me you to go crazy it's fun
to bed where she was like coolito oh
that cool
yeah this is a children's movie that's
crazy continue
we have JD game remember for two years
fifty dollars Super Chat thank you once
again
Microsoft you got IOP and crew out here
holding the line do not disappoint it's
time for Microsoft to be the Beast that
they are time to send that little little
bully boy PlayStation home wondering
what the f just happened I'll tell you
what happened Banger after Banger after
Banger
what they gonna do they're gonna do what
back to back
yo whoever clipped you with that is I
can't front that when they got in the
clap he'd be like that
somebody get you crazy cliff and Drake
with him like this like yeah they need
to have a drink at your attic do it back
to back is literally the funniest thing
I've ever seen and it's like it was like
the way I did it's like back to back and
the hands it's the and the voice classic
classic continue song uh that we have
Spartan goes 17 two pound Super Chat
these Zelda games are just subpar
collect-a-thon
then we have Matt without fear member
for 16 months Lord silver glad you're
feeling better Carl get some Fiber in
your diet yes yes no fiber right now
high fiber later you know wait hold on
yes yes you gotta come on Cog shout out
to the over thousand people live in the
chat thank you wow enjoying the show and
the uh ILP make sure you hit the like
button for him please and subscribe as
well one of the best Xbox pockets
that's like his camera's off guys he had
two thousand so no we did three thousand
in our chat there his camera gotta come
on
shout out the Lord's a game with Gene in
the building continue so then we have uh
let me see let me see Mandingo mcdicken
for two years five dollar Super Chat do
my eyes deceive me who is that big hunk
of Darkness
what is this about I don't know this is
how it goes down over there
you missed it last week King but
somebody was talking about your
Chocolate Dipper yes yes you better be
careful there's somebody coming in for
yourself
yes I'll be there
please whisper the ad stay no ads today
unfortunately no ads today so I won't be
whispering that I'll I'll get in a
Whisperer too with these uh super chats
uh let me play with everyone's joysticks
needs a good time wow August 12th is
gonna be a great time type of day that's
hopeless salute
then we have tsws gaming member for two
months Lord gold not being available for
that statement I recorded last week was
criminal shout out to [__] for holding
the line in the absence of King Hold the
Line hashtag exclusives don't matter
yeah I ain't gonna lie
because that was your moment bro what
you mean oh you think so that was no
that was a moment it was a moment in a
way that we already know the
relationship that you would call him
right we also understood because when I
watch it I like
I like his effect on people he Big
Brothers a lot of people so people don't
know it and and I I watched a lot of you
guys go docile when he's talking
right and I'm just sitting here like man
oh God why did I have to miss today
uh-huh and when he said that you got a
wrinkle in your brow and he was like
wait a second hold on I gotta push back
on that
that's the spirit of King
you know I have that part of me in you
it's just what it is people want me to
be as demonstrative as you and I could
never match your energy that way so I
have to do it in my way so I'll smile
I'll smirk you heard what I'm like I
think I think everybody's eyebrows went
up like yeah I was like be careful
because I know how to be careful I know
how the Fanboys are gonna do the Fanboys
are gonna come so again
it was just it was a moment where you
could have and you couldn't but it was
that I saw it I saw the wrinkle little
brow I'm gonna give a little push back
and I just like yes thank you I just
appreciate you okay I appreciate it you
already know what's up continue we got
to move come on uh we got X dondeo Taco
we're not temp
for the promo for this podcast and
Twitter was my favorite he's like
temporary now when I found that trip I
said there it is that's what we use hey
that's how I feel
then we have dunk X dunk let's put the
crest in the chat but dunk X dunk new
member I gotta go for red red and black
dog eat that cogs boss on the other side
he can't go too far listen bro I
disagree with Colin all the time there's
tons of stuff we agree on there's tons
of stuff like this girl y'all know me
I'm just that is demonstrative of his
kingdom I want that yo what the hell you
talking about like I'm not that exactly
I would do that though I wouldn't do
that all right you wouldn't do that but
you you would clown you would go extra
and I don't think that's what it kind of
likes that yeah
if you notice when Colin came on he was
mad disappointed King wasn't there he
was like oh man I was looking forward he
loves that debate stuff for me I'm just
gonna do it in my subtle way and I'm
gonna smile and I'm but I'm gonna say yo
I'm gonna push back whenever you hear me
say I'm gonna push back I'm going in
that's it so anyway this is the waist
this is a style thing continue then we
have Jay Rembert ten dollar Super Chat
we bleed green shout out to dirt in my
fellow Chicago in the land do you
remember what's up bro salute bags
though
[Laughter]
Avengers United and IOP salute Players
let's get it as to your guests guests
and host indicative of a s tier podcast
salute the Lords and all hail the ILP
stations
thank you and then back to the chat we
have IMAX five dollar stupid chat Cog be
careful with that diverticulitis I had
uh two feet of my lower intestines
removed because of that back in 2006.
listen to the doctor no absolutely
absolutely there's the osis and then
there's the itis and yeah luckily it
caught it early so I'm making the
necessary changes because I don't want
that with that thank you thank you
brother
and we have Spartan 661 five dollar
Super Chat this is how this is going to
be an off the chain with the panel
members and chat yes yes
Corey Tidwell five dollars to protect
this is why you're worried about slow
ff16 pre-order it looks like maybe uh
looks like they me be getting they may
be getting that niggle wake-up call oh
come on don't do that
I know what you're doing I know what
he's doing I'm we gonna move on
yeah hilarious good God man sometimes am
I reading English sometimes in English
but I know where that comes from I know
where that comes from yeah
oh yeah okay
mine now
all right we got it we got it's about
damn time ten dollars to pretend I'm a
Sony guy but I feel like I've been
missing a good experience on Xbox so I'm
grabbing me an Xbox next one brother
hold the line on the top
let's keep it coming you got a new sub
here stay healthy and stay safe thank
you thank you so much appreciated
PlayStation
we got x x Abbott five dollar Super Chat
do I just tell the doctor to give me 15
off that colonoscopy with promo code IOP
yo I ain't doing it look if the bag is
right I may do okay you want me to be
the poster child live live on air
you're so cool
you see cargo gound up ready to go
no move it on continue I need the
microphone ah inappropriately sagging
nut sack 20 pound super chat I missed
the last couple of podcasts but I'm here
for this one I just finished the plagues
tale 60 frames and I'm so glad I waited
shout out to one on the panel and the
chat have a good one hashtag hold the
line hold the line no doubt that 60
frames very much needed solve your
favorites next yeah my buddy let's play
with each other's joysticks five dollar
Super Chat I'm glad you're taking care
of your health Cog SOB you should take
care of yo I'll give you a freak out
loud
I've been offering to give you a call
wow wow right now ILP has changed
I'm gonna need to see those credentials
first
oh man that man
anyway
moving on now we have a hearty Cindy two
dollars potential salute Brothers couple
of days until we're in L.A yeah I'm
getting my stomach right brother because
I gotta see you next week no doubt our
Geeks you already know yeah we got bad
did go big thickens two dollars Super
Chat I see the black Palpatine is also
on the panel chick David yes yes Mommy
then we got one pint Johnny yes papa
chat what's love Brothers what's love to
you appreciate that
and we have Cameron Hill camera for all
Cameron Hill yeah ten dollars to be chat
for all into the star field yes yes so
yeah we're gonna talk about it
JD gamer too can we get Colin and King
together I'm curious yes it will happen
on the show with him before yeah no we
got Hollywood rules five dollar Super
Chat on my way in to see Spidey will
listen later wishing best part a great
show exclusive don't matter huh I feel
better yo King Hold the Line
enjoy the movie enjoy the movie great
morning
then we got gbn aka the green blood
Network
that's the homie Dirk griggity is the
bot father love the soul gentlemen
salute to the iron Lords absolutely
appreciate that shout out to him that's
the homie man
then we have Robert Kelly two dollar
Super Chat ff16 performs under
expectations Phil Grant I just say Phil
be a penny with square okay okay it
happened good afternoon well as expected
Adidas 20 zero five dollar Super Chat
good Sunday dirt good Sunday dirt
brought me here what's up
what's up man no salute are we good are
we good sir we are finished are we done
all right I gotta skip the ball cause
we're just gonna be here so look we
gonna get into it y'all know what we
here foreign
that Xbox prediction series energy man
so let's talk about it I just want to
kind of start off before we do our
predictions I want to kind of start off
with kind of this state of Xbox in 2023
you know coming into the Showcase
obviously we know about 2022 the the
first party or lack of AAA first party
output obviously this year you know
still the ABK deal rages on right we
still got that going on so you get no
predictions just how we feeling about
the state of Xbox and I want to start
with the Elder States before I want to
start with a Randolph or 19. how are you
feeling coming into this showcase uh I
thought you're gonna start with the
ghost he's next okay he's next oh I
gotta I got I guess I got to be the one
to bite the bullet first huh how do I
feel about the state of Xbox in 2023
that's a loaded question because if
you'd asked me like before redfall I
would have been like pretty damn good
feeling really good about it uh
uh and then uh you know after redfall
was like um
feel not so good about it uh but as I've
said on Xbox 2 I feel like
redfall situation was a speed bump even
though we got a whole bunch of info from
Jason schreier this week yes about the
game and all those sort of things about
how the devs wanted to cancel but the
leadership wanted to do it and Xbox was
hands off just like Jess Gordon had
reported
um I still am really optimistic about
Xbox this year I feel Starfield and
Forza Motorsport will deliver hopefully
we find out uh you know if Hal blade is
coming this year or next year and the
Showcase if it's I mean they've had
their chances to temper expectations and
they haven't taken it yet right like
everybody's expecting Fable now and I
feel like if Fable wasn't there Aaron
Greenberg would have jumped on that
grenade
um so broke that down he was like I
don't know what a gay they think this is
so yeah I mean there was uh you know it
seems like I was riding high and then it
was like riding as low as possible after
redfall because ooh that game is
but you know I'm uh I'm still uh still
extremely excited about everything Xbox
is planning and and what they're going
to be doing on Sunday and the road map
that hopefully Xbox lays out for us and
stuff like so
um yeah just just just kind of a really
disappointing speed bump especially from
one of my favorite Studios uh out there
with Arcane like I was that's probably
one of my biggest gaming disappointments
ever
right next to Destiny and Bungie you
know so I know I know Bungie Destiny
right right [__] you know you know how I
feel about about that right if you saw
the active users but
anyways bro oh yeah
behave yourself I know what you're doing
but overall but yeah I feel I feel I
feel I feel really good I feel confident
um I like the direction they're moving
in and you know
um yeah I'll let somebody else speak no
doubt
let's get the ghost man because again I
gotta respect this time how are we
feeling this epic ghost you know coming
into this showcase no predictions just
yet but just to stay though it was the
state of Xbox for you right now Xbox is
in a unique position I think uh because
right now the Mind share is not in their
favor and I often push back on that just
a little bit uh because redfall tainted
I think what people think of Xbox first
party and rightfully so in the sense
that it was their first 70 pillar title
they marketed marketed it disingenuously
and such UH 60 frames that kind of stuff
yeah um but if you look at the series SX
generation output you've got flight Sim
Forza Horizon 5 uh infinite which
launched well Hi-Fi Rush pentiment Age
of Empires ghostwire Tokyo Minecraft
Legends you've got a lot of very good to
great games uh that launched and did
very well and they're very high quality
some of them are very Niche right like
Hi-Fi rush I adore that game but that is
a a rhythm platform game like that is a
unique Niche thing uh pentimate same
thing very high quality very Niche title
flight Sim Etc
um so I don't think Microsoft is in this
terrible state that some people might
have you believe they've done a very
good job they struggled with redfall
that was their big you know punch in the
mouth uh and they've got they got some
blood drip in there they need to show up
and show up well right right
um but they've done a lot of things
right and to rand's point uh that that
Fable tease and with the options and the
uh the amount of times they could have
tempered expectations
backed off they have not and correct you
know you look at Spencer's interview on
uh x-cast with Paris and such they
they did a Phil said no one should
believe me yet until you got your hands
on the game I feel good about your
showcase that was a man that was being
equally honest about the failures of
redfall so I think it's fair to trust
the honesty of the Showcase looking good
and I looked back at last year's 74 of
the games that were showcased in that
showcase came out and were day one game
pass looking good
um Game Pass Gamers have eaten well over
the last year and you look at the state
of Xbox they had some really high
profile third-party titles high on life
atomic heart that could not be
publicized due to like extra stuff
outside of gaming but but they've
treated uh their game pass members well
I feel like as an Xbox gamer I'm excited
going into this one they've done a lot
of things well that we should be
pleased and appreciative of I think okay
no doubt no doubt let's start with Lord
plume how we feel it man plume Network
state of Xbox how we feeling
I'm I'm very I'm very optimistic about
Xbox I know we are everyone's already
talked about redfall and how that kind
of put a bad taste into a lot of
people's mouths when that came out we
gotta think about it so far this year
right we're in we're in June the first
half of the year so far for Xbox I think
has been very good besides that speed
bump which was redfall you think about
what Hi-Fi Rush came out yes everyone
forgets that we got H2 on Console we got
Minecraft Legends
those are all first party games then we
got all the other stuff that came into
Game Pass like the whoa Longs
um that game pass since the beginning of
this year has been very very good so I
think going into this showcase
if we're getting what we are expecting
to be getting this year like there's
gonna be two more hopefully first party
releases coming out you got the
Starfield and you got Forza Motorsport
that's for brand new games that's five
first party games in a single year which
I think is absolutely phenomenal and I
think like the whole red fall discussion
just kind of put a a like set a bad
taste in people's mouths but I'm past
that so I'm extremely optimistic I think
like if we look at the previous
showcases they show off a ton of first
party content and if they do that
they're gonna knock it out of the park
especially now that they honestly don't
really have too much competition from a
showcase perspective they don't have
much to sleep
are you applying that uh something
happened prior to boasts their
confidence
I think I think PlayStation just opened
the door and said here take 20 20 23
it's all yours they can't leave an
opening they uncharacteristically left
an opening whether you like that
showcase or not I thought I found eight
games that I was excited about but
Bloom's right they left an opening that
is not to be dismissed and Xbox has not
stepped back from from taking that okay
is this the characteristics now
or is this the sooner that you will now
love
you're trying to say they reveal
themselves they have shown themselves to
be exactly who I thought they were
hahaha
I told you they are we thought they are
oh my God continue
no I'm sorry I think like the state of
Xbox right now you just take out that
whole redfall scenario that everybody's
been kind of piling on I think man
they're in a good position and they're
at that point already in 2023 if you
remember like Matt booty and Phil
Spencer talked about the fact that they
want to be releasing a game every
quarter yes so they're already if they
get five out in a single year even if
red Falls a blimp on the Raider I mean
that's pretty impressive from her first
party output perspective so I'm pretty
excited going to this show I can't wait
to see all the stuff they have to show
off no doubt no doubtless get my bids
gray kitty yeah I don't know he family
like one of those you get to wake with
the Lord
stay the Xbox man how is Dirk Gregory
feeling how you feeling about dicks well
you know I agree with everybody else I I
um
I agree with everybody else
um you know if you think about the start
of the year like plume said there was a
lot of positive momentum on on Xbox side
even though they didn't have much in
2022 the start of this year was pretty
solid with uh you know high five rushing
yes like everybody said rare fall was it
was a speed bump it was a stumble
um but this industry this gaming
industry isn't what have you done for me
lately right if you if you think about
all of the positive things about
PlayStation this year the sales and
everything else that's showcased because
it was lackluster it made a lot of
people say hey man what's going on with
PlayStation so saying that I'm saying
well Xbox if this showcase
is what we think is going to be can they
swing some momentum back in Xbox favor I
believe it can and um their road map
you know ever since 2020 we know they
announced a lot of games in 2020 that
were still far off it's three years
later meaning those games are getting
closer right
um so the road map looks incredible they
still have a lot of unannounced games
um that that we're anticipating so I
feel the state of Xbox is in a pretty
good State as as of this moment right
now because
um Phil Spencer you know the interview
with kind of funny games you can see the
frustration on his face his body
language she was a little upset about
the rare fall situation but like uh like
ghost said Phil was like yo you guys
know I'm just I'm telling you what I'm
telling you but it doesn't matter until
you guys play the game that line was key
I caught yeah it's like he sees
something he's like but no matter what I
say right now until it's in your head
that was a key point I do agree with you
absolutely so he's saying I think
there's some confidence there and like
he said I've seen it those are the like
that's the term he uh the uh the line he
used I've seen it these games that we've
been waiting for for a while and since
it's 2023 now I believe that future is
is super bright man and that's without
the ABK deal yet
um so yeah I'm very very optimistic and
very excited about the future bro no
doubt we already know let's take it to
the Lords I don't see if Alex is back
yet so if not we will move to Bro Lord
Sav man son of how we feeling State
Xboxes how you feeling coming in
yeah I mean we talked about like the how
what narratives can do to the sort of
the momentum of a of a platform and yeah
it started out great where you know
Hi-Fi Rush was a big surprise and you
know coming off of people with
disappointments sort of with the the the
end product of Halo right and then stuff
like that we were we didn't know what to
kind of expect we had an idea right we
had this conversation about if it's only
three exclusives this year it's an L
right and stuff like that so
um yeah I was excited after that and
then you know red fall red fall really
put a damper on that and it put a damper
on that not just because it's you know I
what I consider to be a triple a studio
making AAA games and that game was not
anywhere near any of that
um so that was very disappointed but it
took on sort of a life of its own where
it's like okay this this speaks to more
of what's going on with Xbox and maybe
that's fair maybe that's unfair but
again it just kind of felt like it just
it took the the wind out of Xbox's sales
a little bit but the truth of the matter
is you have Starfield on the horizon you
have it's supposed to hopefully is great
and then you have uh Forza which
hopefully is great and maybe we get one
more first party release this year so
again narratives sort of create moments
but at the end of the day that can all
be washed away with just great looking
games and games that that show gameplay
that make the base that makes the bass
confident and and that's what we're
going to be playing we're not seeing CGI
and stuff like that so uh you know I try
to I personally try to temper
expectations when I go oh well we type
her in um
no no no I I personally did you let me
finish I'm still in trouble
I want to hit you with the careful
I'm trying to save you before you do so
but the fact of the matter is
the fact of the matter is it's time to
show
it's time to show yeah it is it is time
and it's time to show in a real every
year we could we come in here boom he
said boom's not here this year but boom
will come out I want to see everything
under the sun yeah
I am with him it is time some of these
games some of these games that haven't
even been officially announced yet have
been in development long enough that I
just want you to jump the gameplay jump
to gameplay
I don't want to see the CGI trailer
introduction no you've been working on
it there's something to show you know
there's something to show
too much about Xbox's future to have
seen so little that's the problem that
that is the problem now right we know
their whole portfolio not their whole
but we know we know their portfolio and
it's time and some of it's been in
development for how many years we saw
hellblade2 to start the series X
Generation that trailer was fire on the
best level
and people have been expecting and not
being delivered on exactly right what's
up I I really it's time to honestly me
like you say [__] meet on the table it's
time to show yeah
a little time to show everything it
really is time to show everything
especially because like like ghost had
said
it's only stepped on a rake
very unforced error some may say had had
well Xbox set up to be knocked out as
king would say we just got our first
look at Jim Ryan's PlayStation
absolutely
and I gotta get I Gotta Give King his
props for that because King we clowned
him when we were like fast it's gonna be
you know I was nervous bro
traditionally traditionally it is a step
on the neck moment facts it's like you
just had red fall you just had you you
just had fill out there a lot of people
interpreting it it may be disingenuously
online right but but again you have fell
out there you know talking about you
know apologizing and things of that
nature it is usually in the past it has
been awesome the PlayStation takes to
absolutely go for the jugular and and
show everything they've got in the
pipeline for the next 20 years and
really and really just shut the door and
they did not do that and it was in the
King's Point King is usually hyperbolic
when he says these things or whatever
but he he the hangs 98 right it was it
was on the pulse it was hey at some
point all this stuff we've been hearing
about all this all this game is the
service stuff they gotta show it right
and they got to figure out a way to show
it and the fact of the matter is I said
okay and I was I was surprised that they
showed it and all we got was a jiggly
hamburger
no I I don't mean the CGI I don't mean
that gameplay what I mean is what I mean
is that they they put a lot of those
games in there together where I thought
they they'd give me one or two and then
give you the hotness that you expect or
whatever they didn't do any of that
um so I think it's time
if there's a jugular moment let's go for
the jugular let's go for the jungle yeah
shout out to my brother kid because he
he called it I mean me and addict we
talked about it coming in like we don't
know bro
let me tell you so right quick good
that's a as a channel that you know
talks trash what's up
I was nervous I was like it's been two
years of PlayStation man let me tell you
something my stream before the stream I
had so many PlayStation Fanboys in the
chat talking right yeah after that
stream not a soul
quick because yeah as dirt said
the morale was a bit low
morale coming after the de facto red
fall situation in the double whammy on
the CMA blocking
it was leak looking very spooky but
there was one man in the Xbox Community
there was one man that said I don't
trust them dudes them dudes ain't about
nothing and now we gonna hold the line I
was like I don't know King because two
years you know they got stuff in the
duck and that typical Sony energy let's
be real will have exclusives and things
we never heard about that have grown man
tears and everybody go oh
but there was one in
one laughing and clowning and telling us
how it was going to go and it was just
how you foresold it so King Hold the
Line General how are you feeling coming
into the state of Mexico
got to give him his balls
dude I'm selling my Xbox I'm running
I'm like you ain't got to tell me you
leaving the club buddy don't leave
I said yo that showcase you think you
getting ain't gonna be what you think it
is shut up King
you know how Sony do it's been two years
we're gonna give you two years of
frustration but weapons we're gonna give
you a kalana king Paul wow
I looked at you and said oh hell no no
oh hell no
you're gonna realize who's really the
doctor
I I'm the captain now
ah
the state of Xbox has never been greater
no it was when I first got on I told you
dudes I said Xbox look bright somebody
clowned me I had to get rid of your
generals this belt is from knocking out
all your YouTubers
all your favorite Twitter dudes and all
your favorite YouTube guys
and I told you man oh man I missed last
week I narrative ships oh what did I do
we don't need first party
because we all just get along
wait wait are you trying to say they
switching up now that's what you're
trying to say I'm gonna play nice when
we wanted to play nice y'all didn't want
to play with us it's like we brought the
basketball court
you're about to buy Spalding
this is the greatest just I'm so happy
now y'all talk about the state of Xbox
seems well
Game Pass I watch this show you know why
this show was so bad while this show was
absolutely so disgustingly terrible they
showed you whack games and said you had
to pay for them
so is that the game passes
they showed you nothing for your
PlayStation Plus foreign
and we're giving you nothing in return
and whatever we sprinkle in there you're
going to be happy with you're gonna love
it
yo this is why the game pass the Xbox
showcase is gonna be so great this is
why it's such a good place to be this is
why he's gonna go pick up his series X
or S this week and get ready for the
show
you know at least 50 to 70 percent of
those games is going in Game Pass oh
you know that no matter what
your Xbox the games will be played you
don't have to worry about that month or
I gotta balance
um
I don't have enough for the Wi-Fi oh my
God and I can't get into my phone bill
is due Game Pass got you boo-boo
lies for free
let's go I've never anticipated
something more this is gonna be a
one-way butt whooping it is such a
fashion because you know what it is the
PlayStation dude's dog
all right we got them now with this Red
Bull
I know this is why I love Jason schreier
yo let's go Jason took that weight off
my man
my man was holding his weight not
throwing nobody under the bus in fact I
told you about this was Prior stuff that
was coming down the pipe this I we was
trying to cancel it but these dudes
wanted to get it done we hands off on
that aspect he ain't seen none of that
if this was Jim Jim told his people
under the bus yeah Ben's Studios didn't
perform
y'all
are you applying the leadership styles
are different with bed with best studio
messed up they got snitched on they got
ratted on that's what we doing out of
there they're now black team we're gonna
put them in the back they're gonna
they're gonna run covert Ops
yo they gave them the letters to go to
Brazil and snitch
yo bang Studios hand in the snitching
report
you ain't working on a newton game nah
he sent me to Brazil
so no more days gone we we got a new
role for them days gone is gone and this
is what I'm talking about the leadership
right
I thank you Jake thank you Jason for
bringing that out to let people know
Phil been taking a lot of slings an hour
sometimes it's not his when I yelled out
Pete Hines
I was talking I was talking the truth
I was talking the truth sometimes a
leader takes punches that are intended
for others because he knows those
individuals can't handle those shots
is is Big shoulder stuff this is big boy
stuff we in Big Boy game territory now
when I was telling you that Sony didn't
look the same it's because that's not
them
Sean was a real type of G so when I was
looking for that clap back moment that
moment that yeah Xbox is down they're
gonna go in they're gonna switch up the
show that was Shawn's style shout out to
condo people y'all been clowning but
shot the car he did say it it's like a
sports team it's like a regime change
it's like those are Sean Laden's draft
picks so to speak and now that error is
winding down and Jim what are we three
years into the console cycle now now
Jim's vision is coming into your point
King I gotta give you your boss you said
he moves different they're not going
like a lot of the hardcore PlayStation
fan might not like this new Direction
when it comes to live service and thus
the opening starts to happen and the
Showcase that they're not used to
happens and thus we see the reactions
because when they don't know how to
judge men oh I know how to judge men
I got a chance to meet one guy and said
no that's the leader yeah you called it
you said even when he didn't have those
titles so
my state of Xbox is this
I told you how to hold the line and I
wasn't telling y'all to hold the line
hyperbole just trepidatious they were
nervous the show was coming I said they
ain't got nothing they don't have
anything they told you weeks before that
we only putting out one game a year so
that one game is Spider-Man so what do
they have to show they're going to show
you some games of service they're going
to mix up some stuff they're going to do
some magic tricks some Hocus Pocus and
Jim is not good with the Hocus Pocus Jim
is good with the AAA bangers if you
don't have AAA bangers to show you're in
trouble so I knew his show was going to
be in trouble y'all taught Phil the game
so Phil takes the game and he
assimilates it and he says okay I got it
this is how they want it and this is how
it's going to be
so when y'all got the Game Pass rocking
and he puts people in positions to win
so game I expect Game Pass and stuff
would be good but I expect the rest of
this year
to be like my man addict said back to
back back to back and it's gonna be
something horrible but the state of Xbox
has never been brighter y'all y'all give
me so much joy when I call my Twitter
because the PlayStation dudes are
changing the goal post now to go crazy
they're gonna win by six or lose by 20.
we don't know what's gonna happen
so I love everything that's happening
but Xbox is we on the wave right now the
level murderers
you know what I've been seeing
PlayStation is going to have another
showcase you know what they're going to
have some stuff at Summer Games
they held things back for Jeff
they sound like 2017 Bots man oh
that's a 2017.
wait to E3 I quickly get my boss up look
man shout out to kick yeah you
definitely held that you know coming in
it was Bleak man it was Bleak in my
opinion because it ran we got to be real
me and you would have these discussions
because again it's the double whammy of
the CMA blocking because remember the
report everybody thought it was a done
deal right CMA you heard the post come
on oh yeah it's gonna have thumbnails
you know what I'm saying like so
everybody's like okay the Call of Duty
thing would have been so huge as an
infusion of positive energy into Game
Pass and into the Xbox ecosystem to say
okay those again let's be honest Diablo
was coming out a little bit before so
people getting their Hypes up like
you know maybe ghosts we can sleep alone
you know Diablo 4 Game Pass prior so
then you got that and obviously we know
the red four debacle we ain't gonna go
into detail I was there for it we saw
you know the marketing issue the staff
Foods all the stuff it was just bad
being solved were there together and we
saw it you know so look I'm with Kingdom
man like I feel good I feel good
honestly there's a there's a there's a
different energy to Xbox yeah there's a
swag there's a and it's not I know
everybody shot the grub I know
everybody's worried about don't support
a rake don't mess it and I get it but I
gotta Stand Tall with King on this I've
always said I've expected even last year
and when he talked in 2022 the lack of
the the AAA first party output I looked
at the schedule for 2023 and I was like
it's lined up for them it's literally
all they have to do is execute you know
what I'm saying that's all they have to
do and I think look they got to to
griggity's point to to actually plummet
a good point that they they were even
emboldened
after the PlayStation showcase you could
see it because a lot of people unlike
King did not see that coming like they
were really going to upset their base
and not you know perform the way we are
accustomed to perform during the laden
era and I think they dodged a major
bullet I gotta be honest they're
embolden they like it's almost like oh
that was what y'all got okay and now you
get to look at the reaction okay this is
what we're not going to do this is what
they did you're saying you I don't know
if it's ghost I don't know if it's this
late in the game where they can make
even more edits it may have been
finalized but at least it gives them a
template to know okay this is how this
was received you know kind of thing so
look you know top of the year I felt
started off like you said goes extremely
strong high five Rush effect you like oh
man
Age of Empires you know and again I know
people not everybody hardcore game is
not in Minecraft Legends guy but you
know shout out to Maddie we interviewed
Craig uh late from um you know Minecraft
Legends and he talked about the success
and the engagement of Minecraft Legends
and the fact that it's multi-plat and
how much sales and stuff it's doing so
to me top of the Year showcase two
things one Hi-Fi rush you know that it
just set off a super high quality game
exclusive to Xbox right then you got
Boom the second part that I think the
top of the approved was that developer
direct because let's be honest them the
way they showcase games hasn't always
been the greatest um inside Xbox but um
you know say like now they're like okay
they doing it in a way that me and solve
like as far as presentation so yeah I
think um the energy is up you see the
proactive teasing the Fable on Twitter
people Executives popping off for a
social the fact that they're so
aggressive come check us out come see us
in the theater come like you ain't
talking that talk unless you feel you
got something in my opinion now the
question is you know would it be a eight
like Cog predicted or we get into some
special territory when we talk in grow
man tears Xbox showcase it dreams I
don't want to get too crazy but but
please
I'm gonna add you and what they also did
which we haven't seen previously is
after the PlayStation showcase They Came
Out Swinging on Twitter when they posted
that picture of the brawl Xbox games
previously that's when that's when I
think Phil Spencer became darksville
Spencer
this is even hyperbolic to say that Xbox
is at its best when it's taken that
punch to the nose yellow blood and when
they're counter punching it's like right
now their arms are open like let's go
that's how it feels because as an Xbox
customer we get our best version of Phil
Spencer's Xbox when they've got that
bloody nose and they're coming for it
they're going in for that knockout they
feel like they just took a hit and
they're grinning yeah they're smiling
like yo that's what you got yeah I'm
ready ready that's what this feels like
so that and it's again not hyperbolic to
say that that year of Dreams
is not Out Of Reach given the
Acquisitions they made five six years
ago and the games that have been in
development since the beginning of this
generation yeah it's time right like it
is time for that so I don't think we are
out of the realm to expect a great
showcase and there's a lot of things to
point to to show why that is and that's
cool yeah no no absolutely agree
absolutely absolutely so look we're
going to get into the predictions
portion and I want to start off with
something I don't see a lot of people
everybody does their prediction that's
fun but I want to focus on the Starfield
direct part first you know what I'm
saying and the reason being you know
this is a very highly anticipated game
we know how important this is to the
Xbox ecosystem exclusive that we've been
hearing for so long and we've got little
tidbits here and there but we haven't
gotten the meeting this supposed to be
the meat and potatoes so again I'm gonna
give it back to you girls because I know
your time is limited as far as um you
know how are you feeling about the star
feel direct what are your predictions
there
uh I mean nice I don't know that it's a
prediction to say that we're gonna find
out some of the basic frame rate stuff
because Phil said that's that's coming I
think they need to answer some questions
about Starfield mainly what does the
Action level gameplay look like what is
the narrative gameplay they've got some
gameplay stuff to answer we've seen some
gameplay there but like what's gonna
make Starfield special in the gameplay
category because uh not too long ago we
were comparing it to No Man's sky right
and that's not that's an Optics thing
right that's not ingenuous of the actual
uh experience at least I don't think it
is so I think what what we're gonna see
is a Bethesda that's realizing perhaps
the responsibility they now have as a
first party studio right because they've
had a win and had a loss this year and
bethesda's delivering the 2023 content
uh that people are looking at so I think
the responsibility on Bethesda now is
much higher than perhaps they realized
and so they're bringing their a game for
Star field willing to bet you see not
just the controller well I bet you get
special edition console uh I think
you're gonna see some deep dive
questions answered and I'm I'm there for
it right like I'm there for it and I
hope that it's a different energy than
the actual showcase proper right I want
to see the distinctive difference
between the two that's important so no
doubt Dirk Gregory I don't know I never
got a chance to talk to you dirt about
how you feel about Starfield overall I
never knew your excitement or not I
don't know if that's the guy like that
in that sense but how are you feeling
about the Starfield direct coming in
what's your predictions there well first
off I will say you know how important
this game is because they are having a
30 minute direct dedicated to this one
game yes sir um it's super important um
like go said though I I believe Bethesda
knows how important this game is and and
they're under Xbox now that comes with
an extra level of scrutiny they probably
didn't have before extra bit of eyes
right that they didn't have before you
know before that was multi-platform but
now they're only on the Xbox so people
want to look at them a little bit
different and judge them a little bit
more stricter than they would have
previously so I believe they know how
important it is obviously Phil Spencer
Knows and I think this game is is huge
for for Xbox this is bethesda's First
new IP since when hell with the 90s I
don't even know
um you know and their their games are
very popular from the fallouts to the
Elder Scrolls so this game um it it
means a lot I'm sure Xbox knows that
Bethesda definitely knows that and um
having a direct means they're they're
ready to show this game off it also
means in my eyes it probably won't get
another delay
um I do believe they will have some
Hardware uh like we already saw the
controller maybe some headphones maybe a
console like gold said I think uh little
series that's a little little man in it
okay
okay yeah I mean I mean you know just
just my prediction but uh yeah it's it's
gonna be a lot of fun man because I
believe Starfield will be a great game
and I'm looking forward to it no doubt
no doubt I see y'all avoiding the frame
talk yeah
okay
you want to clarify what you think the
frames might be before I move on I think
it's 30. okay I think it's 30 and I'm
gonna right now uh smooth 30 is better
than an inconsistent janky 60.
um if if it plays smooth we don't get to
complain I don't think okay uh okay but
that is that's not to say I don't want
it 60 right right not that you're
against the performance that sounds like
someone who just came off a performance
mode on Star Wars Jedi Survivor
uh Survivor
pause on Survivor if they had waited a
week until Star Wars week May 4th that
patch would have been golden why didn't
they do that is such a strange thing
because with in a week it was fixed yeah
what a weird weird
but let it be smooth
um and don't promise the world right
don't Market it don't mark it don't
Market it it's not I don't okay can we
put 30 frames on the screen it says 30
y'all
is give me a box that has a sticker that
covers up
it's too soon it's too soon those are
recovering from that
fair enough dirt where are we at with
this frames you know honestly um I can
obviously be wrong just a prediction but
I think it will have a 60 FPS mode
I think it will have a 60 FPS mode uh
but I think you know maybe the
resolution dipped on the X to 1080p on
the S to 720p okay so we're we don't
worry about them we worry about the
Resolute as long as you get there
people say right we don't care about
resolution just give me a solid 60.
yesterday
in the Vaseline mode right so shut up
now I don't know if it'll be a lock 60
but I think it will be a quote unquote
60fps mode
20. it better be locked that door better
be locked shut up
if they if they say it and they can't
deliver it they're gonna get dragged so
under promise on frames yeah well Phil
said it wasn't the kind of funny and
even shout out to Paris Lily in the chat
um he they did say that the frame rate
will be addressed we will know he did
say that so that is interesting that is
let me get the flu he's been patient man
so how are we feeling about so I don't
know what's your connection to Starfield
or not you know how are you feeling
about it what's your predictions on the
direct and of course the frames question
yeah I know I'm I'm extremely hyped for
it I mean I was going through this here
and I'm thinking the amount time of game
that's going to be taken up by Zelda and
then Starfield this year is going to be
like 50 of all my gaming so I'm
extremely excited for it and like dirt
said they put a 30-minute show just for
this game this is it this is like
essentially everything is this is Xbox
this year this is the biggest thing that
they know is going to bring in the most
traffic so it's a huge show I think
they're gonna go into deeper Dives of
like the entire planetary system you
know like the Thousand planets
um get the mod Community excited and all
the stuff they're gonna be able to do I
think we're gonna I agree there's gonna
be some Hardware announcements like the
controller we've already seen the leaks
so that's definitely going to be there
there's a headset we saw
I think I don't know if they're gonna do
console a console just because we've
been hearing about like the hardware
issues they're still having so I don't
know how feasible it is to get a bunch
of Starfield special editions unless
they're all just sitting in a warehouse
waiting for this game to come out but I
think we're gonna get a special edition
of the game I don't know if you guys saw
that previous leak of like the smart
watch I feel like that's going to be
something that comes yes
um
so I think that's pretty cool I excited
that to me is like an amazing special
edition if I can replace this crappy
thing
um I think we'll also see like one of
the biggest complaints from the first
Gameplay trailer they showed was some of
the combat where like enemies weren't
reacting to getting shot so I think
we'll see all of that polished out kind
of like what we saw with Halo infinite
with their first trailer and then the
second trailer was a lot more polished
and
yeah and um yeah I think it's gonna be I
think it's gonna be just amazing game
and I'm gonna go with 60 FPS oh frame
rates boom he was confident
that's my heart I've been I've been
saying 60s from the beginning and I'm
not going to change my stance
I'm gonna die in that Hill give me
confidence give me I want to know why
you standing on it school I I just think
like what's a first person shooter I
think they know they saw first of all
the drawbacks and like the outrage about
redfall you know Phil Spencer was on the
phone with Todd Howard right away
you got that ready you got the right at
least a mode that'll like maybe unlock
but I think like they're aiming for 60
FPS and I don't know I just feel like
they have to do it I mean they got to
just lower that resolution get that
frame rate off they gotta do it's first
person shooter no matter what people say
say like there will be anger if there
isn't 60 FPS there even though it's it's
a Bethesda RPG and people are gonna play
the hell out of it there will be anger
if there's not 60 FPS I don't think they
want that again so all right he feels it
in his plumes
I could I could resist I was thinking
about but moving on moving on I don't
know if attic addicts probably get
started to go but um I was curious my
brother loved Starfield man I wanted his
opinion on this one hopefully when he
comes back but what's up fellow
bethesdian
fellow selfish single player Western RPG
immerse yourself for hours don't talk to
us for days yeah leave me alone
direct what's your predictions and how
you feel about them frames
what a frame situation to me uh listen I
think King mentioned this a couple weeks
back but it's really time to start
showing all of these things that they
Xbox series X was touted was touting the
FSR and all of these things just sort of
variable resolution
um
Implement Implement all of the specials
doing all the stores you want the es Ram
all of it all of it use the clouds
from the cloud on this we want all the
results Jason we want all the resources
we want all the resources
we were all the tools we needed we need
the tools off you better get the tool
all the tools tools all the libraries
um this game has to have a performance
mode it really does it needs to be it
needs to show that it can be done there
and do what you need to do in terms of
variable resolution whatever you need to
do get that mode in there and then of
course give people that their 4K 30 uh
resolution and of course obviously the
series that's just going to be a prop
more than likely and I would I mean it
would be amazing if they could figure
out some way to get a super you know
whatever 480p your performance
at 540p at 120. Let's Do It
um but that's that to me that is that's
important that's important I know it's
not important to Todd per se but I think
you just have to again narratives you
have to look at what is going to make
the base excited and what is going to
make the base angry it kind of you have
to I feel sometimes when especially when
you talk about uh presentations of this
magnitude you really do need to come out
there and show
um so that would be great and I and I
hope that that is the case
um I'll be playing on the PC so I don't
know are you masturbating I'm not I'm
not just not I'm not even dealing with
this concept no no no no um but I really
do think this is
still over there I really do think that
it's time for all of this console stuff
that we heard from the beginning of the
generation to really come to fruition
and start to start singing in these
games
um in terms of what the game has to show
we've seen a lot of the game already
right we have
um but I really do want to see console
gameplay right
they said we can't we can't pay we can't
say or captured on PC and if I we can't
get away with that listen man as someone
who was recently at a red for the match
but you don't want to see the 49 you
know what's with the 49 you can do on
the X
it has to be console gameplay
um they have to show the hardcore RPG
guys how much of a hardcore RPG this is
right and it has to be in such a way
that it's brief enough that it doesn't
bore the more Casual Gamer because you
also have to show the game in a more
casual action-oriented light that's
that's not going to turn away the guy
that's like what do you mean this is
some in-depth a lot of menus kind of are
you know RPG that may turn some people
off so I think what's great about this
game and Bethesda games in general they
do have that very sort of
action-oriented aspect and it's it's
amazing when to play
um well it's gotten gradually better to
play over the years I want I want to see
if they have improve that dialogue
system you know back in the old days
like you know the old Fallout games you
can literally not fight the last boss
and just talking like you can do it you
can talk no Jutsu to him and get him not
to lower his guard and it just felt like
in Fallout 4 it's like dude no matter
what you say I'm I'm pulling off I'm
pulling up right and then that's the
thing so it's those old games and again
the immersive Sim Lover In Me loves the
fact that you could do you can get
around all that stuff so my hope is that
they do go back to that so it has to
show on a spectacle level it has to show
and on a technical level it has to show
and and show that again because a lot of
you the hardcore RPG you guys want this
to be a hardcore RPG
um so and I do think I do think Todd
knows that and I think that's what we're
gonna get
um we may be disappointed in terms of
the frame rate stuff I don't know but um
I think the game is going to show well
and I'm excited to see it no doubt no
doubt Lord addict my fellow Bethesda
brother what's your feelings what's your
prediction about this just the Starfield
direct portion and uh what's your
prediction of the frame rate
I want to spend that whole 45-30 minutes
just showing gameplay I don't want to
see taught however no controller I want
to see no jacket it's like you come back
here like you do that you do that off
the stage you know you could play the
game off the stage I don't want here's
the thing we've seen too many where
people out there playing stuff and you
get the game and it ain't nothing like
that like it's like I don't I don't want
one of those scenarios where they're
just pretending to play the game oh look
at that like nah like like you you
better show me I want like one of those
things where I touch like press the
start press up down eight oh let me make
sure this ain't pre-reported like it's
just like look I want them to show us
that this game is actually functioning I
want to be very transparent on whether
or not this game is going to be 60 on
the series X you know if it's not just
just tell me I'm playing on PC now like
it's just one of those settings where
it's like
you need 30 minutes of game please
unrealistic I mean it is unrealistic but
guess what he asked me he didn't ask you
tomorrow
we close the borders
whoa whoa
did it
right in front of those things
you delayed the game multiple times
you I mean you literally put the release
date in the last trailer and you had to
delay that thing too
no excuse is why this is 30 frames I
don't know
you could save that for the birds
because if it's 30 frames I'm playing on
PC I like that energy okay I like that
energy if I feel that Lord King
Starfield demander of release dates
early
someone who knows had a very interesting
relationship with this title over the
years so uh my thoughts you know you
know coming in
[Laughter]
I don't like being lied to actually
didn't lie to me
um I tried to strong on them you know
feeling have nothing to do with that he
looked from the distance like Todd I
told you
Starfield
I love thee let me count the ways
well you disappoint me surely you shall
surely you will come in a broken State
and something will be wrong with you you
probably love you any other way
ugly little baby
don't you do that I I believe so I
believe so it's gonna have some little
warts here and there you know um when I
was hearing soft talk in the back of my
mind all I heard was missing Impossible
music
he was telling you
telling you I need you to do this but I
also need you to do this and I need you
to do this but I made sure you can't do
this while you're doing this but you got
to make sure that you do this and you
got to convey this to this to make sure
that this happens I'm sitting there like
this dude has a monkey on the tricycle
battle Center banana off his nose while
drinking coffee and I'm like damn why
does it have to be like this they're
gonna show a game and I'll show you how
wonderful that uh it's it's gonna be how
many planets stuff like that and stuff
that you're able to do stuff you don't
want to do now or whatever and people
are still getting caught up with the
frame rate
um I told you Seth Lord Phil uh walked
over and said yo show me your bill I
don't give it what's going on no more of
this dancing in the closet by yourself
stuff I'm sending the team over there
because he said before if we knew the
state that redfall was in we would send
that team over there in April it was too
late yeah that's it without throwing
anybody under the bus also Jason
Schreiber I told Andrew uh half of that
team was gone it was decimating more
than half yeah you know everybody
thinking all the original people they
were pretty was working on that game it
was like a skeleton crew but not exactly
so they wanted it to be one way they
wanted to be something else I think this
is Todd's baby where it has a clean
concise Vision in what he wants it to be
and what it shall become it's not going
to be Fallout 76 oh it's not going to be
readful it's it's going to be exactly
what it's supposed to be this supposed
to be one of the pillars going forward
in your franchise so that show that
they're gonna show and and this is how
you contain a nuclear bomb okay
separated from the populace so
everybody's trying to figure out well
why it ain't on the main show first of
all we already saw that move just the
same way I said Final Fantasy I didn't
want to see it again at the show Sony
joint effect you take this separate you
do this this Final Fantasy had their own
separate little joint right Point good
point and you do this and and you show
your RPG in a light that it's needed
that there's nothing around it and you
you need to detonate that bomb and see
what happens right so yeah you're gonna
have a 30 frames per second mode I think
it's gonna be 30 frames per second
locked I think it's going to be unlocked
on PC now if they do have a performance
mode on the consoles I don't think that
the series s gets that performance mode
but I think the series X does he can't
play in the 60 60 frames
um unless like Sovereign says Jason and
the team
give the full development kits to Todd
and why wouldn't he have it right yeah
first party he should have everything
right so you mean you should have
velocity architecture you should have a
vrr and everything popping you should
have everything that y'all talked about
all those bells and whistles everything
should be available for little man and
also I heard that you gave them extra
memory and development kits yes to
achieve certain performance right so do
that with FSR yeah I keep seeing that uh
AMD Fidelity resolution crap almost all
the buzzwords yeah but I don't
internally 720 or sub 720. and upscale
it
and be able to hit 60. again but all
that in theory stuff right I'm tired of
in theory because at the checkout
counter there's no Theory
at the 70 checkout we live in an
actuality right when you when you press
uh yeah I want to buy you know actually
this is gonna have to hold the line and
give me that no they they need to this
game and yeah be it right a bit wrong
it's under a hell of a lot of scrutiny
yes will this game make a break Xbox no
it won't but what it will do is set a
level of expectations across the board
for everyone so unlike redfull because
redfall is a baby that they made you
think you wanted you didn't know what
the hell it was they made you like it
they put out all this merch and
controllers and all this stuff and he
was like oh it's super cool and it's
vampires with guns I can do this and you
found out it was crap so this is
different though this is Todd we want
brown jacket Todd that's right I want to
see the the leather jacket I want to see
Todd take the controller I want to see
Todd go up to a table and pick up a cup
and look at the cup because that's what
he liked to do I want to see that if
it's in 30 frames I don't care
if it's in 60 frames yeah so what but I
want to know that it's playable on my
consoles I want to see it on Console
captured on PC I don't want to see that
don't pick up a series X pick up a
series s pick up a controller move
around pick up a cup go to a space
station do whatever you want to do I
don't care but do it all on Console win
lose the draw do it on your field and
let the chips fall was going to fall so
this is how you detonate a bomb without
having collateral damage around the rest
of the stuff we don't need to see it on
the Xbox proper show right let it do it
over here by itself but do all the stuff
that you say you're going to do and just
let it be what it's going to be facts I
like that I make mines quit I agree okay
we're gonna say this game has to show
out I mean first of all right I'm such a
Bethesda Fairway because I have this
Theory like for any video game though
that if your title screen music is epic
and I don't know if y'all been listening
to these constellations when they do the
thing and have music come in soft have
you heard that music yet like it's just
translation yeah like when they talk
like those little shorts that they do
when they talk today talk about the
quest design they talk to Todd they talk
to the T and it's just a fable it's like
energy and I know it's yeah I know it's
crazy to get excited about that but it
I've always had this Theory a lot of the
great games have that level of detail
and seriousness and attention to the
music and I think it's that energy
coming in look I'm with King this is God
Howard this is a team this is brown
leather jacket energy this is the reason
why I did multiple games of the year
Studio bro talk to a man this is
Morrowind this is oblivion this is
Skyrim you know what I'm saying every
top like 10 like best games of all time
I see Skyrim on that almost every time
that this is why I fell in love with
Bethesda why they are the goats of the
western RPG I don't okay when nobody say
when it comes to that main vein Western
RPG no one does it better this is taught
with something to prove a chip on the
shoulder this is Phil basically saying
whatever resources you need to help get
you across the Finish Line we will get
Lee and I'm with you King in the sense
that you know we I feel personally that
he took a lot of slings and arrows for
Bethesda for them in the preparation of
this game because let's be honest they
called out their own shot with 11 11 and
we know how that release date worked out
so look this is a unique ambitious game
this is NASA punk you know what I'm
saying in space planets Unique Mechanics
factions like addicts said the dialogue
trees the the things you could do that
makes them unique what I need from them
is to show at least two to three
mechanics where you go get that scope
and you say all
not many games is doing that they need
like two moments where you go where
there's going to a planet doing
something you know coming back down
where you say okay this is some sci-fi
Space
Odyssey you know what I'm saying like
you know I'm at Rando are you there with
it friend I'm curious I mean I'm there
with them cause I'm gonna get to you you
know but it's just like I need that from
them and yeah as far as you know the
frame rate
look I gotta be I hope I take the L on
this y'all I I got it because I'm just
concerned as far as like you know when
when Todd says hey we like to pick up
every cup and analyze it we like to you
know what I said when you hear that
energy and you know I'm about to
Fidelity the frame rate is secondary you
don't say like when I hear that energy
and I know his attention to detail and
World act you know accessibility and
complex systems and procedural planets
and NPCs I get it you know what I'm
saying so when I hear that stuff it puts
me like Carl it is doing a lot
and it's like Skyrim beats no man's Sky
meets you know whatever right so that's
a lot of CPU bound systems in my opinion
so when you have that my opinion friend
now to your point if they're able to
work that magic and they get Jason
around on the team over there the devs
over there and they really showcase this
would be such a moment for them but I'm
gonna stay conservative you know with my
pick on that got out of it I got to get
ranks I think I was gonna say that
what do you see I don't mind if it's 30
I just wanted to be transparent I don't
want to wait to the last minute this
thing put it up on that screen if it's
got it all you got to do is tell me if
it's got a performance mode because if
it has a performance well I'm assuming
sorry my only pushback addict is that I
feel that if it is 30
and it's gonna sound lack of transparent
but I don't think you could say 30
frames per second on the Showcase I
don't think you could put 30 80. I think
you got to find out about it in the blog
post
I don't think you could put 30 on the
screen he put that energy out there
already man it's like it's it they're
too far down that rabbit hole to just
not say it just say it right the people
the people because the thing is it's
only going to matter to us I don't think
they're only gonna let them be like PR
you're gonna put the three oh
gonna say a very matter-of-factly you're
going to keep it moving
I think if they just come up there and
they say if there's a performance mode
that's a performance mode and then oh
it's a double dog there's a Blog that
takes you to another thing that does not
if they got a performance or it's
already a w we're good yeah that's right
that's all if if it's dirty and they
mention 30 I don't know but red I got to
get you that I gotta get the ghost
because I gotta get some dicks out
because he's got to go but what what red
what's your thoughts man stop
ah Starfield biggest Xbox game biggest
new Xbox IP since arguably Halo in my
opinion yes I think it's bigger I think
it has a potentially bigger than gears I
mean just look how big
Skyrim is and Elder Scrolls and stuff
star field could be that so it needs to
show up and show out
um
it's we haven't gotten the official time
yet Aaron hasn't said like
how long either one of the shows is
gonna be right like we're assuming it's
an hour and a half
for the Showcase in 30 minutes for the
Starfield direct but we don't actually
know it am I correct on that yeah
I'm looking at the blog there wasn't
really a specificity on time length yeah
I mean because normally I think somebody
asked them a little not like recently
but like maybe a couple weeks ago about
what the time length was and he said it
hadn't been set in stone right so I'm
assuming it's an hour and a half in 30
minutes but maybe it could be hour 35
and 25 because we've seen a lot of
Starfield already yeah I mean the last
showing was 10 minutes plus I think yeah
so
um assuming it's 30 minutes maybe you
get a deeper dive into like how the main
missions are structured uh like what to
expect on different planets uh maybe
more information about dog fighting and
building colonies it's just like a
deeper dive into kind of a
the things they already show
Ed
whoa whoa whoa moving on out of the way
oh
[Laughter]
um yeah what can I just cancel for today
yeah as far as uh the tech stuff yes I
don't know if anybody's saw the on the
Xbox store if you go to the Diablo 4
like gameplay launch trailer on the
store yes at the very bottom it says
captured on PC with Xbox settings okay
oh that's the new hustle let's go let's
go all right hold on hold on hold on
down
I think the whole redfall situation
change things for them right about
presenting at 60 on PC and then as Phil
said getting that gut punch right of uh
oh Arcane can't deliver their you know
60 FPS and we we didn't know and we
should have been there to help him and
because that really is that whole 30 FPS
thing was just like you know like what
so I think we will see more we will see
them kind of adopt what PlayStation has
been doing this whole gen of captured on
PC captured on PS5 stuff like that so I
think that Diablo trailer is a view of
what's to come for the Showcase and
future things especially for Starfield
where
if they're showing it on PC they'll say
captured on PC at Xbox settings okay
okay you're like okay is the series X
okay that's what it's supposed to look
like for XBox guys if it's not if it's
captured on Xbox they'll say captured on
Xbox
so I think that will be kind of a a
through line throughout the entire
Showcase in general they're going to be
really transparent about that because
they got they got beat up over it right
and that's not something they want to
relive again and the frame rate
discussion is an interesting one because
you know it's a series X the world's
most powerful console and if you're
coming out here at 30 frames people are
already feeling a certain way about how
you know sometimes the PlayStation
outperforms it and sometimes the Xbox
outperforms PS5 on certain games but you
know we were sold a bill of goods of
every game not some games it was every
game oh you waited for rdna too remember
that whole thing like hey we
intentionally waited for these features
and none of them are there yet I don't
even know if a game even uses velocity
architecture yet
um you know whatever so it would be
pretty disappointing to say in your
showcase
this game's 30 FPS I mean series
that would be disappointed on this if
it's 30 can they say it I mean the thing
is they're they're gonna have to at
least specify because Phil said it would
be apparent when they show Starfield
again what the frame rate is going to be
I mean you could do a blog post and be
like hey or you could say there's
performance mode
I'm kind of torn on this because my my
heart my well my my head says 30 frames
right because if you're expecting 30 and
you get 60 great let's celebrate all
right right I expected 32 because I feel
like the moment kind of funny would have
hit them up he could have just clapped
or no it's six no because because if it
because if it's 60 he's not going to
take that shine away from the team he
did say he's not going to take their
huge announcement from the team
and then he said when you know uh Paris
interviewed him and and Gary Widow and
snow black Mike
he said that they got in early on
Starfield with the atg team the advanced
technology as opposed to late with red
as opposed to basically
he pointed out like we were in there
early okay okay and part of me
thanks man he got in there early you
only deliver 30 frames
if you didn't get in there at all
right and stuff would have been you know
so my counterpart on Xbox two the one
only just recorded salute he is says
it's gonna have a performance mode and
they'll they'll somehow uh like turn
down the stuff that Bethesda games are
known for like the interactivity like
maybe they don't make things static or
something
so you know what I'm waffling a little
bit here [__] you know for a while I've
been like 30 FPS I'm expecting it but
there's a part of me that's like all
right all right that would be a big
announcement that's part of this thing
for Todd to say we know people are
worried about performance on Console I'm
pleased to announce that on the Xbox
series Zacks it will have a performance
mode
that would shake the building if they
announce it thinking about it now
I feel like if it I don't know now that
you said that makes me feel like if this
thing was 6 30 they probably would have
said it by now before the Showcase
so we think the great wins it Jason
motto I'm saying if you want to get bad
news out you gotta get out ahead of time
that's usually what happens exactly
right on Friday
I'm gonna go with my I'm gonna go with
my heart my heart you go with your heart
I'm gonna go with my heart I'm gonna say
that
I'm gonna say that it's got a
performance mode and that Todd Howard's
gonna announce it on the show
so my heart might be broken
I'm going on a limb on this one I guess
okay
with his heart in everything that he's
done so 64 eggs 60 frames series X
little man no question
frames
bro we gotta have Jason throw the show
we got better knee if he get a little
bit to do 60. no it's just the idea of
like we were in there early with atg to
deliver you a song Wait a minute if
little man has 60 frames you're you're
like on the X there's gonna be all this
grass that on the series S no to that
crap the NPC density might be a little
no less
it's gonna be equivalent to like what
happened with the 360 or the Xbox One
where they had this giant tank in Call
of Duty on the 360s little van
we'll worry about that but we
quick hidden predictions from my man
we're gonna switch gears now and shout
out to the 1500 hit the like button chat
hit that like button like button y'all
y'all out here showing out you know what
I'm saying we hit that over to 700 or
we're silencing King the rest of the
show exactly you'll get no King balls
for likes
I gotta hold you for Answer Man you know
what I'm saying look we got Michael
Jackson back
anyway
bro
all right
ghost this is what we're here for this
is it the big one the prediction series
The separate Ghosts Xbox expansion pass
what are your predictions on how this
show is gonna go also I need from you
what do you start this show with and
whether you end the show with all right
uh so I will take you on the logical
journey and then I'm gonna drop a few
hits
yeah I need the mic drops let's go uh
you start the show with with uh
with Fable because you teased it all
right you start off strong starting off
you teased it they can't do that to me
ghost I'll have a heart attack before
the show even starts
um just gonna let me like lay on the
floor
I need grown man tears from you because
I know how much you let that game
continue
uh but yeah you start with Fable
um I think they spend some good time
showing you what you're gonna get in the
next year they may not say 12 months
12 months right because being me and
dirt we don't want to hear that 12
months don't say it okay don't say it
okay you need to show it okay um but I I
think 2023 you're going to see Forza
Motorsport uh and Starfield you're gonna
get your date for Forza uh you're also
going to get stalker two this year okay
and I think that's what's gonna take
them through like 2023 right those are
your three big Xbox exclusives
um obviously stalker not first party but
that's that's not the point right they
want to get that one out there
um and then they're also going to show
you hellblade which is going to drop
into one or Q2 2024.
um I think that's your jam right there
you take you use Forza and Starfield and
stalker to take you through holiday with
the promise of hellblade in q1 uh that
way you've got something to show it at
game awards okay so no hellblade this
year you said hellblade topic you wonder
right because now they need a Cadence of
every quarter right okay every quarter
they got to do it they need big ones and
it's time for hellblade
um and next to that of course in 2023
you've got grounded sea of Thieves uh
you got Forza Horizon five whatever
you're doing live service in that front
um if you're gonna talk you don't talk
Halo unless you've got to Tonka you
might Sizzle reel it but you don't talk
Halo I'm witch so don't talk Halo
um let that be its thing uh but it's
time to see some gameplay for a lot of
this big portfolio you need to see some
gameplay uh for for whatever machine
games or it is doing one of the two
Indiana
would make sense
um really real talk I hope it's a new IP
I hope it's a new IP okay right those
two those teams are real talented
they've brought Doom uh into the modern
era which Doom has always been amazing
they brought Wolfenstein into the modern
era but I want to see something fresh
from either one of those teams and uh
that's what I think they're going to
sell on
um
but the whole thing for Xbox needs to be
you know what do you got now why do I
own my box right why do I own my body
a lot of box talks you're lucky we just
hit 700 so you're allowed
keep cooking
so you know as far as like let's get a
little bit crazy maybe you talk about
the family plan you don't talk about it
rather you show us a quick thing with
family plan I think people seem to care
about that a lot it doesn't talk to me
but I know a lot of people want to know
about it my cousins all right we need
that yeah yeah get them in Breakers
uh as far as getting just a little bit
crazy uh I want Phil wearing the leather
jacket oh it's not allowed you know like
the leather still wears the leather
jacket underneath he's got the hold the
line t-shirt bro if any any Xbox will
hold loud bro I'm just saying right it
feels Phil's rocking Todd's jacket with
the hold the line t-shirt that's what's
happening right there
they absolutely need uh they absolutely
need a superhero game and I said this
last year I think I've said this every
year it's time for black panther to get
his game we hashtag just wanted
that's right yes and Heaven narcisse
writes it oh that's what I want that's
what happened it's time because Xbox
needs a superhero game six times and it
writes itself when you throw the wakanda
it makes an X let's go
uh maybe you see some sort of of uh
Activision love there maybe they show
some cod content or whatnot
um I would like to see that in there but
we just lost the idea we brute force of
the deal on the show understand I mean
I'm sorry I'm interrupted I'm sorry but
I'm gonna tell you right now for for
real what I want to see is Xbox bringing
their a game and telling everybody why
you need this box uh in your house why
you need a Game Pass subscription and uh
it's time to see the proof in the
pudding that we know so much about their
portfolio Perfect Dark Fable Indiana
Jones Contraband uh guy you just go on
it's like I know so much I want to see I
want to see what you're cooking what are
your Studios making and then real talk I
want to know what some of those
secondary studios are making we got high
five rush out of Tango whoa okay
obsidian brought pentiment to uh uh out
like right like I want to see those
level games next to the AAA because okay
those are great sides right I need my
meat and potatoes facts and I need them
both together to compliment so that's
what I'm hoping for No Doubt yeah give
me that superhero game before you go um
so yeah I got I love your mic drops you
had just for clarity what was your start
your finished skin just I forgot I just
wanted to remember again oh start with
Fable
um
I think you finished with it's hard to
finish with Forza because that's a yeah
yeah you can't finish with poison I
think you finished with an unknown
either new IP or something fresh and new
you finish with something that we don't
know about and that's how you finish the
Xbox conference and then you take us to
Starfield which we do uh need to see so
I think you finish with the new IP or
new game okay that last question because
I know this telegram topic here because
I know you got to go right now it's a
topic ahead for you it's not gonna have
some fun now okay
the Xbox showcase is an L if what would
absolutely disgust you if you see the
way it's handled on the Showcase goes a
certain way what would aggravate the
ghost
uh I don't think this is if they didn't
show Fable capital
okay just did that right that's that's
the L uh if you if you if you think
Kojima making some weird cloud game is
the mic drop moment that's that's a loss
right gameplay I want game and don't
show me a single game that's not coming
out in the next two years
um okay don't show me a single game
that's about the next two years and you
need to focus on the next year talk to
me Q3 Q4 2023 q1 Q don't you dare say
that 12 month stop I'm not saying they
should say 12 months in their
presentation but don't forget
I want them to don't say it yeah they
should not say the words in the next 12
months
should all be targeted within that realm
so so what you're saying ghost is don't
say it but do it
yes
don't put it on the screen
I'm okay with that as long as they still
still have a like a little bit of the
show that's dedicated to the Future you
can have the majority of the show
dedicated here and now yeah but you
gotta tease me before I'm playing in the
future Sizzle reel is different than
they used to do the spotlight okay
Sizzle reel is different than spot you
Sizzle real me your future Sizzle real
Contraband Sizzle reel Perfect Dark okay
right but don't don't like spend me
spend time on something that's two years
two and a half years out three years now
okay all right you know what I'm saying
I remember you need to see outer worlds
too again we know it's been worked off
that's what that's really what I'm
saying does that make sense so basically
if something already like had like a CGI
or something like that already like
unless you're ready to really show show
you don't really want CC okay all right
listen Man hellblade 2 needs to be there
oh no needs to be there so I don't that
answers the L question no hell no help
that's a problem that's a problem yeah
that's the only game that they've shown
to go toe-to-toe with like a god of war
a third person narrative style which
people are calling for like people are
calling for it and it does need to
happen
um I just don't want that to be the only
strategy and Microsoft's really good at
having a diverse portfolio they're
really good at that so that's that's my
that's my jam there I appreciate you
girls I know you got a boogie so I just
want to let everybody know my name is
epic Ghost Xbox expansion pass where can
I find people find you what you got
going on Sir yeah
um you can find me on Twitter at insipid
ghost of course the Xbox expansion
passes on all your podcast Services
focus on dev interviews a lot
um I will thank you guys both I'm you uh
King we met at E3 right and that means
the absolute world that you guys still
let me come in and party I'm sorry I'm
not making the trip this year but uh
hopefully I get that invite next year uh
and hang out with you guys again in
person but I mean it means the world
when I get to see you guys and and that
you guys give me a platform to talk and
grow because you guys have been there
every time for me so I appreciate you
guys all love brother Mama man the
insept one enjoy your day I know you'll
be listening in the background when you
get a chance but good good for you to
come through on the prediction Series so
now we're going to keep people take care
brother we're gonna take it we'll move
it up move it over to the plume
all right it's the prediction time you
know I need to know what you what you're
feeling what you think's gonna happen
and give me give me what you start of
the show
end of the show and then some mic drops
also so what do you think is gonna
happen first I I have like I have pretty
I I it's weird because I've made videos
saying hey guys like go into the show
and don't get like insane expectations
so you're not disappointed but but I
have I have pretty high expectations
going to this show so I think I think
they're gonna kick the show off with the
game that everybody's been wanting to
see and we thought we were going to see
last year was it was going to be a vowed
I think that's going to be the main one
we open it up with the black rock
obsidian let's go yeah I think like you
started with about and then
you and well I'll get to the ending
after but then you move on to the start
field you actually got two huge RPGs
kind of at the beginning and the end
um of this entire thing and I think they
move on to like because that's like the
big bang for opening it up people are
gonna be excited for that they drop some
more first party stuff I actually think
that they do 343 does show up and they
talk about project to tanka I think
that's gonna be something that
invigorates like life back into Halo
um so I think they obviously desperately
need at this point so I feel like if
that game is ready to be shown
you put it in there you put it in there
and you get people excited to jump in
and maybe they do something similar to
what they did when they launched the
multiplayer earlier and they're like you
can jump in and play project Tatanka
right now and I think they'll get people
hyped up so I don't know how realistic
that is but that's a that's a
prediction I have and they're gonna go
on they're probably going to show off
like age four for console because we
know that's supposed to be coming this
year I think they're gonna go into after
that like some more like smaller style
first party stuff so like stuff that
we've seen predictions of or leaks of
like compulsion games with their with
their project midnight let's go yes yeah
like that's the third person you know
the set in the Deep South and everything
it looks really really cool with like
the gothic Vibes we saw like a
screenshot of that so I feel like
they're gonna announce that finally
because we haven't really heard too much
from compulsion lately
um and then so Psychonauts 2 came out in
2021 and then they did like their whole
documentary where they were talking
about how they had two games in
development that they had to pause for
Psychonauts too so I think at least
we're gonna hear about one of those
games that were underway in development
a little double fine appearance okay
okay
and then we'll probably get some some
Tango uh gamework stuff with the Hi-Fi
Rush DLC stuff that we've already seen
like achievements come out for but I
feel like that section is gonna be like
first party not the biggest first party
stuff after about and then they're gonna
jump into like just a bunch of
announcements for Game Pass
um the stuff that like we've seen in the
previous shows they they always come out
with some pretty big announcements that
drop into Xbox game pass maybe that
Persona 3 remake's gonna hit which would
be pretty crazy if they announced it at
Xbox show
um
we'll probably get some
some updates on like because we know
flintlock's supposed to be coming or
place is still supposed to be coming
Silk songs it's also becoming a game
pass so maybe the update on us on those
when those are going to be dropping in
uh stalker two probably will be
somewhere in the middle there as that
hope hopefully that's moving along
um with everything that's going on with
them so uh that'll be huge and then
maybe I don't know if they want to throw
this in but maybe they're going to throw
in
60fps redfall update
the parents oh
screen 60 frames y'all just shine buddy
reform is not invited to the cookout
no this will say nothing just update the
game
we got to do a blog post off screen yeah
oh
that works now
you got one dude walk past really fast
it works now
it just worked yo
oh man continue
um I think we'll get some like more
cloud gaming announcements that we've
seen that stuff be coming out because
obviously they're trying to show hey our
first party Xbox games are going to be
on all these This Cloud streaming
platforms for the Activision deal so
they'll probably jump into that and then
after that section I think they're gonna
end it off with
the announcement of uh Keystone like the
streaming box and they're going to put a
price and a date on that my man stole my
junk cause I was definitely going oh you
got a whole weekend
my bad my back you're good you're good
so just the clarity um I'm sorry let you
finish it with Clarity I need what was
your mic drop moment even if it's
unrealistic like I want to let you
finish and then you might try I just
want to clarify that okay oh yeah I'll
uh so when I drops actually is coming up
after this section go for it
um so I think the Coalition is going to
make an appearance and they're going to
do gear six just like a teaser getting
people hyped for it and they're gonna
drop the gears collection as well
holding my paperwork
what happens when you go live
you you saying the mighty keys I think
so I think it's fine we haven't heard
for them in a while whoa that'll be
maybe that would be crazy maybe they
show some like Unreal Engine five stuff
because we know they're going hard on
that so that'd be that'd be pretty cool
um and then after that that'll be like
the middle like oh this show is lit for
boys
it's a crazy show let's go
so like the middle part was like people
maybe have started falling asleep a
little bit so they come gears wake
everybody up okay and then they they
bring out in Exile and I think they're
gonna announce the project Cobalt game
with the first person steam Buck RPG
game
and then they end off the show with
three big games we got Ninja Theory we
got
um hellblade 2. I think they're gonna
release this in
early 2024 and the reason I think yeah
we don't need boom we just yeah
the first half like
I like it oh I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna tell you what we would normally
look like end the show with but it's
gonna be the beginning
you got two retrievers I love this
continue
we got Coalition in there we got keys
[Laughter]
okay continue continue uh yeah so yeah
Hell by 2 early 2024 because I think
there's already way too many games
coming in 2023 from them we'll space it
out okay yeah and then for tomorrow
Sport and then they end off the show
after for tomorrow Sport with
if this doesn't show up I'm going to be
extremely disappointed with Fable
because they teased it like they got if
if they don't bring Fable to the show
it's I think a huge a huge misstep
um for the entire thing so that's that's
the end that's the end Anthony I like
that I like so we ended it with me okay
what's a shorter list what's not at that
[__] it's all there
baby
tonight
you know it's funny he he he's saying
the show like like like we running it
back
it's like and then a year from now
they're like what are we gonna show we
showed everything last
year's outside let's go they gotta
capitalize that door is open from
PlayStation they gotta get in there
there you go no that's definitely Mike
drop worthy all that dirt yes sir dirt
let's go what do we talk I know you
ain't tempering nothing yeah I ain't
tempering nothing
definitely
okay I got you like go out the show I
got you I got it all right so let's go
what's these predictions so what you got
first off I really do believe they're
going to start off with hellblade
with some gameplay with some gameplay
um I'm starting to believe they will
drive hellblade like in March of 2024.
okay okay early 2024. now me
for my trash talking purposes I hope it
is in 2023 but it will be okay if it's
in 2024 but um I really feel that
we're going to get an update for project
Morrow and I remember they announced
that game in January of 20 20.
what kind of update I don't know but I
want I really want Ninja Theory maybe
right behind hellblade or somewhere in
the show but I'm thinking they're going
to be right next to each other with an
update for project Marvel
um on a little something from Project
Marvel don't know what style the game is
going to be but uh you know that's what
I'm hoping for like um little Ninja
Theory section to go back to back yeah
yeah back to back
[Laughter]
there you go I like the Antics there we
go yeah so
um then also I'm I'm expecting
um a vowel like everyone else I'm
expecting the valve to have some
gameplay with a 2024 release date don't
know when obviously but I'm thinking
sometime in 2024 I'm also expecting
a little
um something from Contraband that that
game was announced in 2021 uh I'm not
sure how far it was in development then
but it's obviously been a couple of
years since I I'm thinking we're going
to see a little bit of game play maybe a
late 2024 release date that's just me
being optimistic
um you know of course we're going to
have a little Indie section I'm of
course I love Indies I definitely want
to see it replaced and like some of the
other endings they have announced before
um I'm expecting the P Hines to come out
there with some updates okay well you
know uh you know Elder Scrolls Online
yeah you know stuff like that why is he
here
don't do that be respectful
well I mean you know like some Fallout 6
uh experience
I mean they didn't last two years the
bad news is doing
oh
[Laughter]
my God
I'm not dead yet I have DLC
now I do believe Fable will be there now
you know like everyone else said I
believe if they don't show Fable that
will be a nail because the t's I mean
listen man the evidence is looking like
it was Fable a lot of people did some
investigations I watched Rand video he
compared to music and I said um this is
uh
from Fable that sound just like that
yeah definitely and I was like oh with
the glitter the the glitter Trail so I
do believe they will have Fable there
now the question is will it be
some gameplay or would it be in engine
trailer or something like that um
after either either one is okay as long
as it's not another CGI trailer okay
yes an engine all right okay and in the
trailer
um but I do believe they uh they're
gonna end and this will also be my mic
drop moment oh let's go
this is me you know like wishful
thinking I'm hoping because I love the
franchise
it will end it with Wolfenstein three oh
because listen I love the franchise
machine games I love them I love the
Wolfenstein one and two I even like the
little DLC they had
um no not the hold on let me take that
back I like the uh not not the one with
the two girls
not that one I'm talking about the first
was the old blood or something yeah
not young blood but uh so I really
um
that's gonna be my mic drop moment I
hope it's there I know they do Indiana
Jones but did they start Indiana Jones
in January of 2021 because young blood
came out of what 2019 uh 2018 winning I
mean today was doing something those
years right so you got one thing over
over Indiana right now you know like
Indiana uh because I still think Indiana
is probably a little now if if they're
developing Wolfenstein 3 I would still
think it would be I don't know maybe a
little bit closer to Indiana Jones
that's just me guessing
um but I'm a huge fan of the franchise
so that for me would be my mic drop mom
guys I like that I like that though Del
Randall 2019 are we back sir
there we go there we go so here we go
man's prediction time man what does Rand
predict for this showcase what does he
want need to see there I need your start
of the show I need your end of the show
and I need some mic drop
well okay so this might seem fairly
similar because attic just heard it
yesterday
or people on Xbox 2 on Friday or people
undefining to come Wednesday you make it
around you make it around maybe I'll you
know switch things because like I feel
like they could open up the show one of
three ways they could open up with Fable
if they wanted to but I feel like
opening with fables the
would essentially send the wrong message
because I think if Fable shows up
it's gonna be in game and they won't
even have a year attached to it because
I'm not expecting it till 2025 so I feel
like you're starting the show it would
be like oh Fable's here
but you're starting off a show where
people are expecting gameplay and
release dates with the game that's not
gonna have gameplay in a game that's not
gonna have a release date so I feel like
that's kind of starting off the show on
the wrong foot we'll get no gameplay I
don't think so I don't I think we'll get
an in-game in-game engine look at the
title okay
um won't be CGI uh you could open it
with hellblade too especially if it has
a release date where it's like boom it's
coming this September this you know like
uh this like November or late October
uh but I'm gonna say I think you opened
the show with the vowed black rice
yeah you know one of the one of the
studios carrying Xbox this generation
right
uh it's been a while since we've seen
about haven't seen it since 2020.
um I think it would be a good show
opener with uh
um you know gameplay not an engine like
gameplay I mean Philly even talked and
kind of funny how he's seen a recent
build of the game you know addicts show
me your build like Phil's Pro after Red
Falls Phil's probably emailing all these
dudes like show me your builds at a
regular three month intervals please
don't have a chain of events in the
building
uh
we're gonna cause like people are sort
of used to
uh obsidians like oh pentimate right
because a lot of people kind of clowned
on how pentiment looked even though you
know we kind of mentioned what it would
look like Jesse even had like an art
like a picture in his little Arc or what
it looked like and grounded it's
impressive looking for what it is but
that's not like the graphical uh style
people people want so I feel like
starting with the vowed having a good
Gameplay trailer and then saying 2024 I
think okay fair enough you got you start
off a show with an update of one of
those elusive five or six titles that
we've seen since 2020 I think that's
like okay we see a vowed
um and then in between I mean let's just
get the small stuff out of the way
Microsoft loves to
uh have trailers for their big live
service stuff okay right I watched the
last two shows recently sea of Thieves
that both
gotta get if you
leave there's even a chance grounded is
there again right then who knows if they
got new bosses or whatever so they can
show grounded Halo right I know it was
it was Ghost said he didn't want no Halo
right unless the taco yeah was that
ghosted up go sit there yeah
um season 4 has come on June 20th and
Microsoft hasn't showed anything a Halo
at these shows since they released the
game
so the fact that season four is so close
to the to the Showcase okay yeah I mean
people are worried about the future of
Halo 343 after what happened after
Bonnie left after they laid off all the
people so I feel like Halo's gonna show
up with the trailer for season four
um
[Music]
no I don't think so I think Tatanka is
still further out I think maybe it's
been expanded as well in this day and
age because it's because it feels like
going after BR in this day and age right
now I feel like BR is peaked
and people are moving on you look at
look at Bungie they've they've shifted
to extraction Shooters
no no I'm not I'm not saying I'm not
saying
Battle Royal is not super popular but I
feel like the market for getting into a
battle royale and being a game that
succeeds is extremely low at this point
in time okay right you know what I think
it is I think people are trying to find
the next thing because they can't
compete with fortnite but yeah fortnite
and Apex Legends and Warzone and stuff
so I think like yeah they're gonna do a
battle royale Halo spin on it but it
might be more than that so I think they
probably needs need some more time to
cook all right okay
um I do think we we get new new
announcements from uh compulsion
compulsion games I think we'll see that
uh and the reason my line of thinking is
well you know it's been a while right uh
they haven't shown anything I think
they've been done with you happy few for
a bit and the big reason why is because
they hired a a community manager
recently correct and they haven't
tweeted since October
and why else would you be hiring a
community manager unless you need to
manage your community real soon
unless there's something upcoming to
talk about unless there's yeah unless
there's something upcoming that you're
about to announce why would you need
somebody in that position uh plus that
is probably going to be a CGI
announcement trailer you know how Xbox
loves to do like first announcement
first CGI that's fair um I don't know
when it's gonna come out Jazz thinks he
leaked it too early as he leaked and
this is the thing with jazz he always
comes to me he's like I'm leaking this
and I'm always like
you need don't leak it sit on that like
so like I think a lot of Jazz's leaks
the project names Belfry
typhoon dragon
and all that stuff like I think
way too early way too early way too
early okay
um but I do feel project midnight will
be there and they'll have a CGI
announcement maybe it comes next year
um
and you know I'm sure there'll be I did
Xbox will be there I'm sure there'll be
a bunch any titles that are day one game
pass announcements uh silk song probably
shows up again maybe with the release
date this time hopefully I know that's
the big uh the game I mean Axel Primal
is a big game for them for Game Pass in
July that could show up even like Texas
Chainsaw Massacres their big one for
August I mean that could just show up
um you know my heart's like Splinter
Cell because Ubisoft the next day I mean
that's shooting for the moon but yeah
probably unrealistic
yeah I mean that's probably not gonna
happen though so Sony Sony got
Assassin's Creed
they do they do
but I mean yeah
um what else we got I'm thinking
okay if you go on the Bethesda side I
see I'm I don't know what to think about
Bethesda because it's the Xbox game
showcase previous couple years where
Xbox and Bethesda game showcase
does not having Bethesda imply they're
not there are they combining stuff now
and it's just like okay we feel people
know bethesda's part of Xbox
uh I know the xbox.com thing mentioned
new games from XBox game studios and
Bethesda so maybe they are there we know
that you know Pete Hines loves to talk
about Fallout 76 and Elder Scrolls
Online the whole Xbox Live games as a
service develop it directly
um yeah uh I don't know I feel like
we already know about uh Bungie we
already know that bethesda's there with
Starfield after yes I feel like
machine games is gonna show off Indiana
Jones okay and I don't feel like
Wolfenstein 3 is a thing
really or at least the thing that's
close to being revealed any point in
time okay I mean I hope hopefully I'm
wrong hopefully it's like yo Wolfenstein
three ends the show and it's coming out
this year and we've just been holding it
for a while I don't know I just sort of
feel like they were working on
Wolfenstein but they weren't really
feeling that high on it especially after
young blood and then they got the the
contract bid and they won it maybe for
Indiana Jones it's like okay now we're
working on this and this is the game
okay but Indiana Jones movies coming out
this year it's coming out in June maybe
that maybe Disney sort of wants like
okay a trailer out to kind of be like
okay the game is coming to
um
so maybe maybe they're there
um is it exclusive ring
[Music]
the thought process is this was before
yeah this is before the acquisition and
it would you know I mean maybe they
bought out the the rights for it or
whatever and it is but so before dark
field that was nice Phil you know that
was nice Phil okay I mean maybe jazz
baby jazz is around King send him a
message you know like you're wrong on
this one
see what he says see what he says
uh let's see what else what else could
uh be there so
indie games uh maybe some third party
maybe Monster Hunter world two from
Capcom you know it's that's about it's
about time right for them to reveal
something a new Monster Hunter world
um it's tough to really think about
third party because the way Xbox does it
is they want everything Game Pass
centered yes and a lot of the bigger
third parties don't do Game Pass so
they've kind of shifted away from it uh
uh from having those big announcements
at their showcases
um I do think we will see one of Jess's
projects not outside of project midnight
and compulsion I think we will see
stoics game which is uh which are the
people who made um Banner Saga I think I
think yeah I think that will be coming
next year
um
and like when I think about what Phil
said a collection of games because
people jump to that and immediately said
hey here's collection Fable collection
I would like to think both of those are
real oh we do it right back to back back
to back I would like to think the gears
collection the Fable collection are real
I feel like gears collection makes sense
a lot of those games aren't on PC and
maybe you could do it in a way where it
comes out the year before gear six and
not many people remember Fable because
it's been yep last Fable game was 2010.
so by the time Fable comes out that's 15
years almost
and it might make sense to remaster
Fable two and three and just kind of let
people in and they'll remember like
celebrate Fable again so maybe that
could be a thing although I I don't
think it'd be at this show because I
feel like if
gears collection was this year it would
be here and then it would tease gear six
but I think gear six is
I think gear six is a 2025 game and then
that would the collection would be next
year so I don't think you need to
announce it that far and early
um as for like the show Ender
it's Fable oh I think it's Fable I think
they end with Fable oh okay I like that
now gotta interrupt you for a quick
second
um I love that they did end with Fable
in 20 they did they did they did they're
done with Fable but the thing is Fable
is
huge yes like I think Xbox has huge
expectations Halo level expectations of
fable and I think then positioning it
closing the show twice
um letting because I believe this game's
further I I think it's a 2025 title
um
I think they feel very confident in it
and showing it
having it close again and showing it off
in game engine sort of stuff uh
signifies like how they want to like
okay we need to start drumming up
excitement for fable it's coming in two
years we want people to look at this and
be like holy crap get really excited
um so that's why I think Fable will end
it okay um because it's not going to end
the year there's going to be like look
at this crazy amazing looking uh
playground games reboot a fable you know
Matt booties talked about how he wanted
to show it last year
no literally I was there I was there at
Pax West shout out to let the legend
Bill Stillwell was with me and um you
know he was dead he was talking he was
just like he would you could when you
saw him talk he was like chomping at the
bit like yo yeah what you got is so fine
like that I want to show this like he
literally was saying it in the team
playground had to calm him down he said
and say no when we're ready we'll show
so that was ran like a a year ago right
yeah that was a year ago so things
changed you know it could be like all
right we're ready to show we got a cool
um you know uh segment that we could
showcase and then you know you you maybe
even have like a like a short 15 second
trailer for Starfield to be like tune in
don't go anywhere here Starfield right
and then you go into the Starfield
direct so I mean I think
Xbox probably show like 10 plus of their
own first party content it's just a
matter of like
will H4 be there because the H4 console
version is coming this fall our history
Untold was revealed last year and was
supposed to Launch
before you know the end of the 12 months
is it coming this year still if it is
that might be there right uh Hi-Fi Rush
achievements leaked on Steam is there
some shorter Shadow dropped expansion
incoming uh would that be at the Keeley
Summer Games Fest they're at this show
so
um don't expect at least I don't expect
like only three first party games
because you want to talk about what
would be an L right what would be an L
for Xbox
save that yeah save that because I want
to make that a segment just to get this
part going with everybody else a little
quicker but yeah so I expect a lot of
Xbox first party from Bethesda to Xbox
game studios to publishing uh 10 plus
even I mean it could be even more
depending on how much they want but yeah
nothing so not at all notice you notice
you notice what a week does right
okay I'll hold it I got us hold it a lot
we feeling confident now dude wasn't
this confident before but you know
as that holds a lot of effect yeah I
expect you had shrimp and lobster that's
what the general is
you know we we hope this to be here
okay I like that red I like what just
just for Clary what was your mic drop
moment
it's a mic drop for red get red
I'm not sure there would be
problem with mic drop moments is usually
mic drop moments are things that are
unknown okay you know like that's just
come out of nowhere and you're like all
right we're dropping the mic maybe the
Minecraft moment this year for them be
like look how much gameplay we showed in
an era where like people are not really
showing gameplay
um
yeah I'm not I don't know I don't know
shoot for the stars damn it
okay mic drop moment this isn't gonna
happen all right okay but I said it
attic knows what I'm about to say let's
go
Phil's joined on stage by Doug Bowser oh
and they announced an Xbox Nintendo
partnership oh switch coming in hot and
starting off uh Game Pass will be
heading to the Nintendo switch and
select the Nintendo games will be
heading to Xbox okay how's that how's
that for a mic drop I like that I like
that it's not gonna happen but whatever
that's the switch cover yeah something
like that I need that I needed that
energy
you are up it is time your predictions
you are very keen about what starts to
show and so this means so much to you so
I need to know and then your predictions
I think they started off a vowed oh wow
we go okay Black Rock obsidian I think
people they've showed so much of how
blade will be okay the only way I see
they start with fable
is if a vowel's not about uh hellblades
gameplay looks so good that they feel
comfortable showing ending with that but
I I think a valve is gonna open they're
going to do the middle of the show with
hellblade and they're going to close the
Fable oh so we're gonna close the feet
okay I like that
and now as far as like just general
predictions what you expect to be there
for many of the studios which you need
to see there what you think will happen
I think we'll see a compulsions game yes
you know I'd be a little bit
disappointed if it was CGI uh because
it's been undevelopment for like like I
feel like some Studios have made like
three games by the time this game comes
out
but uh you know if it is CGI at least
we'll know what some kind of form it is
especially what like
what kind of quality of this we can
expect because some studios are doing
double some students are doing AAA we
might see Exile entertainment's game
there but I think it's still too soon
okay
the problem is even know that
they have some serious contenders to
come out with that they can come out
they got a vowed most likely Fable
hellblade in a star filled thing right
afterwards like to me even though that
we want them to come out there and shoot
the whole clip do they realistically
have to as long as a vowel comes out it
looks good
Fable comes uh has a good showing it
doesn't have to have gameplay but it's
got to show us more than just a logo
yeah and hellblade combat looks good and
has and all of it for the most part has
release dates that that that's that's a
key point you know a Val release Windows
fine for for a valid but but hellblade
needs a release dates question because
you're the Fable guy I defer to you you
are Lord fable Fable shows and it looks
impressive and they show what you say
will you because this is a big stickler
for you be upset if there is no Fable
release there
I won't be upset as long as they show me
like maybe a story trailer show me what
they're going to do as far as a story
narrative okay but it is interesting
that they chose to show fable
because it's like out of everything you
could have showed let's say it's a
vertical slice
why Fable you know you could have done
this with any other Studio but you chose
Fable and that that's why I feel like
maybe those surprises and and Fable
comes out like oh late 2024 and it's the
holiday game for next year and at the
end of that trailer it says fables
releasing in the holiday of 2024 and
that's the reason it's at the show
because to me if it was 2025 you could
have easily have like with hold this
clip to show it next year but not only
are you showing it this year from the
looks of it you are teasing it on
Twitter oh they going hard
so to me why are you teasing your
biggest bullet unless there's something
more on with that bigger spooling so
maybe closer you think that's where
you're going okay yeah I think I think
there's a chance it comes out holiday
2024. you know at the end of the day
they you know as long as Hellboy comes
out and it does good a valid comes out
and it does good and you know Starfield
comes out and does good
let's be real here they they get closer
to Holiday 2024. yo Fable gonna be have
to be we have to delay that like six
months
like pretty much if Faye was there part
of me feels like they're gonna pull
they're gonna pull a PlayStation they're
they're gonna give you a date
that they know they can't meet just to
just to just to be big up people yeah
yeah because it's like if you look at it
that worked out well for for God of War
god of war came out there and said some
crazy dates and we knew for a fact that
it wasn't meeting that 2021
but I do think that the the as long as
this remember it said that the game had
some restructure and it still said
holiday 2024 in the league hmm
like that's why part of me feels like
this game might hit like holiday like
November of next year interesting okay
because like if you think about it like
they have so much in the tuck why this
game especially if it's a 2025 game
fair enough I see where you're going and
what was your your mic drop so your
magical moment
Persona 6. oh yeah Comfort solves next
Persona no I'm coming from my neck
let's go soft shaking his head and
especially if they see that day and day
Game Pass like oh you real
[Laughter]
because like here's the thing
the fact that that because it's been
highly rumored that game's coming out
next year Persona 6. so it's like why
didn't they show that on Playstation
showcase they ain't got the box okay
I see what we do we see this like real
like obviously it could be exclusive but
everyone thought Metal Gear was
exclusive for like two years yeah yeah
they did yeah you saw that and you don't
be crazy if
all these rumors oh it's an exclusive
PlayStation
and it's it is an exclusive but it's the
Xbox like it's just like I doubt that I
I would be happy even if it's not on
Game Pass if they just have the
marketing rights and it's on their stage
but don't don't let them come on that
stage saying that's an exclusive to Xbox
and it's in Game Pass
I don't want some of that crack yeah
so it's a perfect transition
I thought about a uh a hype moment for
you oh let's go because the Nintendo one
is kind of like whatever that's probably
unrealistic so I'll give you one I know
you'll like I think I'll give you one
you know you like let's go you know we
we saw Island link 2 at the PlayStation
conference my most anticipated game but
how about if they show up with the rise
oh you stealing yeah
all right no fan no fan no fan bro man
shut you up grown man tears for me your
romantic listen when we get to me yeah
bruh that that means a lot I don't care
what nobody say but we'll get it we'll
get it I like that red I like that a lot
continue adding it I gotta get solved
so that that's pretty much it it's like
look you know I I think the biggest
thing they can do for me personally is
dropping that Persona six you know
obviously that's right I want a banjo
but I'm slowly giving up on that you
know I would love it
you see you get three-headed Vegas
see here's the thing though if one
person has three then why wasn't Persona
six at the PlayStation show okay you
mean to tell me that they have the
marketing rights to that but they hold
on to like the key component I don't
think and all of these leaks have been
consistent and it's coming out next year
and you needed to tell me we halfway
through the year and then they can't
show that that's that's exactly that's
expensive game awards thing you might be
on to something there but it's just like
you look at it from like Game Pass
perspective on Sega games name some that
came out I'll wait
um
they have such a good relationship with
that that I'm convinced like now look if
it's a PlayStation exclusive they have a
great relationship with Sega not Atlas
we got Persona on the platform yeah I
said that wasn't never gonna happen yeah
wow late yeah wow I said it was never
gonna happen
I'm trying to get away from the sloppy
seconds I want that
predictions start finish mic drop so
start see for me I like I like a
conference that builds up and Crescendo
me too me too all right so I think the
most immediate thing besides Starfield
is people wondering okay obviously force
is coming this year where's Forza okay I
I see I I I think we get the the
whatever the cover car right we see that
whatever
no commodity people expecting it this
year set the tone with that show
whatever the the cover car is and shows
some like it's it's literally going to
be a Sizzle reel of gameplay because
you've shown a lot of the game already
and boom date whatever the date is you
know fall of this year right
then after that
um no let's jump to the middle I think
the middle
we do see a vowed I think it's time to
show you know we've seen kind of
initially when we saw it right we saw
something that looked like gameplay but
it wasn't it was more of a vertical
slice kind of indicating what the games
will look like I think we do finally see
something from a vowed
um and I do think it is a 2024 game it
could be early
cool you know it's crazy solve a vow
could potentially steal the show just
like hell blade just like Fable and just
like starfield's stealing all their
shots those four right there which is oh
those are crazy right yeah so then after
that after that this is Middle towards
the you know middle going towards the
end of the show and I'll fill out
everything afterwards I think they need
to show if hellblade is this year right
okay the big thing for hellblade is show
that combat yes please the combat is is
Paramount I think they've been they've
been saving that combat just for this
show okay I think so too they've been
working on it they've talked about it
um especially you know coming off the
PlayStation show uh what is it demon
blade where's the demon blade thing that
what was the name of the demon blade
thing that we saw oh yeah the um right
random blade random they do it in that
combo
people saw that I saw that people saw
that it was like okay is that a real
game right true
if if Ninja Theory can can combat can
look super visceral you know that that's
the game that is the game that's the
game you're playing because the last
time we saw
hellblade that whole scene with the
giant baby you know that stuff that was
amazing
it was it was more cinematic it was
cinematic in-game engine it would you
know they tried to make it seem like it
was gameplay but it was more yeah in
engine kind of QT exactly so we want to
see gameplay proper right but fear so
that's that I do think right before the
end right before the end I think we do
get Fable and I think yeah Fable
gameplay I I think this is this this
showcase I hope if I if I believe in the
crescendo okay I think you keep building
and right before the one more thing so
is Fable I think let me throw this
energy out to you guys because the Fable
like glitter line thing that could
either be fairy uh dust or or they could
be doing like an Easter egg from the old
fables where there's like a line going
to your objective what happens if we're
already into this too much and this is a
fable remastered and it's not the Fable
game so you think they could get away
and I think they could get away with
the remix
and no new Fable gameplay no here's the
thing here's the thing it depends on how
well the remaster is like if if we're
talking like like a Resident Evil 4
style then yes they could get away with
it as long as that's a remake
Fable two is the most beloved Fable uh I
like Fable one more but most people like
Fable two more so who would be the one
where you put all all the eggs in the
basket it's just like when it comes to
that Fable it's just interesting that
they chose because that's what I'm
saying like having Fable here makes no
sense to me it really like logistically
it makes no sense the game is nowhere
close to being uh to being out like you
have all it would be different if like
they had a light showcase but they don't
like we know hellblade a vowed and
they're having Starfield gonna be there
after the show so to me it's like why
breathe Fable here and like but it might
be one of those things where they they
show a new trailer for fable the new
Fable and then they show you that
remastered Facebook to kind of build the
hype for the people if Fable is longer
why is the Fable uh it's a stealth job
is for the Fable collection and and not
the reboot they can help what I'm saying
hold your L segment right
that's a l man what I'm saying is is
what happens if they do a like they show
you the Fable the one that we want but
then they they go into that too yeah I
mean that's kind of that's kind of
exactly what I said I said you could
have a scenario where it's like follow
collection and then fall out reboot or
years collection and they could come out
and be like here's the gears collection
everybody's like okay cool cool what
about gear six but then they're like and
here's a tease of what we're working on
next and have a trailer for gear six it
could be very similar to to the Fable
collection to then the Fable thing
um but
if it was just a collection
they're eating that owl
so disappointed there'd be no reason to
tease that whatsoever and I think like
the idea of like addicts action like why
why show up this year like because it's
it's it's like I think I forget who said
it like because it's time but it's time
it's time and it's not like and the
thing is like it's not like Fable's
unannounced it was announced in 2020
it's gonna show up at some point the
game's been been in development for a
long time so whether it's like people
have been waiting a long time to see
updates on these 2020 games whether it's
gameplay or end engine just to know like
what it looks like what it might play
like when to expect it
um this was all going to happen because
I hear you ran but steady K3 is nowhere
to be found perfect darts nowhere to be
found like I think they had to announce
those games
all these games that I I just I just
don't give it that oh it's it's time
it's time for the majority these guys I
I am of the mind that and we never think
alike when it comes to this like we
always we the fan thinks a certain way
the business thinks a different way
right and the things that they consider
to be bangers and this that the other is
not how we would have it right if
perhaps if they end with a third-party
guy
no here's the thing here's the thing
once they end with something like like
uh Splinter Cell
fan here no no no not really I remember
Anthony
yeah you're right there
the Fable thing addict because I don't
know if you're here when I said it it's
because they're positioning fable as the
next big thing yep right it's better all
the games well yeah and then if it shows
up next year it's because they need to
pound that home because it's been 15
years right fable fable fabled they want
it they need it to be huge I think we
got a pound at home
you gotta pound it real hard
I just feel like when you look at like a
perspective of all right we we have a
game that we're gonna show this year
with no gameplay and we already showed
this game with no gameplay and Phil has
said on multiple occasions he's not
about showing games anymore if no
gameplay he under he hears the feedback
and he knows that people want to see
gameplay but the biggest game they have
at the show has no gameplay
have you been scarred too much by
because this is your beloved favorite
you you've been 2018 remember like it
was yesterday song me you in there
everybody told me it was 19. everybody
told my brother that Fable was gonna be
there the entire one of them the NBA not
me sir all the NBA dudes told us
every every announcement I look over
here
and then we walked out of the Showcase
he saw some grown man tears for sure it
was like they told me it was gonna be
here it was no favorite and flew we
walked out this conference we threw the
mic on and we just went live we
literally did it out front the Microsoft
theater right and we was like that
wasn't it Xbox
attic proceeded to go on a redstone
attic I'm just saying like it's part of
this baby you're scaring that you've
been hurt and you don't you don't want
to believe in him you've been so damaged
by the face it's too good to be true
bringing Fable here and say this game
comes out holiday 2025 or the the middle
of 2025 with no games
after you already know that that's what
ran is insinuating it's a 2010.
why would it have no gameplay though why
that that's what rand's saying that's my
prediction
we had this discussion on your show
yesterday
because there have been waiting I just
want to say it yeah addict you're acting
like games being
um announced or well I take it back
Fable was announced in 2020 but we've
seen in the past where games will have
some gameplay or an announcement and
still wouldn't come out for another two
years I mean we've seen plenty of games
today the second announcement they do
without gameplay I think they'll be I
think they'll be game but we've heard
Matt booty until Spencer throughout the
year to say that they've seen the game
and it looks amazing
gameplay I could see it being here but
if it's got gameplay if it doesn't have
gameplay I just don't see Phil going out
and saying we hear the feedback and then
when it comes to showing their biggest
game on the stage yeah we got nothing
for you there we're gonna show you Fable
on the screen again we're right you know
what let's just show them the same
trailer
come on my man's hurting right now
instead of almost like he doesn't want
to he doesn't want Fable to show up at
all
it's just I think we I don't like to be
from watching these shows
it just so it feels like there's
something off that's why I feel like
they're gonna follow me yeah
nobody mentioned Fable anymore yeah
to me it feels like there's something
missing like like a
a foo like remaster remake along with
the I just don't see them coming out and
say yo we ain't giving you release date
release window we're gonna show you uh a
CGI or maybe in-game engine and then
we'll keep it moving
though if this is if the new one is a
reboot
I could see them working on that but
it's not a necessity right it's not a
necessity that has to happen in that
order so I think you've been working on
this game for everybody no you're
working on this game you don't show this
game after what it's four years almost
they gotta show something so moving
moving forward so we hijacked you sorry
for April got mentioned that was there
don't mention Fable anymore yo that
isn't even the show Ender for me the
show and then again this is my behind
this guy and you're gonna like this guy
screen goes black okay
Obsidian Entertainment
comes out
and then you hear all our New Vegas too
Jesus Christ Jesus
okay go back go back turn the lights off
[Laughter]
no this is Star Wars Star Wars 2. that's
what it is
no that's not at all he just folded mine
no no don't worry about go back repress
the button press the button and play
Black what's gonna come on that screen
we gonna see yeah
Frank Sinatra come on
Spreading the News
you left me standing alone
and then you get first
New Vegas remake Maddie please awesome
the world and then and then
the announcement okay two is coming
from obsidian
we get the dice no PNG that's that's the
night that's that is the end of the show
does it end with uh or or whatever bro
I'm gonna watch Baddie plays crying that
will live I will see that man he will
have grown man tears for that because I
will say right now if you breed that
into existence
that I might cry just as much of a heart
attack if I saw that as a fossil Fable
gameplay I think to me I probably have
over a thousand hours in in New Vegas
My Hope Is that they they listening to
what the fans want and the fans want to
be wow moment to moment right and maybe
that's not realistic fine but some of
the stuff like all you have everybody in
the building to be able to make this
happen Max Joshua let's make it happen
like let's make it happen like uh it to
me it just there can I push you back for
a second no no no I love it I love it
trust me but we all gave Microsoft crap
for announcing games in 2020. I don't
care but that aren't gonna release until
either this year next year 2025. and now
you're gonna announce Fallout New Vegas
2 when a valve is not out yet and out of
world's two stools yet to come out so
we're essentially announcing Fallout New
Vegas 2 in 2023 when we know that that
game's probably not yeah
my thing is that this it PlayStation for
the most part when they've done that
name any game that they've done that
with that has not eventually come out
and not been great or at least good
right
to me to me it is a thing of like yo
have confidence in this idea that you
have even if you know it's five years
down the line excite the base excite the
bass right and that that to me that's
what these showcases are for that's a
marketing event here's a marketing event
like you come in if you come into this
event be like oh your expectations are
tempered or you're expecting you know
okay what is the business version of
what this looks like because of business
we can't show all this stuff no like
just to me as a fan I don't care what
your business is about I want to see
what I want to see like give me the hype
surprise it Delight surprise and Delight
beyond that there's a bunch of other
first party stuff we don't know about
and that to me fills out everything else
in addition to a few Choice third-party
things that they have either you know ex
you know Game Pass stuff going on um I
would really love it if we did see
Splinter Cell on that stage
Assassin's Creed Assassin's Creed went
to PlayStation right Splinter Cell
obviously has a history of Xbox it would
be nice and what would be we already
know it's coming right and they they
already had like a sit down talking
about what they wanted to do with the
game it would be nice behind the sky
maybe you get a little trailer kind of
indicating a little bit of what it might
be like and then you hear the voice oh
you hear the voice right he's 100 years
old but you hear the voice is Ironside
coming back we don't know right that
would be the eyesight I don't need no
key for anything yeah no no none of that
so that would be nice
um
one of them yeah okay yeah beyond that
let's just keep it away
still keep sticking 124. I would
absolutely
lose my sanity if they announced the
Fallout New Vegas too yes facts and then
we have replaced right the place is
still coming this year he silk song
those big games that are going to be in
Game Pass absolutely show that off
stalker I would love it
the situations of the world
um and then what was there was one other
one okay
I know this is coming day one to
everything but it will be on Game Pass
day one let's go but considering the the
fact that the the PlayStation base has
not gotten their dream in this regard
wait wait what are we doing if if lies
of p is that game okay give it more of a
shine here okay all right people are
excited for it it's their bloodborne
surrogate facts let's go evil Pinocchio
let's go evil Pinocchio if it is that
game and it's still coming this year
right if if it gets pushed out of this
yeah I don't want to see it but if if
it's still coming this year show it it
was yeah I saw that Paxil West last year
yeah I went down so that's it that's it
man I I want the sun moon and the stars
I've done crazy stuff in the past I
don't I'm not gonna be like scale bound
too or whatever
shout out to the 1400 people hit the
like button man hit that like hit that
like button do you want to say one thing
man I see people on Twitter asking you
know if you order that that we hope that
hold the line now you get it in time for
the showcases before they might get it
in time yeah
I'm not gonna lie I got mine in three
days today's stuff man I I really didn't
believe that they would be shipping as
fast as they shipping they know they
hold it that hold the line
you're up and then Plum I know what I'll
do is I'll accelerate because I don't
want to respect your time I'll
accelerate after a week being King gold
to go to the holy Elder I don't know how
how you doing on time are you okay I
just want to make sure no no I'm good
okay my man just want to make sure I
respect everybody
um all right it's okay this is it the
general
this is the moment because he took them
in there oh no okay we're not even the
general today okay
okay
let's go
um
all right so start I know they want to
punch Sony in the mouth
um I had a theory the reason why they
showed that Gran Turismo movie
is because they didn't have a racing
game
because I'm pretty sure that they got
the trailer of what fours will look like
um
I'm pretty sure they got their spies and
everybody can't and it was like yo B
show that Forza yo you know that Gran
Turismo movie it looking like that b
what you serious put the movie on
that's what PlayStation responded
they're gonna play the footage of the
movie and then go into voice okay
y'all remember the time when we saw
horizon horizon yes and it swooped in
and it just went because they showed
that the mountain and the stream and the
joint and then it was like yo that'd be
crazy if that's a game and it was facts
playground let's go
um
you turn ten this is gonna be and and
I'm saying this unequivocally
Forza is going to be the real
this generation
game
[Music]
not everything that we forgot before
it's up to this point right now has been
almost
like y'all didn't see the reason for
your purchase like you didn't you you've
I don't care either side either side you
can tell me that the God of War was the
reason for your purchase bro it looked
just like though
it's the same job
you know like Horizon Saint Joseph it's
nothing Xbox drop is the same Jones this
could be done on your your PlayStation 4
and this could be done on your Xbox One
you know um even that Spider-Man y'all
saw the Spider-Man but I saw a lot of
you dudes hit me up like yo that look
like prototype these dudes just stealing
stuff oh but it did look like a
PlayStation 4 Banger right
no this Forza from everything that I'm
hearing
is what we spend out with five hundred
dollars on we're gonna see these the 12
teraflops finally lessons lessons for
getting that shirt
um yes uh so they kick off the show with
Forza um you were solving agreement they
take your breath away
immediately to show you Pace right to
show you we have what
everybody's running from now
exclusive okay
that's this Jen okay because exclusives
matter here
okay I see what we do you know do we do
a release date do we do a release date
oh yes you got that you get that in
October okay okay that's there's no
bones about that they shoot that shot
straight down the pipe oh cow October
but I don't think this this showcase is
going to be about uh release dates
I don't think so okay I think this this
showcase is going to be about we got the
games that's exclusive
um right being that what we saw from the
PlayStation showcase
yeah so
um these dudes they gotta double down on
the fact that you can only do this here
and I know dude I can get on a PC shut
up shut up in the ecosystem you in the
ecosystem shut up
yeah it is come over here we got you
baby all right next game's going through
and I think it's going to be a section
of you get two games
um first party so I think you go right
after that you go into a valve and you
know they show you doing some magic some
dungeon crawling stuff like that and
then you have the game pass portion of
the show where a lot of those games
third-party games will be going inside
Game Pass
and then they hit you with a little bit
of Hardware in between the break it up
this is the low part in the show we're
always going to get the low Parts well
um hell no no I I think uh
I'm not doing my Pie in the Sky crap
okay okay all right but at this point in
time I think they show you the streaming
device okay and they tell you yo um go
straight from the game pass and you're
going to the streaming device because if
you looked at the that uh trailer that
they put that teaser online with uh the
Fable if you look in the corner of the
TV that little streaming device was
right there yeah
but if nobody paid attention to it why
would they everybody was his favorite
another streaming device you idiots
and he's showing you but you yeah
I know you're messy so
for the CMA boom you're streaming is
real is your problem now
this is this is the rise of Darth Phil
this I'm feeling the energy
and then this is where the back to backs
come out this is where okay you just
start going straight for the juggler you
start going for those games of service
the games of services that we do have in
place I know y'all don't want to see
um
yeah well that's happening
it's gonna happen yeah this package this
DLC is is dropping here
um I know y'all maybe Tatanka is there
you know
opposed to what uh Rand is saying yeah
show it
um show that stuff I think Battle Royale
will really boost that lagging Community
right there's certain things that need
to be done do that show your game of
service portions there so all your games
and service is there and then also talk
about the DLC for single player for
PlayStation got dragged for match games
that's today's business they don't do it
right
you don't even have a community
and you was gonna be slave dancing in
the living room oh that's what I'm
talking about I don't care if y'all
haven't played sea of Thieves y'all
won't understand that they have a dance
in there moving on anyway I like the
slave oh Lord oh um get to all your
games or service get that out the way
then you start hitting them with those
single player games perfect dock
I want to see something from perfect dog
initiative yeah and you end with with
Fable Okay Okay Fable is gonna be that
that centerpiece that the same way they
lasted 13 minutes on Spider-Man I think
they last eight minutes on in-game
engine in uh in that and it sprinkled in
there I'm pretty sure that we're gonna
get the the Whatchamacallit the the
coalition to come out and talk about the
gears uh Trilogy uh package and if we're
lucky if we're lucky we'll have two
packages this year with the Fable
package of being done right all the time
yeah so I'm I'm I'm hoping that right if
that can happen on the road man let's
get this true
that can happen but
we're doing it for real all right let's
go so
if we're holding the front line
I start the show off
what I have a lawyer type dude walking
up no no yes yes and he hand me the
paperwork news just in
we have broken through
deal is done
again the CMA and everybody have folded
oh you you want a a letter of
Declaration of surrender they have
Bethany
you're gonna have Brad Smith walk on
stage
the war is over
oh
we can't go home everybody pack your
bags
Call of Duty's coming home we're going
to do Call of Duty live deal on stage
Diablo's in Game Pass right now
is everybody
it's a celebration it's a celebration so
we're going to accept the letter a
resignation from the CMA
live
in the FTC Miss Khan has gave in her
resignation they found evidence of
collusion
[Music]
we have the paperwork this is amazing
1090 Jake got them snitching
this is amazing I'm telling you that's
how I want them to start the show and I
want him to do I want to feel a drop to
Mike
and just say Enjoy the show
[Laughter]
yo that was fun that would be fire that
would be fine I can't I can't hold it
literally
cat videos
and they walk off with the biggest win
ever because
the messy part of me kind of went some
foolishness like that to announce it
loud wow they just go yeah and we got
games coming out
Justin with the tickets
we we interrupt this showcase degree
and they pairing up to the screen and
have a general reading the paper
the conditions of the CMA surrender is
as follows
sure
look at that hold the love over the
field and Phil has on the dog hoodie
Execute order 66.
anyway what I'm talking about I get my
voice over quickly I can't top that that
was crazy yeah for me that was hilarious
for me um it's all about that Xbox draft
class the 2018. you know we need to see
what you've been cooking it's been been
a while and we need you to show well you
know we need to me it's all about the
presentation day everything's lined up
just showcase well so I'm with y'all you
know obviously you know we all
predicting for the most part Fable is
going to be there showcase it you know
Maddie's bad booties comments you know I
think they they're really excited about
it you know what they want to show in
for them to do that level of promotion
with compulsion huge fan as Rand said
you know they got a new community
manager we had the former Community
manager on on IOP at the time and that's
when they broke um Shelton amazing she
broke the um there it was third person
you know kind of over here energy so
that excited us and they need we need to
know what they're doing we need to know
what I remember that that podcast
specifically she's like I don't think
this has been League
that's the home girl miss you hope
everything is good
um and Exile I need to know what Brian
fall going to team I need you out there
I need to what's going on these are the
makers of wasteland they've been very
active on social media they've been
really you know involved with every Xbox
game Studio release and remember this is
the creator of Fallout people forget
before but the indexes right I think
they're one of the most underrated you
know Acquisitions well see if I if I if
I remember the history correctly them
um and it was they used them Bethesda or
the the corporate as the uh Exile
entertainment and obsidian used to all
be wonderful
broke up that team right those those
three together is insane and now and
it's crazy they're all on the Xbox crazy
bro crazy so look I'm with plume um
initially I didn't I love Tango Tango's
my my rosin Star right now you know what
I'm saying I think people really
obviously we already know what Hi-Fi
rush but people really sleeping on what
Ghost Rider Tokyo's potential could be
and at first initially ran when we did
the prediction show with you and Duke I
said no because I was like look Tango
already did high five they good but then
shout out to our men Tom in the city if
he's in the chat shout out to you kind
of broke something about these you know
the steam leaks so to me that's a huge W
thanks Tom you made my video right
tomorrow fat bro that would be huge to
show DLC for one of the sleepers hits on
Xbox one of the brightest new IPS that
they have at a complete unique genre
meant to have DLC content and let's be
honest they get some money on the back
end too because people go back
how much you want to bet that they come
out there announce
uh the the expansion and then follow
that up with the a teams game whoa that
would be crazy
yes please I didn't get to this yes
please do you think is any stealth drops
during this show like um at least at
least maybe one of the code at least
once at least I think
um
uh Fallout 4 current gen yeah they have
announced that yes or if any of the
collections that y'all mentioned I think
those craft Ray tracing
yeah can I please have that already
and that is uh Mr
um my booty that's where he's from it's
original again somebody hit me in the DM
uh and I'll be remiss if I didn't say
this yeah the grandfather that just
recently passed oh my condolences I'm
gonna answer your question right here on
here brother
asks uh his his mic drop moment would be
uh Arc system work developing Killer
Instinct
I hope man I don't even play Fighters
but I know like hey Mega they want that
yeah
it's like Phil just do it for the
fighting Community they need a studio
associated with it was that his question
King no yeah that was it uh he just it
was basically a statement yeah
um that was his mic drop moment and I
talked with him so much and he was
really depressed uh this week so I just
wanted to do that for you brother yeah a
whole lot better no doubt we got to take
care of the community
um yeah um Halo infinite you gotta
restore the feeling you got to get the
energy back in the building I hear what
you're saying rant about the season
content which is probably lined up
perfectly
but I'm with ghosts Man a part of me is
like
God at least show us maybe maybe it is
too early but I'm gonna say this is me
making my prediction I I would like to
see Tatanka there I would like to know
what the concept to Tonka is you know
whether you know Unreal Engine whether
it's war zone or or it's a mix of some
Battle Royale functionality you gotta
have a king and attic will appreciate
that you got Halo needs that taken King
moment
where it started off bad like when
Destiny and then they had this DLC then
you go okay I believe again with all of
this repackaging yeah and all this extra
feature in addition to the seasonal
content then you got people saying okay
they're on their word as far as they're
not giving up when Halo what does
believe uh Pier Heights and those guys
came out make the statement so that's
what I think maybe maybe we're still a
little too early but if Halo infinite is
to be there I like it in that complete
package to really show the reinvestment
um let's get to obsidian the black rock
man I'm with y'all you know um let's be
clear
we've been carrying this [__] for this
series can't something going on over
here I know y'all talking about the
Coalition and all these other dudes
right but when it comes to series
consoles we've been holding this thing
down with our output so I'm very biased
towards the Black Rock obsidian a vowed
man man I I would love to see this here
I think it should be there I would love
shout out to Xbox two shout out to uh
Jazz ran when he you know he said he
doesn't think it's going to be like a
reboot because there was rumors of a
reboot but maybe just kind of like some
refinements some directional things that
they want to do there to really showcase
I think they they know the
not the pressure but what comes with
something in an Elder Scrolls kind of
environment but this is going to be like
pillars of Eternity their take on it and
let's be real it's going to be a while
before we get Elder Scrolls so to see
them have their take on it and I think
there's a little inside competition
because they used to be you know with
Bethesda at one point just showed them
like look this is what our Elder Scrolls
is and it's going to be this generation
and I think they they they definitely do
that
um force is going to be there it's going
to show well we know turn 10 was it's
Ray trace or whatever I think there's
gonna be a ton of game uh third-party
deals and exclusive deals um I agree I
think uh Persona should be there so I'm
not gonna say six so I remember give you
that for now I'm not I'm not bold enough
to go against you there just yet with
six but the three remake makes sense and
again it wasn't on the Sony stage so I
assume the marketing I'll jump out the
window with Kojima again
only because
I know he was dead it was symbolic last
year
but greedy I've been watching you man
you know you've been holding the line
and you're taking pictures with Kojima
and y'all all got the suits on and
you're in the studio you make so to me
why is marketing showing all of this
interesting without so maybe it is just
the again I know it's like yo they just
he just said he's working with Xbox last
time but it is a soda PR's lost ain't
mine I'm gonna go show Fable it's not
gonna be there Kojima he's not gonna say
so my thing is maybe you just say what
the name of the title is and just a
basic concept and then after that we
don't see you for until you got the
actual gameplay but I I do think it's
interesting for them to be showing that
right now because technically we
shouldn't be seeing from y'all you told
us that Kojima is working with you you
got a deal to make a game and go away so
yeah that's that and then um
yeah hellblade tune of course it's you
know I'll steal my starting and I think
with my start
I would like for them to start with
something new
I I feel like I don't want hellblade to
start as impressive it is I'm with soft
I want to build up I want a bill I I
know my heart of hearts I I feel
hellblade is going to cook I feel Fable
especially how confident they sound like
it's gonna cook so I want to build I
I'll say this I'll end with Fable like
they did in that uh 2020 but I want to
build up with a vow with hellblade too
and I want something that we didn't know
about that starts off that looks
graphically impressive that's why I feel
like a vowel is the game because you
start out with hell plays you're going
to get a lot of like ooze was but like a
vowed I feel like it's just no one knows
what that game looks like it's a good
point it's either I I feel like either
if I was gonna end it or close it like
about is such an important IP that it's
got to be one of those and I feel like
hellblade's been on enough stages where
it's easier to be in the middle right I
went hellblade in the middle I don't
want it ending because part of me is
okay I know most likely go get you soon
I mean I would be mad if it ended but I
would I rather like your favorite or
another unknown in it but yeah I'm with
you I'm with your attic on that and look
you know this showcase to me is set up
to be you know at eight minimum it could
be potentially one of the best showcases
all time as far as my mic drop
yeah right they said it man I did
centurions
on me we need the true hero back we need
the Lord who was supposed to be to face
the Xbox oh he was supposed to we need
our Lord and savior Mary who's Titus
dammit please we need him back the girl
oh yeah
they had oh listen I'll I'll get there
but we we need the greatest 900p game of
all time we need it on the Xbox stage
now King I will concede let's just say
the reason why this held up is because
cry Tech the money situation ain't they
didn't get their return back look right
if they if it's multiplied as long as
the marketing and it shows on the Xbox
stage I'm cool now if you want to throw
a Game Pass back on that you know what
I'm saying and make it right with the
community you know what I'm saying you
won't make it right you know that that'd
be your Cog will definitely accept your
apology for getting gay
so look I think the similar symbolism is
there it is it represents that hashtag
just one of a promise unfulfilled and
the Xbox Community cares about this game
I don't care what nobody say so I need
my vibes under more I need that music to
hit and that's where I'm at so um yeah
why's that they come out there they get
they tell you that game pass still with
it all grown man tears for cop don't be
crying I'll be like oh my God this is it
this is the greatest oh my God like Rob
do like I still do playthroughs around
to this dips on the road to the day like
their game is amazing I don't care like
and and of course you know the qte you
know but
save that for like a finisher of a boss
fight or something like that and then go
back to that cry Tech you know what I'm
saying dip down you never play Rush
shame on you go play that now is you
serious yeah you got to play that you
got to play so look we're gonna move
quickly because and then we'll do super
chats after this one which is the fun
part fun part of the Showcase
this showcase will be an l
if
this will disgust you
if so I'm gonna open it up for everyone
let's just go to the Lord's follow the
Lord's first oh The Lord's Prayer let's
go let's go okay I'm gonna go straight
to kick I need to discuss it okay
what would absolutely disgust you the
general they pulled out some nonsense
what would they do to get you fist
though
hmm
what can they do to really piss me off
don't be a bad joke disgustly I can't
believe Xbox did this into showcase
[Laughter]
an absolute disgusting morbid type of
smelly L like that's not even a rake
that's
did that you come out there and be like
well you know being that we had to sign
the CMA to see if they told us we had to
thank you we had to give up you want
Call of Duty you got to get that out
we need to sell over there we need to
cut Europe
like not
um
that will be the most difficult because
you keep smelling L that you can get
because anybody can sit there and say oh
60 frames ain't there and start no none
of that the worst thing that you can
hear is that the person or the person
that you you've been dating exclusively
bungee images in an open relationship
I don't want that I don't want the over
relationship flirting over there
I know I do not want to be dipping in
the pools with other people
don't play like that man that's
unforgivable right there exactly
does this apply to uh if it's not set at
the show but is afterwards like Sony
puts out a thing like look at this great
group
I could just see like Phil and the
executives like tweeting saying that you
know we are so excited to breathe
without you again or do partnership we
want more people to play our games
the Starfield
exclusive
Hold the Line shirt right on camera
I will only accept that
point hold the line they got behind the
line what would you accept it this is
the only way let me hear this the
discount that can be accepted his
is for PlayStation to say starting in
September
Game Pass will be exclusively
so we'll play get gay family places that
game pass existing into the PlayStation
ecosystem we will be removing
PlayStation Plus for the superior
and YouTube can't enjoy the one
dimension today it's a Global Peace
out like he was feisty red just showcase
you're right I'm sorry I got a redhead I
got two Lords first correct
addict I need the disgust the Fable's
not there yeah
no that's not even my number one thing
like my number one thing is if I see
the Halo season two
if we see basketball
the new season
or if I see some VR nonsense Microsoft
is proud to announce
the proud proud to announce that
somewhere else look better already kind
of hits
yo what's up
okay and I would be a little bit
disappointed if the Fable thing was just
like a re a remake or a rematch just a
remake just a little bit disappointed I
love Fable so I I it would calm me down
the moment I started playing
I love it all right so we got a soft
but with disgusts of I don't have
anything that spicy man for me if this
if you have less than 60 60 65 percent
of that show is not first party stuff oh
I'm gonna be bad yeah I know third-party
showcase energy this is your showcase
you have a lot of stuff to show show it
don't hold it don't tell me oh yeah you
know we'll show more of this no I don't
want to I don't hear about Keely I don't
want to hear about the game awards I
don't want to hear about uh what people
call it uh Gamescom oh so you don't want
to you know what the first one we're
gonna show this on their stage you know
what you know what that treatment only
only if you give me a tease or whatever
at the show and then you tell me hey
Xbox extended or whatever you'll get
more of a breakdown beyond that I want
close to 70 of your stuff
that's it and beyond that you know
whatever I think the king's just too
funny I can't even hilarious I can't
even begin to imagine that so that would
be hilarious e for everyone Starfield
you're a lot of thought we've uh we've
decided to congratulate with the CMA and
bring games to Gamers everywhere like
I'm jumping for me um yeah attic said it
best
y'all better not get any bright ideas
from Sony and start showing no movie
showcases and trailers uh we'll see none
of that nonsense don't be showing me the
Fallout TV series no TV TV TV we don't
want that we don't want to see no Halo
Master cheek season two none of that on
Paramount you keep that for your side
stuff on Twitter or a Blog you want to
see the Gears of War show no don't want
to see none of that on that screen keep
that away
um yes if Fable is not there after all
of this teasing on in any capacity
smoke is going to be given so you know
that I better not see couches I better
not see couches the only time I better
see couches is for Starfield direct
maybe because you sit down and you're
doing one game but if I see God sit
there and there's dude sitting in the
car hey guys so what do we think
no I don't want none of that hey guys
hey guys energy
no infomercials no couches no hey guys
um
[Laughter]
that's what I see couches they they roll
out the couch and I see Sarah Bond and
fail in them no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
you know it's always not good when you
see the couch so yeah
listen I was on the couch today Harvey
Smith it was clouded me and we see
without the tribute what about the
trebuchets
no history bring that up come on man
don't take me to that energy so again uh
Indie pacing very critical Cog loves to
Indies but we know how the community is
right so do not put
back to back four in there I don't want
to see like four or five back to back
and then like the Energy starts to you
we just saw that's why we should have a
show for them
let's listen you elitist listen Okay
this game gave discrimination
unless you are of the inside right a
person okay no I don't want to see you
there you don't belong there I will give
you this with your discriminatory
practices
it got to be the creme de La Creme
Indy where you go oh okay that looks
very unique and like replaced right
you're like okay replace you don't plan
on we already saw you know what I'm
saying but you're gonna be there just
hellblade on the two boom valve then one
or two you know what I'm saying like you
gotta you gotta mix the vegetables in
you just can't give a straight vegetable
because you know the hardcore games oh
that's the power of the series X at work
you know how that go when they see as
much as listen Penniman is God tears but
we know how people felt and King clown
he's like this is your king this is this
is your you know what I'm saying because
a lot of people respected that triple A
energy all the time so the Book of Enoch
I don't want to turn to Revelation
chapter four verses
oh
[Applause]
Keep Your Passion of the Christ games at
minimum Ninja
I do not want this one at all keep that
at your couch somewhere else keep keep
that for twitch
I love you I take the Xbox you know I
love you I'm just I'm just talking about
how important and the pacing is for this
showcase so that's pretty much my let's
get the pedal I gotta let me start with
I want to start with dirt man dirt
you know what I gotta be honest man if
if they show some amazing hellblade too
uh uh gameplay and then they don't
announce a release day or even a release
window that will piss me off that'll
piss me off yes to say um he'll play too
and then nothing afterwards you're happy
right
Spider-Man 2 and they said fall 22 guys
yeah they uh if
or even the window like you know this
ain't a year if they didn't do that I
would be I'll be pissed bro this isn't
coming soon
oh man I mean that's pretty much it man
um you guys got some great things that
you said what king said if that happened
you know
my bleeding green will be a little
different at that point I don't know why
I'll still be bleeding greens hey now
stop stop feel for the people what if
the hemorrhaging
let's put up this ridiculous scenario
and that's the only capitulation you got
to give stuff because remember didn't
Bethesda games didn't Saudi initiate see
they they lied and they they said
Bethesda stuff so what if that look to
get Call of Duty get all that Activision
Blizzard Kingdom mobile oh wait wait
even though it's unrealistic let me put
some sauce on it
for the deal to go through right and and
for them to get started
they can release everything in the game
pass that same day but Starfield need to
go come on man why are you doing that we
got to put this you got to put something
else on it okay so you saying all all
the APK games all the APK Game Pass from
effective immediately immediately Sonic
check
I'll be fine if the PS5 version is
gimped oh my God
oh my God
your boy Jim already said if Call of
Duty is better on Xbox we can't recover
dirt you know what it is not only is it
gif you know they get that performance
mode they get the performance mode
resolution
what about it what about it you know
since the EU remedy was basically uh we
have to give these games to anybody with
Cloud what if they get star feel but
only through Cloud oh yeah yeah like
there's no native version of Starfield
on Playstation but like you know they
forced the guy to hide the situation
down I like that that's crazy
there's only there's only if
everything is released you know y'all
can get the [__] version
you know the 720p 30 frames per second
version
oh there you go this is cool that is
cool it's cool purposely sabotage
another platform as long as their
version is [__] it says [__] version
ain't somebody in the chat he said do it
like cycle knots too only a PS4 version
oh man I forgot about that I forgot
about that yeah that's what he said
anyway let's get it available on
Playstation three
it's only available streaming on
PlayStation now oh man it's only
it's online scan mode it's in the loose
I don't think I want to move on
yeah
some amazing predictions very lofty
but I need to yeah
what would you be like Xbox what are you
doing
you guys you guys you guys covered it
all my initial was if they do the movie
things like PlayStation that's like I
don't want to see movies at a game
showcase but I think I think I'm just
gonna go like I'm with Sophia if they
don't have a large section of first
party content I'll be pretty
disappointed because I mean
Jim Ryan has literally opened the door
got it on his knees and said here
we're gonna let you back in we've been
we've been we've been at you for a year
and a half making fun of you everyone
laughing at Xbox without nothing in 2022
and then the delays they've opened the
doors there's like hit back hurts if
they don't hit back hard with this
showcase I'll be I'll be pretty
disappointed not fair enough Fair
reasonable very logical Randazzo
uh what would be an L let's see I mean
similar to what PlayStation did I want
that road map I want that I want to know
what's coming after four is a motorsport
and I don't get that
so now right like if I'm going in there
expecting like hellblade and a vowed and
what's in 2024 I'm like I don't get that
you don't get hell played well it's not
even flip Well yeah if hellblade's not
there or whatever or vowed there but has
no gear attached to it or whatever and
like if the question still persists
after the show about what the hell is
coming after Forza Motorsport straight
up L
um like I I gave the PlayStation show
like a c but it was just PlayStation
content it was a d it'd be even worse
for Xbox because I actually care about
Xbox I don't care about PlayStation in
that way right so it's like I want the
road map and you know they I think they
need to deliver on that um obviously I
don't want to see any TV [__]
unfollow TV show gear stuff Halo Master
cheeks we don't need that here you wanna
have it at an extended showcase yes fine
by that exactly okay what whatever
that's cool none of that stuff I also
if the kind of what plume and soft
saying like if the mix is more geared
towards third party in Indies and less
towards first party
that's not going to fly with me either
not when you have all these Studios not
when you have all these games already
announced
uh I'm not tuning into Xbox showcase and
only seeing three games and I guess
maybe even I'll expand on that like just
go if you show me more games as a
service that already exists than like
games that are yet to be released you
get to see at these ESO I like it if
it's like the whole bag it's like you
show Halo infinite and grounded and
Fallout 76 and Elder Scrolls online and
uh uh you know sea of Thieves right but
I but you only show like hell blade and
the vowed or whatever I'd be like uh uh
I'm uh you know that wouldn't be good
for me I I don't know if it would be
good for the rest of you but that
definitely would like I'd look at that
and be like really
uh that you know so yeah
um yeah those are the main thing for me
is the roadmap you know because I was on
Sony for that it's like what's what are
we looking like after Spider-Man 2 right
and it's like I would be the same with
Xbox like what is what's next after
Forza I got wolf tell me I want to know
what's coming 2024. let me know for you
okay if they start the show they
probably will come out and the queen
comes out so Queen the Queen's hairball
affectionately
she comes out and she says
she says
I got a bad joke
and she says from this point on
everything you see we released in the
next 12 months and that's that's insta
that's no that's in style bro
ldm dirt and I'll be like sorry I ain't
showing up next tomorrow
expectations in check it just just just
if they were gonna do that they should
say that on Twitter right now by the way
the Showcase is uh gonna be featuring
games for the next 12 months just to let
you know so we would all know
because here we are being like Fable
Fable Fable right everyone poor addicts
gonna have a conniption oh he's gonna
lose it he gonna throw tomatoes live man
once they show the 12 months because
fake was coming out 12 months
said what if they actually hit like what
if they learned the lesson from the last
time and they're not listening to Todd
because Todd really messed up the 12
months right and then we you know you
can't really say you know um with with
stalker too that was something that's
yeah that's the life it is happening
there yeah
um and a couple of games kind of missed
a mark but for the main part those two
games that were supposed to launch in
those 12 months and besides Forza you
know
if they hit the smart what if they
actually get the Cadence and they can
actually deliver on this and they do say
that I mean plume does have a a valid
point there what if they do hit what
about the mood and the energy when
people hear 12 it takes away a lot of
the Wonder people it takes a lot
especially after last year like great
some people here 12 and be like Boo most
people say boo and then most of them
targets was not hit it's not the problem
they said 12 and they hit the door
unless you know what kind I I think we
want to I mean like we know some of that
road map now obviously
but we haven't got any new announcements
for the roadmap in in the field right it
says 2021 so it's about time for us to
get at least one or two new games that
has been unannounced so that's why the
12 month thing unless it's one of those
new like new games coming in in 12
months but it's here in 12 months uh now
oh man I feel so that's it ran out those
are the the final discussions I mean I
don't I mean I don't think they'll do 12
months I mean Phil was even asked about
that and he's like you got and Paris was
even kind of careful to tiptoe around it
like and then Phil was like no we
straight up didn't deliver you know I
don't think they're gonna put themselves
in that situation again
all right well we gave us this 12-month
Target because game development's tricky
man things happen but they said we know
we didn't meet the 12 months last year
but we're gonna do it again this year
you know I expect for as a motorsport to
be there but are we sure it's getting
release date I mean yeah Spider-Man 2
didn't even get a release date
let's get a big stuff here no I feel you
I feel where you're going no this is
that was it you know what you know what
oh let's go I kind of want Starfield to
go to PlayStation just to see king after
meltdown
it happened then you know what really
happened so I will turn that loss until
when yeah
I will melt it down into brass knuckles
the right oh no and they they push it
out of September
appreciate the paddle coming through now
obviously we do have one more time but I
gotta be respectful for everyone's time
cause we gotta read the super chats so
if anybody has to leave please let me
know now so I can give you a nice outro
on the way how we doing plume dirt rant
how you guys got doing because I believe
respectful we all know we're super happy
I'm jumping bro
I'm gonna be watching King on the
sidelines for this one you already know
red out thought of there with the video
my brother always a pleasure to have you
in the realm the man with the million
came through with the smoke all this
world tour damn near Six podcasts I feel
like I've podcast you for 10 hours
probably literally we mean you have
literally
no doubt where can I find people find
you what you got going on sir I mean you
could find me
youtube.com19 the YouTube channel Xbox
twos on Friday not with jazz this week
because Jazz is going to be in La you're
gonna you're gonna be able to yeah
he might be king bed Jazz before I've
never met Jess for real yeah so uh we'll
have Xbox two on Friday with uh with a
guest and then you know I'll be
streaming the show on Sunday and videos
or whatever comes to mind but yeah
thanks for having me on again it's
always a pleasure to be here even though
you called me at 11 30 be like you up
yet yeah he was on Chicago time I had to
make sure I was just like all right well
all right but uh have a great rest of
the show King I look forward to your
thoughts on uh Ratchet and Clank coming
to peace I thought that was impossible
yo you know something impossible this is
crazy you know you are my um I like I
nominate you for uh for tribute all the
time yeah so anytime somebody call out
my gaming score oh yeah
I like to nominate Rand
I said my Champion is here
where is
the fair enough that boy be killing it
blessings bro no doubt Ray have a good
one brother Dirk flew him how you
holding them I just want to be
respectful plume how you doing I'm gonna
have to head out soon my wife just got
home so I got a fan
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah you
got the look
at the house
Network man again a pleasure to have you
in the room love the takes love the
content very informative you know what
I'm saying you're out here killing it
bro that it was a pleasure to have you
in the room we'll have you back again
where can I find people find you what
you got going on Sir yeah first of all I
appreciate you guys having me on give me
this platform talk about the predictions
this is going to be a huge show next
week so extremely excited for that but
you can find me uh plume Network YouTube
Twitter Facebook Instagram and all those
places oh no doubt brother get enjoy
your Sunday look forward to hearing from
you again it was great I watch the
videos all the time yeah he comes up
with my feeds again I saw him on attic
more funds gaming you they good on five
questions bro you killed that all right
um
I'm okay uh
look at the smile look at my boss when
it's time for the Super Chat okay
this is gonna be real messy
he analyzed the subject matter and he
knew the smoke that was going to be
given but he said you know what I might
need to stay for this one
though I know what dirt is about so look
let's get to the Super Chat song and
then we got that final topic and DJ
auros no we're not doing three more
questions first yeah because we did
because they were relevant to the to the
top oh you just oh you just want to okay
together let's just do them all together
okay so just go to the next topic and
then okay do the next topic fair enough
you're right you're right you're right
because then we we got it then
yeah yeah okay super chats again we we
respect we knew it was gonna be a crazy
show so apologies but we're going to
read all of them so look this is a
king's topic he on the Xbox prediction
series he demanded this topic be read so
um yeah Ratchet and Clank shot The Game
Informer Rift apart jumps to the steam
Dimension this July so it was made
announced the chair is laughing at the
uh first party PlayStation title is
making the jump uh to steam on July 26
making the series first appearance on PC
the 2021 Dimension hopping Adventure
served as one of the earliest Showcases
of the PlayStation 5 Tech namely its
fast loading SSD and the PC versus King
stop laughing Sports additional bells
and whistles such as performance
enhancing upscaling of Nvidia DLS S3
why has he got a belt AMD fsr2 and Intel
xcss unlock frame rate retrace
Reflections and shadows Ultra wide
support developer Nixon
developer Nexus so you didn't even know
who they was until they started making
PC Plus you're a liar
don't try to Champion nixes you were
ridiculous candy whoever you want to I
tried you know it's funny though I did
try to reach out to Nixon to see if they
have all merch and see if I can buy a
shirt and get it to you because that's
because you just reached out to me and
they picked up a hold of line yeah they
said we'll be handling the PC Port of
this acclaimed action platformer so can
this is your topic you couldn't wait to
talk about yourself
yes okay
can you dig it
that the Warriors not the Warriors we
know
we got it 1 400 plus strong in the room
we did 50 away from a thousand likes
Kings
let's go
I told you you weren't special
I told you your so-called SSD wasn't as
fast as you thought
the SSD that can solve World Peace the
SSD that could do everything oh my God
it was a glorified pull button
s
pull the dimension of the character
that's what we do it we don't have a
jump we have a pull button
no I told you it was gonna happen to you
nothing in your box is special you don't
believe in exclusives anymore
a joke
that proves it
couldn't be getting you weren't special
how special you are look at you now
[Laughter]
look at you now reference I mean
Christopher Hall used to come at you
hard about this oh man it's exclusive
and he's not a champion
yeah because the reason why I rock belt
I'm not
I knock guys out all the time with your
same words
next is your ears remember Mark 36 give
me your ears
let me smell your breath oh oh
not the blowing the controller come on
don't do that y'all was blowing into the
controller running around with facts
they about to do the DUI thing with the
controllers
[Laughter]
it's like you breathe into it it just it
just beeps and turns off the place
I can't with you right now
box yo
this has been the greatest moments you
guys I swear man y'all talking about
Xbox stepping on rakes come on man there
you go
refrigerators thrown on their heads
just reminds me what about you I'm a
Road Runner cartoon y'all Wally coyote
boy
y'all are running at the doors y'all are
stepping on Race y'all doing the best
you can to make this the greatest
Generation ever this is how you lose a
generation and for every one of you Sony
dudes that was talking about this SSD
and this is ratcheting Clique it can
only be done
box the PC said hold my beer
I'm gonna do it a little bit clearer a
little bit faster and a little bit
better than you and shout out to nixes
for being exactly who I thought they
were
oh this Valentine's Day was brought to
you by nixes
clearly your heart they've delivered
they seem to be doing these PC Sports
better than anyone from PlayStation
about uh the game being done better
than the platform that said it can only
be done
please oh
the kid kick his [__] he couldn't
wait I suggest start go next yes I I
agree dirt's waited for this look look
let me just say this let me say this oh
God the pony said to us
this SSD
is so Superior to Xbox series X's SSD
that the Xbox SSD was going to hold back
the generation
it's going to hold back multi-platz I
had to do hit me up in the conversation
say dirt
the PlayStation 5 SSD is so powerful
it's going to make the frames run better
oh God I have a receipt y'all think I
have a receipt you got the receipts I
said this dude can't be serious what
does that even mean I have no idea 2020
was wild y'all when when they found out
that that the PlayStation 5 is Chronicle
has a superior SSD oh they ran with it
they ran with it they said oh God fault
it's only possible
yeah that was dude the lumens era and
the unreal only can be done ever oh my
God I know you know I know you don't do
the cons of War stuff but you see it
that's it you see some of the things
said
the whole engine was exclusive
now here we go
Ratchet and Clank
it's only possible on the PS5 they was
bashing PC said the PC can't run his
backs they had the PC Master race
Community hot I've never seen them so
angry at PlayStation fans all
of you PlayStation fanboys
look at yourselves
look at the stuff you said over the past
three years you should be ashamed of
yourself
the stuff that y'all said this name
Beatles
remember this last generation in 2016
when when Microsoft announced they're
putting their games on PC
[Music]
they beat our legs why do I need an Xbox
you're right why do I need Xbox right
there's no value for the cops right it's
devalued even some Xbox fans were
struggling Xbox fans were some Xbox fans
are really struggling with that that
concept of going to people and they did
it for years of PlayStation doesn't need
to put their games on PC that game
sailed unlike Xbox
now look what's going on now oh God
y'all I love it this is payback for
y'all y'all was holding these you've
been both holding on to this oh my God
my legs was beat for four straight years
so now exclusive don't matter
okay
we build the mouse
let's go this is there is no surprise
when another PlayStation exclusive is
announced for PC at this point there's
no surprise right but you still got some
of these guys losing their mind
what's wrong with y'all
I got a question being that we finalized
that SSD portion of this uh thing is a
lie do you think Spider-Man 2 could be
done on the PlayStation 4 oh are you
asking me for that game
that game that I saw last week and it
run on the PS4 yeah I'm pretty sure that
was PS4 Pro footage
[Music]
so I got a podcast on Monday evening
it's called wbg means Weebly green Xbox
podcast you know we have a lot of fun
over there
um you know PlayStation fan boys you
might not be too welcome like I banned
all 15 to Chris Hart accounts
so yeah man you know just check out my
channel you know I have a lot of fun I
Am pro Xbox
it's called a pony free zone now if
you're a PlayStation fair you want to
come in and talk and chit chat that's
fine but if you're in there just Xbox is
trash y'all trash and you gone
oh you don't you don't tolerate any
insulates hey we got an echo chamber man
oh so we we are promoting the echo
Channel
okay so like before I leave every say
this so I saw I'm lost podcasts I see
ran I see deal I see boom I see Cody's
well I say you know what
they got that style the podcast locked
down imma go this way you do it you're
okay let's go this way yeah now now I
know so like no I know that some people
might not rock out with me I might not
bit them like you know big interviews
but it's okay we're gonna have fun you
know what I'm saying you know I've been
growing so I respect you be two reasons
one you're honest about that two you can
you can go you can move what's that jet
line that Jay-Z you can move in a room
you could move it anywhere and still
adapt and that's what I love about you
you know what I'm saying and salute to
you you got a great show awesome and
you're hilarious so thank you for for
you thank you man putting your suit on
in the eye opener because I know this is
that what you normally do but I'm glad
you know for people who want a little
bit more spice they they go W definitely
spicy over there man I appreciate you
guys man keep doing your thing you know
you guys are the best man thank you man
I appreciate it enjoy your Sunday
brother you already know
putting his Twitter in the chat yeah
yeah yeah yeah
thanks
revenge is the
dishes delicious
shout out to you guys
it is what it is at this point you know
he said the whole slate for a reason all
right like I guess they thought it was
the only slate but for some reason PC
couldn't run PlayStation 5 games
I can assure you PC can run them all
right that is gonna be interesting yeah
I can't wait to see when that God of War
Ragnarok hits the platform well the
regular God Awards there and the other
one's just DLC the same thing this is
the one they was holding up talking
about I honestly be done here yeah
when it happened I really didn't think
so many people was gonna get upset over
it like I thought it was going to be one
of those things where people like look
at this point we're used to this so
we're just gonna rock we're gonna rock
it out but like there was people
generally like believed that that
couldn't run on a PC old facts oh yeah
what was that um that loopy uh game
where she was in space and she dies and
all returnable remember how it can only
be done because you know that's a co-op
Game King we should play that together
yeah we got to do that we should play it
on the PC too
yo shout out to to to
um the the Miles Morales movie I just
saw on Friday yes
um and and just this is a small little
minor Easter egg but when uh miles goes
back to his dorm room and Yankees
playing on his PlayStation
he's playing Spider-Man but he's playing
it on his PC did you notice that song Oh
no I didn't he had it he had a dual
shock uh PlayStation 5 controller which
work on the PC but he was playing on his
PC yeah I didn't see a PS5 I didn't see
a PS5 that's true
it was on this PC shout out to Sony
letting you know the road map of the
future
solve your thoughts suddenly yeah you
know what's funny oh yeah the whole
Discovery was always an idiotic tick and
it's just you see the extent to which
Fanboy is and takes people but it I to
me it's funny because we I saw this and
King was like we're doing this I'm like
I thought this is old news already
because for me for me though moment they
said yeah put these hard drives in your
PlayStation 5 and it's the same yeah
that was that was a year ago already or
longer I was like I'm not they lied to
us the moment you said they did your
same hard drive that goes right into
your PC you can put right into your
PlayStation and go do the same thing it
was a wrap I was like oh I knew it was a
lie so this is just the perfect
exemplification of it because it is this
particular game yeah that was about it
but for me in my mind this was already
folded a long time ago because I was
like all right it's not like you saying
this proprietary thing that you can
attach to the PlayStation kind of like
the Xbox to proprietary but
no they said hey these Samsung
plug that in and you're good to go
they've done so it's old news but it's
particularly funny because this is the
game this is the game they were like can
I be done it's jumping world's tour and
it is it is literally a pull mechanic um
yeah very very funny I'll jump it right
in look shout out to the marketing team
for PlayStation like shout out to the
boss because you know they they really
were pushing this as as a feature you
know I got to give King you know how to
do the messy stuff but King is right you
know at the end of the day they got the
base to believe
that this technology that they're using
is so Advanced it's it's more Superior
than anything on PC and PC Master race
dudes we're not we're not we're not
having it and you basically they were
definitely inhaling that code and you
best believe the PC Master X committee
is about to fully test this game on
release they're going to test every spec
I'll be victorious saw but I'm curious
like how you feel on
non-ssds oh no that's the first thing
they're gonna do bro the first thing
they're going to do on a regular old
yeah
they're gonna break out the old
mechanical Drive bro let's see how this
runs on this they're definitely shout
out to I think you know who said
something like that too shout out to oh
no it's Alan I think he said he can't
wait to test it on a mechanical that
will be interesting
yeah I doubt this but it'd be crazy if
it runs almost just as good oh that
would be great it was exactly the same I
don't think I run exactly the same yeah
my man Gene magic G he said they're
using Ram like returnal yeah yeah so
look we'll see it's going to be put
through the gamut let's just say
fraternal like bass on the piece like
base they say that you need 32 gigs of
RAM or something like that that is never
the recommended spec like it's always
that you know 8 16 it was 16. well when
you say the recommended Baseline to run
this you need you need 32 gigs of RAM
yeah yeah PC Lords are going to be
outside they're gonna test that but
shout out to shout out to King's heart
Nexus man they got these ports they you
know what's crazy their points be really
no Nexus this is what they're doing this
is what they do they if you notice they
didn't really have a hand and The Last
of Us
they were working on this apparently
apparently Alex said in one of his
videos like Nexus is one of the better
yeah of course that's King's
PlayStations
if you listen I know a lot of
PlayStation Studios do listen to the
show um please I would love merch for
Nexus so I could buy for my man so he
can support y'all he's the biggest fan
that's his heart that's just hard right
greatest Studio ever made get you need
to get you could probably go on uh that
website that you can like have people
custom making yeah okay we're gonna have
to make one yeah yeah so what you what
you do know you know the Iron Man chess
piece thing you just have Nexus this is
hard this is hard no that's all I got
man so salute to this salute the cake
for being messy for flooding to force
this onto this that's my predictions
you were missed last week so clearly you
have I mean because goal posts be moved
every day B
SSD okay
one narrative to move on to the next I'm
gonna say this on one topic we're not
going to the topic but
um the Jason schreier
Dreadful that breakdown on redfall
two things it made me terrified that
whatever Arcane is now is not the team
that can make the games that I love I
know I don't I don't think I don't think
that's it now that's that's scary
because they have so much so much well
there's two different there's Archie
Leone and Arcane Austin but it but in
general they just had so many people
leaving because they thought they
thought that that type of games they
were making just not aren't getting
amazing so what you're saying is you
feel like they lost some good talent
trying to make redfall
even that even death Loop because death
Loop isn't really yeah it's it's it's
kind of that one told the line more than
redfall does right
um so you still had that you had more of
that but that it might be done man which
is scary to me bro I don't know maybe
they get them back when they they hear
okay with making Dishonored three or
something like that but um
I told you what that game when we talked
about the game after it released the
words out of my mouth were that this
game should not exist and it's and this
game is nobody's passion project and
that's a harsh thing to say but we turn
out to be right we turned out
ah and we turned out to be right with
the lack of you know the involvement um
hands-off involvement and we we turned
out to be right with you know the way
the situation with Bethesda was handled
like a lot of people's heart wasn't in
it they lost direction as far as where
it's going to be right and then yeah it
came out to where it came out well the
funny part I felt was that when people
said the acquisition happened people
were holding Microsoft was canceled some
of them
oh yeah they're here against we condemn
this like
it goes to show you that yeah Phil
definitely died on the sword he took the
bullet for that as like King said like
the leadership dude you know we felt it
what's funny is that shot to Jake but I
everything we said with to me was
justified all of us said this so I was
it was one of those things where I read
it I was not surprised in the least
minus like one or two things about how
much they didn't want to work on it and
how many people left when they found out
that it was going to be this multiplayer
thing that said I'm actually on the top
was trying to force and remember this is
that that pre-acquisition mindset
nothing selling let's be honest and this
is the thing I had to tell Maddie I
don't even want to hear it but he agreed
is that the problem with them at the
time before about that's why I'm Lord
acquisition by the way the problem with
them before acquisition was as great as
prey was decided wasn't all those games
they didn't sell
they didn't sell that's the sad reality
so now brass is like all right what's
popping at the time fortnite rainbow 16.
we got to do something panic mode hits
in now they Infuse this mentality into
the studios to put this thing out as
this discontent this discourse and
that's why if think about this if
Microsoft doesn't acquire zenimax what
happens what happens whatever out of
here is what happens yeah I know that's
the thing about it they none of it like
young young blood failed yeah
um Young Blood failed then you had death
Loop which again it tows that line right
I lost 70 cents before Fallout 76
miraculously they didn't do it to ghost
wire which which is kind of miraculous
they didn't touch ghost wires and then
you have like even though that I didn't
particularly liked what I saw a
ghostwire I do think enough people
believed in the game that got it pushed
over yeah absolutely absolutely yeah but
no people did like it I loved it I see
the potential but the general emphasis
behind the community was redfall was
extremely disappointing to a lot of
people and that's why I don't get it
caught up in all this oh consolidation
is the death of the industry you want
them to go away you want them to die
then okay as a polio dying exactly I'm
only against consolidation if you're
consolidating and you're messing Studios
up correct look sure there's been
incidences where you know you can look
at
stuff that Microsoft saw in the past
sure you know but it's like you know
people like to look at rare rare is
making cfds and and ever while and you
can argue that see these has been more
successful success games combined
exactly so again I'm not saying
Acquisitions everything is perfect and
that there's no chance of mismanagement
of course that could happen anything but
again like Saul was saying what is the
alternative if you are feeling and
making wow yeah yeah I just laugh
because there's people that's uh um
against Acquisitions because their
Studios can't do it like yeah well what
it is against Acquisitions when it's on
the team that they don't like
they're not a fan of them
Acquisitions when when the this uh the
company that they ride and die for can't
afford with the competition exactly
because if it go to their team
everybody's all good it's all good
there's no problem oh because because
they'll take care of it the right way
yeah we will do it the right way the
pure way to do things yeah sure but
anyway so that's what I got I'm gonna
get super chance man get these super
chats and never get out of here
I actually cut and erased the ones that
we already did and still a lot uh we got
Cappy blappy five dollar Super Chat Xbox
has shown many games since uh 2020 and
hasn't seen hasn't been seen since with
all the first party games you think
they're gonna show everything saved up
copia I certainly hope they do right
that's pie in the sky but I hope they
show everything but we say that every
year
it's no more back slap remember for two
years ten dollar Super Chat DPS couldn't
get the prediction video done in time
but here but here are guaranteed
predictions hellblade 2 opens a show
with gameplay slash release date it's
softer or it's software with a Punisher
FPS oh okay and by the way Bungie is
still overrated
then we got Freddy Fox in the building
Freddy Fox
let me see
[Music]
Freddy Fox Five Dollar Super Chat I'll
be at the AMC and NYC next week for the
Xbox Showcase in full gear with my Hold
the Line shirt Show hellblade 2 Combat
gameplay and it's over
blessings thank you so much we
appreciate you yeah I'm aware of I hold
the line shirt when I go to the
conference yeah hopefully mine here
then we have Adidas 20 zero ten dollar
two for chat Sony state of Agony showed
us third exit third party Xbox games now
Xbox will show us first party in a week
a second what's up big p and Randall in
the house with uh King and dirt this is
an All-Star Game paddle no doubt yes it
was then we got Phase 23 became wide 100
Super Chat wow thanks brother blessings
Spider-Man 2 gameplay trailers have
passed 20 million views between
PlayStation and Marvel will Spider-Man 2
overshadow Star field in September I
can't wait for these first party games
to go head to head this year hey man
nope it won't
you got a one game that's being sold in
one place where people don't buy games
and you have another one
where the game is going to be on Game
Pass is going to be on PC it's going to
be on Xbox the law of averages and
numbers tell you that you can't win that
battle and you're gonna say yeah King
but uh Spider-Man is gonna sell 10
million in three days ah your numbers be
looking funny Under The Lights
I don't ever believe you guys
moving on green blood Network five
dollars I love plume Network he delivers
consistent content and value to his
supporters amazing panel dirt's voice
hit the like button for IOP No Doubt
let me see let me see let me see Adidas
20. and we got put the crust in the chat
for Adidas 20 zero remember new member
to the realm Lord bronze
then we got Jacob J
remember for one year five dollars which
had Xbox about to rip the trachea out of
PlayStation neck at this showcase
Patrick Swayze Patrick's crazy Roadhouse
style happy Sunday Lord It's dirt what
up
shout out to the Roadhouse reference I
like that I like that pixel bit g2000
Super Chat Xbox three Xbox treats his
Gamers as first class citizens hashtag
game fast
Sony has porn stars fam going to be uh
going to be cultured uh
shout out to form Stars
Dragonheart yo me ridiculous slime like
the game remember for one year is that
dollar Super Chat um Jim's Vision he's
copying what Xbox did years ago and they
got clowned for it some of a few people
are praising that showcase but destroyed
Xbox for that same thing
know how it is
it's too early right when they doing it
exactly and it was too early it was too
early to be telling people about stuff
like that we got Robert Kelly Super Chat
after Zelda and Jedi no one complaining
about 30 FPS
is Jedi 30fps on Xbox 60 and 30. but um
I don't know what are you talking about
with that Zelda that zeld is 24. it's
okay
there we got this part in six six one
two dollars we chat they need to show
Starfield on both Xbox series s and not
PC I agree
black Ronin three five seven five
thousand chat sup Lords what if other
big names are shown uh doing 60 FPS on
series X like hellblade and Fable but
Starfield isn't is it still bad um
hellblade was probably gonna be a
smaller game so that makes more sense
Fable running at 60
um is telling because it's an RPG right
it's a bigger game but Starfield stands
to be a much bigger game than both of
those it doesn't matter to me either way
yeah Lord meyerhoof with the 20 oh damn
I hadn't looked this up so I don't know
IDR twenty thousand rdrs thank you it
should be captured on series X from the
start yes it should be 100
Spartan gold 17 two pound stupid chat
I'm still on the fence for Starfield
quality
uh we'll see we will see you next Sunday
karma karma God 91 five dollars for chat
King David I know you got to deal with
Xbox for hold I know you gotta deal with
Xbox for Hold the Line movement to make
an appearance turn up Islands
that'll be what's up King will secretly
appear at the at the Showcase next week
that would be sadly uh not happening
then we have acute perspective member
for six months five dollars to be chat
star field is the Starfield is the title
that Stony tried buying exclusivity on
for their PlayStation consoles from
Bethesda Studios and was denied
yep it was promised to fail
then we have dub member for 16 months
Lord Browns shout out to the panel as
always I'm late tuning in but if I but
if it hasn't been touched upon already
what would y'all be dreaming what would
be y'all's dream announcement something
unexpected I need my rise
then we have jax 82 two dollar Super
Chat is a series of 30 FPS is the series
s a 30 FPS machine or can it do more it
can do more depending on the game and
depending on the work they put into it
right
then we got Kevin Baldwin two dollar
Super Chat hot take prediction Xbox paid
for spawn will show it okay okay
got it
Dragon heart you'll be better for what
year five dollar Super Chat I just want
Phil to open his mind to working on IPS
that are not owned by Microsoft I want
to see Punisher by Coalition and black
panther by obsidian damn Chris out there
not about all the superhero stuff hater
yeah for real I'm not saying hey let's
see how Wolverine turns out it's gonna
be great
stash Gordon remember for 13 months Lord
bronze unrealistic mic drop Fantasy Star
one through four pixel remastered
collection like Final Fantasy all
dungeons redone in first person like
yeah like Fantasy Star one oh wow see me
in the clouds with that that'd be
awesome okay I like that
then we have
Uhuru two dollar super chat project Mara
question question could be dirt said
that he's hoping to see something from
that yeah then we
then we have jax 82 10 super chat we
will hold the line on June 11th pack
your bags Jim Ryan we coming through and
we not slowing down we're not backing
down we busting through you had the
chance and blew it no redo it's over
Xbox one this is all one sentence
hilarious maybe you got Brett Bingham
too loud super chat a rise to
announcement would be fired
that was the music Brett Bingham five
dollar Super Chat Phil did say
collections with an S of games not
collection of games I think gears Fable
Fallout or Elder Scrolls collections
could be a thing could be be magnificent
then we got lady Foxfire five dollar
Super Chat I can see them doing the
Fable remake trailer gameplay and then
teaser like they did with Halo Master
Chief Collection slash Halo 5 and gears
uh Ultimate Edition and gears four
teasers much love guys yeah I forgot
that they did that in that way so yeah
it's possible 100 then we have kkj wars
85 new member put the crust in the chat
Lloyd gold appreciate that
then we got a perfect heretic with the
10 SARS that don't sorry didn't look it
up don't know what it is but thank you
appreciate that
actually but he said Elder Scrolls six
anyone oh yeah I think I think now
though nah they already did that earlier
and right now Starfield time exactly
then we got Lord Metroid member for 20
months Lord silver
I disagree with addict on tears of the
Kingdom because you know he's bugging
and wrong at the same time damn why you
gotta be bugging animal game of the year
taking bets now let's play some Street
Fighter six let's pick music man I just
I just got one thing to say to you I
just tell you not what you want to hear
what you think
I see what you doing then we have GSD
getting stuff done remember for one year
five dollar Super Chat thanks for the
tea suggestion I'm going to wear all
Natty for the show like like Pooh bear
no dance with my buddies wait who said
that who said that I like that getting
stuff done I approved that
no because they're using little
references yeah what if that's that's oh
black that's that's somebody we know he
uses a very key IOP after dark
references
with Justin Valaria right
no underwear that's that's different
that's different
then we got ever born psycho five
dollars to pretend after the show the
new narrative will be exclusives are bad
for gamers and they shouldn't be praised
hashtag Hold the Line hashtag free
knockout oh and all right
he said and no need to skip the line
when you can be the oh okay hold on no
because everyone send me something oh
okay okay commemorate the new
relationship he wants them to announce a
new handhold variant of the series
that's called Game Gear X oh my God he
got he got the Sega ties ready
shout out to you dinaka about to do two
and a half years
he tried to free the whole of it he
tried to feed the homies right there
then we got bow and slave the whole B
two dollar Super Chat anyone anyone
think the rock Ally will make an
appearance it makes absolute sense
nobody mentioned it but it's true the
rock Ally comes out with the following
Monday yeah it does come out Tuesday
time yeah it comes out after the
Showcase yeah that would be interesting
it makes sense
for people to play yeah that makes sense
then we have Spartan go 17 two pound
Super Chat 1090 Jake got all the
snitching reports on Deck
oh
there we go Robert kill it two dollars
to the chat General King do we see Phil
nuke Sony headquarters like I gotta drop
it wow
Hiroshima okay all right pause it shows
up shots fired yeah
we got hargit to knee one member for one
year two dollars in the chat L if
there's any movie TV crap only games yes
in agreement
and we got JD gamer remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat I don't
want fabled or hellblade ending it those
are already believed to be there and I
need we got one more thing surprise rise
to or Killer Instinct yeah okay okay
that's why I didn't put them any one of
those games I know what you're doing
something new you'll see what you do
Robert kellett two dollar Super Chat
telling the little guy to sit in the
back damn whoa I don't know what that
was a restaurant maybe maybe little man
little man probably yeah that was a
little man
then we got loose side well you're gonna
have to send it back for that 30 FPS
that's just
we got Lucifer with 6.66 donation thank
you for the Demonic donation
Microsoft to come out with the Xbox
bidet toilet for fans that are sick of
their crap wow
slanderous
then we have let's play with each
other's joints
five dollar Super Chat the only thing
that I want to see coming soon is soft
oh whoa whoa whoa
sir yeah yeah Jesus come on now you're
messing with my meal come on man
that's why the screen is off and I'm
muted
JP 45 remember for two years put the
crust in the chat from Lord bronze
appreciate that Noob Saibot then we got
crazy horse with the two dollars to
attached Starfield coming to Playstation
you on YouTube okay yeah on YouTube wow
then we got Rel ski remember for two
months Lord Browns dirt is that guy if
you don't already make sure to tune in
to uh hashtag wbg TTS hashtag IOP is the
best Xbox podcast as well thank you King
absolute
[Laughter]
I can't wait to play Ratchet and Clank
on my HDD exclusively
old school hard drive testing yes all
right so let's see if we get anything
else after that
got jumped a little bit let me see I'm
just going to read backwards
um we got Lord Metroid two dollar Super
Chat Naka don't drop the soap oh run
like Sonic yo don't be talking like that
to the legend when we talking like that
man man fight the case
I'll find the case right there cool then
we got free R Kelly Two Dollars to the
chat by the way been watching you guys
for two years he said something bro
[Laughter]
no no he's being nice and I respect the
fact that he's locked up and he's been
down for two years
then we got smoke three show uh with the
2.20 uh Super Chat yo King any good cat
games
um hopefully
we don't have any cat games this week
well don't we when is isn't straight out
already or Xbox yes we're getting there
right in Game Pass if it ain't a Game
Pass I want to hear about it yeah and I
think they get him I don't know if it's
no no it's coming to Game Pass oh it is
talking about it oh I didn't know that
oh they got to pay they can play with
play with cats and we get it for free
yeah you know it's a way I could have
worded that I know thank you
[Music]
oh man we did it we made it the
prediction series is done big shout out
to the piano everybody that came
actually proud that wasn't as loud as I
thought it was going to be here for five
minutes
I'm not saying that it wasn't long I'm
saying I expected like a six six and a
half hour show with four people
for real that's a little to everybody
ran plume dirt you know I'm saying ghost
the whole team she looked everybody that
pulled up in the chat chat was in insane
today they still here 1070 wow this is
this is love man from that last week
yeah last week they thought I was going
to be here last week
you know sorry guys nah it's all good
it's all good so look um I'll make an
announcement after we'll do our intro
Lord attic where can I find people find
you what kids you got going on Sir first
off I wanna I wanna thank all the guests
that we had it was a fantastic time uh
we will be going to La next week too so
uh me and Carl won't be here but I have
recruited kids smooth to host the
reaction and the IOP next week okay so
uh you guys are doing the reaction yeah
okay I will be what I'm gonna do is the
moment the show's over I'm gonna Uber
back to the hotel and join at the hotel
okay uh so that's most likely how that's
gonna happen yo shout out to the chat
yeah head over like it was like 1300
people in the chat man yeah the only
time we've had that many is the
Activision still when that was that was
like 3 000 that day yeah but you know I
appreciate you ever coming through you
know we have we have over a thousand now
hit that like button now like salute hit
the like button the fact that you're
still rocking with us is is amazing and
I like everybody's energy salute to Xbox
salute to everybody with the hold the
line movement that Kings got going is
tremendous Lord solve where can I find
people find what you got going on yeah
man uh I will be coming in hot next week
so I'll be driving back from
Massachusetts so I I will be joining in
Providence so more than likely okay okay
so but get some recruit you know some
reinforcements yeah but I'll be
definitely joining in progress and I'll
definitely be here for the entirety of
the um nice the Whatchamacallit the
Starfield presentation so yeah I mean
shout out to everybody for coming
through this is a good this is a little
bit of a different mix that we usually
have for the for the prediction stuff it
was fun man again I just want to see
these people finally shine man really
really shine yes I'm excited we we'll
see I will be I'll be wearing my whole
design shirt yeah
probably two two and a half hours to do
the in uh the the promotion yeah to the
promo and it took about three hours to
do that starting soon screen oh hold on
heart geek I got a break protocol he
said I'll switch that attic you'll
definitely not want to jump back to the
hotel after the Showcase that's when Fan
Fest unfortunately I'm not in Fan Fest
yeah but let's see what happens nothing
can happen things happen um shout out to
Sean Capri in the chat oh man he said
you started still here you guys deserve
it if you guys want me in Fan Fest go go
on Twitter
we got over a thousand people go on
Twitter right now and say why ain't
addicting Fan Fest and tag everybody
take my place because I'm not in L.A and
that's my co-host that's my that's my
buddy that's my my hashtag one of my
best friends
yo if you I heard you and NY hit me up
on Sean once you get back you know we'll
link what's up but uh I'm sorry that was
it from you uh let me just get the super
chat we got uh minutes five dollar Super
Chat unlikely bold prediction I think we
see GTA 6 at the Showcase with the
marketing going to Xbox with GTA
releasing fall of 2024. huge that would
be huge that would be Bonkers yeah
that's it's all for you that's it that's
it see y'all next week
[Music]
yeah yeah that's okay yeah I broke
purple with him because I'm with the
attic no Lord King the return the smoke
oh like IOP when Kingdom did it too nice
you wasn't you you was on your Square
man I sat there and I watched it and you
know shout out to um Mr Bad Bid And yes
everybody that showed up that uh last
week you know calling everybody it was a
great show um that was you know I always
get full mode because I I watch the show
and I'm answering questions
you talking yes and I have a I have a
tough time during the week because I'm
still playing scenarios nah man I would
have said this man and I would have said
that and yeah but you know so this this
is one of those jobs where you don't
want to miss work you do not want to
miss work so a lot of you guys talk
about oh King you don't play enough
games I play so much games that with my
two hours a day that I do get to play
which is you know maybe I can get three
out
um usually I'm playing a game with a
service or something like that so I
don't get progress for that but right
now this Diablo
um it has me in the sense that um it has
my mind because I went to sleep thinking
about it right and I wanted to do some
other stuff we had family over again
this weekend you know they've been here
this whole weekend
and um I have you know family again so
didn't really get a chance to do
anything couldn't do combat talk last
night definitely couldn't do a combat
talk the house was full of people it's
still here
um and that's why you see me snacking I
don't know when I'm gonna get to eat
but uh sort of uh Fast and the Furious
saw a Spider-Man
so attic and I are still doing certain
stuff uh he has a lot of stuff that he's
catching up on uh preparing for this
week that he's getting ready to leave
and go out with Cog over to Fan Fest oh
well not Fan Fest to E3
in the listening party or whatever
they're doing there and I just want to
say that because of this podcast
and because of all the stuff that we do
get to do it you guys are the reason why
we're able to go to these shows and
bring you back information
um they're going to have video footage
while they're there so it's not just oh
we're just going to California do this
know they're actually going to
California to work it's actually work so
they're going to get information and he
sets up stuff in the background for us
to be continue to work while we're here
for us I had to stay behind me and solve
solve is going to come from work it's
going to rush right back in I'm gonna be
here we're gonna give you a full show
and it's going to be hilarious and I
believe Microsoft will have day moments
this week
I think this is going to be one of those
seminal shows it shows you they can play
in the big pool they are uh where they
supposed to be because a lot of times
they said that you know people say that
they don't act like they belong I think
this is the show that they show you that
they belong in the upperclassmen area
where they're going to start taking the
reins away from PlayStation and I don't
think they give them back they take them
they keep them and from here this is
where the beatings start right I think
it's going to be a one-way beating I
think it's you're going to see a show
that's if it's not a 10 out of 10 it's
going to be a 9 out of 10.
talking about this has been the most
strong the strongest show that I've seen
from Microsoft and they really put the
boot on the neck of the PlayStation
where they left the door open and this
is going to be the moment you look back
in time and said this is when it
happened turn around okay
this is where the uh
oh yeah Sith Lord uh Phil uh comes into
play but hold the line uh if you didn't
get your merch yet and I know a lot of
people
is getting it this week or whatever I'm
gonna have my shirt on my wife got her
shirt everybody's gonna have their
shirts on or whatever and we're just
gonna watch the show we're gonna have a
good time uh try to stay out of the
negativity I know it's fun but you know
just don't call nobody out of their name
and don't make a person that's all right
don't do that you can make all the jokes
with the games and stuff like that just
don't make it personal preach thank you
guys no doubt no doubt Yeah man so you
already heard it again thanks for
everybody for pulling up next week so
addict as he told you we're gonna have
most like a kid and someone who's gonna
host and then but uh Saul will be coming
in hot and King will be there for the
live stream so there will be an ILP live
stream with IOP and friends on the iron
Arlo podcast Channel when it goes live
now it's literally gonna be a Kings
podcast yeah it's gonna be kid get to be
messy without us being you know
so he gonna be on UNT you know he's
gonna be unstoppable
I mean I'm gonna call out I'm gonna call
if there's L's to be taken I'm gonna
call it out but I'm gonna be so mad if
that happens though I will not enjoy it
yeah if it happens but kid will be off
the chain and then again you gotta wear
the general thing for the whole reaction
I got a whole skit a whole bunch of
stuff set up oh he ran such a great time
and then someone said king without
referees oh man yeah they loved it they
love it they're like yeah get that [__]
out of here so look and then for me an
attic we are going to be in La if you're
at summer game Fest pull up we gonna be
there and then we shall be there for the
hopefully the Showcase said yeah yeah
and I have uh I'm gonna try something
new you know because uh we'll try
something new some content some fresh
content that we ain't never done number
four okay or when we get back yeah so
we're gonna we're gonna have to try to
get some footage we're gonna try to get
some access to you guys have that stuff
up in the east coast it's in the house
yes sir we're gonna be in there we're
gonna plump the west and I saw my West
Coast homies and again anybody that's
there please hit me please pull up it
will be fun to see y'all but that's all
I got anybody got anything else before
we get about it here I'm gonna send you
guys over there to level one gaming go
in there uh tell them IOP sent you and
uh you know whenever you can't watch the
stream anymore be sure to uh hit that
like button on your way out but we go
over there man go over there hit that
like button hit that like button level
one system love the fame and the home
exactly and then uh for me Lord stop IOP
uh
not on Twitter this is this is my uh
Capcom ID
this open challenge the single player
with the open challenge ball do it let's
go so for y'all heard that yo this is
rare appearance for song multiplayer
game challenge street fight he's feeling
himself right now what was it what
what's the what's that Lord SOB IOP
you'll find it yeah fine so sure Laura
Savage he want the smoke go let's see
where you can you know what I'm saying
if you can mess with him right now I'm
assuming it's Ken let's be doing oh it's
Katniss
all right so that's all I got anybody
else we good enjoy your Sunday oh my LP
set you
[Music]
foreign
got it we back
GSD getting stuff done five dollar Super
Chat sorry gents you don't know me
personally yet but we will in the future
God bless all right Salud it's fun
we're gonna say that's in peace in this
but he said God bless are we going to
say that love Street before they do it
again all right peace
[Music]
thank you